Hey,
hey, hey.
Heat. Heat.
Oh,
hey.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Hello and welcome back to coverage of
regional qualifi. If you like what
you're seeing here on your screens and
maybe you want to get yourself a little
buy coming into something like an ARQ,
head on down new summer skirmish, get
some refund games in.
>> Yeah, they are so much fun to play in.
Absolutely communitydriven and there's
multiple per set as well if you're
interested. Yeah, little more
competitive than maybe your Nexus
Knight. Kind of if you're looking for
the next step in your journey as a
Riftbound player, definitely something
you can get going. Again, organized play
at Riftbound's got something for
everyone at all levels. We talked about
Nexus Knight, some skirmish kind of your
next step from there. And you know what?
We'll probably casting your games here
as a regional qualifier as we are back
for round number five. Ursa Day, it's
been quite a day already.
>> Yeah, there have been so many great
games. I mean, we got to see Rumble, we
got to see Jinx. I saw there was a Zir
on the last round. very sad that I
didn't get cast it, but so many cool
ones and I'm sure a lot of these were
tested the nexus knights, those summoner
skirmishes and now coming in today
around does seem nice.
>> Yeah, and we were kind of scouring the
top tables kind of between our ads
looking to see what might be coming up
and there are still some pretty spicy
legends undefeated. We'll take a look
though at the prearch metag game or the
preq metag game. was yesterday you could
win a buy and unsurprisingly with no
bests on the line there was a lot of
Draven in this metag game.
>> There was I was walking up and down the
aisles and I mean Draven was everywhere
so was Ireelia and it was really cool to
see the players choose you know what
they thought was the best deck because
one thing that was up on the line for
that pre-rq was if you went undefeated
five and0 I think it is uh you were able
to get your round one by as well. Yeah,
good stuff there. You can see 17 on hope
for the same as Misfortune, which is
quite a lot. Kind of going through the
rest of the metag game. We'll actually
go check in with not just this meta
game, but today as well, we'll get
through the RQ first cuz it's always
interesting to see what might be coming
through. Obviously things change a bit
in a bigger field. 14 is quite a lot.
Same number of Teeos and somehow 13
players decided Lux is what they wanted
to play in the PRQ.
>> Yeah, I think you and I were walking up
and down. We actually saw a Lux versus
Yasuo. They are side by side here, but
that is coincidence we didn't know in
the moment. It was really cool to see
and the one Garen who decided to run it
in the prq
much more confidence than I have.
>> Uh and the fun thing is uh if you know
you don't have to ask who it is.
Everyone knows see that Gar play. You
may even see them on stream if they go
for the best of once again. Here is the
day one metag game here though for the
original qualify at Las Vegas and very
similar actually as far as numbers. I
thought Ezreal would have a bit higher
representation but Kaiser still sitting
in spot number three as far as
representation. Yeah, it's interesting
to see them flip positions because PRQ
Ezreal was in third place, Kais' now
just moving up with about 20 more
players and with it being day one met
Metagame, we are looking more at best of
so even though Draven is at a lower
percentage, I do think it's largely
because of that those best.
>> Yeah, makes sense. I mean Draven
certainly still the best deck and
certainly the most represented deck. So
alongside Aurelia makes sense that
they're the majority of the metag game.
But even just looking down, there's
Azian and Fiora all with similar
numbers. 45 Hobbles have registered Lux,
which is an unbelievable number of
people. The fact that there are more Lux
players than Ahri players is very
interesting to me.
>> Yeah, I'm not fully sure uh the
decision. I think Ari is so much fun. I
actually played her a lot during set one
and I do like her ability where the
leader does minus one to all those
attacking when you're defending. But Rex
Eye is one that I really really love. Uh
the broodmother I think it is.
>> We'll have a look at what else is going
on here because the numbers are going to
get a little thinner as we go down.
Renard still with healthy representation
42. MF we've seen already on stream at
40 seems to be a decent number over
those. What else sticking out to me? Not
too many Teimos. A decent amount of
Annies and of course we've uh I don't
know the number. We've octupled the
number of Garens from the preq with
eight now trying to v for their best
slot which you got to be careful for cuz
one player has won the mode so far.
Yeah, it's interesting. Garen multiplied
by eight, but Voli Bear only by two. Who
would have thought? But so many cool
decks. I was actually surprised that
Misfortune I think was only uh I think
like 20 of them even though it got
second place.
>> Yeah, it feels like we've seen a lot of
other Aurora variants. This is actually
a really cool vari. This is comparing
kind of what you were talking about,
right? The amount of Draven in the
precute versus day one here. And there
is less here on day one thanks to those
bests. In general though, the numbers do
seem to cleanly convert pretty well. In
fact, for the most part, the top five
decks, they're staying the top five most
represented decks, even with the numbers
shifting down slightly.
>> Yeah, it's so interesting to see. I
mean, that they are still the most
represented. It does make sense.
Overall, a lot of these players do want
to get a lot of those games in. And top
64 still does qualify you, I believe,
for the nationals, um, if you make it.
So, if you can get top 64, sometimes it
doesn't matter the best of. You just
want to be able to get a lot of wins in.
>> Yeah. kind of seeing again like the
number of Arian Lux players like shoots
up at the RQ as they want to make sure
you know maybe V for that spot. Volar
actually not a bad choice if you're
looking for a best of not too many in
the RQ slots and kind of down the bottom
there alongside Garren Lein another deck
that didn't expect to see too much of
but a lot of fun stuff here and we've
seen a pretty good amount of diversity
on stream so far even though we have
seen kind of the metag game players. Uh
so I'm excited to see what else we have
cuz our first few rounds and even the
rounds we've had on camera since we've
been gone have been pretty awesome to
see. Yeah, still so much diversity and
we are already up to round five. It's
going to be really interesting to see
how it continues, but I know walking the
tables, there's so many different
leaders in just like those top tables.
So, I'm excited to see what we get.
>> Yeah, at least early on enough that we
still have quite a few undefeated
players on a host of different legends.
Let's talk about our upcoming feature
match and have a look at some deck list
because they are two similar decks, not
necessarily the same. We're going to
start here with a player that should be
familiar to the Legend of Terror
audience, IO. He's on Ezreal.
>> Yeah, I actually was talking to him
briefly. I think yesterday during the
PRQs about his list, he is going down to
two Vexes. I was talking to him briefly
about like in set one a lot of times if
you wanted to be able to mulligan away
some of those cards that you haven't in
your starting hand, you wanted to run at
least three because you couldn't draw as
much through your deck. But with Codshot
now and these miracle lists, we are
seeing sometimes our entire deck. So now
he is able to go he said that down to
two vexes which is really interesting.
>> Yeah, I were not necessarily happy with
their play yesterday. Uh I was a player
that if you're in the Twitter sphere in
these new spaces especially for LOL Rift
found you got a lot of takes uh from
them and uh very wonderful person very
skilled pilot not surprised to see them
still undefeated here. We'll take a look
at the other list as well cuz it's a a
list that's kind of similar and I think
a player that people are definitely
going to recognize LGQ has made it all
the way from Italy here in Las Vegas.
Yeah, I mean he just won the Bolognia
regionals. Uh I think it's a very
similar list from last week as I
mentioned. This is a three Vex versus
the two that we watched earlier, but
there are a couple differences largely
in that sideboard I believe. Uh we have
Dr. Mundo, which I think is really
interesting. Dr. Mundo is so difficult
to kill and it's one of the big
differences in the sideboard. I'm not
sure how it'll play in this matchup per
se, but I know it helps up helps in
different matchups like Kai'Sa and
things like Yeah, definitely those three
pick pockets did good work for Allan in
the his other SU mirror that he had to
play in Voluon. We'll see how it fares
here as you are going to get down to the
feature match and watch two extremely
talented players play what I can only
imagine is a pretty complicated mirror
match.
>> Yeah, this is probably going to be a
master class here. So exciting. And we
are starting at Void Gate in Sigil of
the Storm.
>> All right, so Ako on the left of your
screen on Ezreal Proto Explorer. Alan
Ziku, the winner of the last regional
qualifier pretty literally less than a
week ago at this point. Flying all the
way in from Europe here to NA. See if he
can't do it again.
>> Yeah, it's time. I mean, I can't imagine
the jet lag you would have. Uh I'm from
East Coast. It was a large enough
difference to Italy, much less if you
are all the way on the west coast here.
So that is it's crazy to see him playing
here. Already 4 and0. Both these players
are fantastic job coming in here.
>> Yep. So we're going to start things off.
Voidgate the battlefield of choice here
for AO and it is Sigil of the Storm the
opener here for Allen as uh stack deck
and open things up. Pick a card, shuffle
them up and put them on the bottom. I do
expect these players to play quite
quickly. This is definitely a match up
that can go pretty late and both these
players are very clean, very good
technical players and they know that
this deck can go to time especially in
the mirror. So they're going to want to
play as quickly as possible in the hour
round timer.
>> Yeah, I think these battlefields are
really interesting. We do have void gate
which both of these players are going to
have to watch out for. They are both
running damage spells. I'm thinking the
Bellow's breath, but also a couple
different ones. But if you're in
voidgate, when damage spells come down
or damage abilities, uh then it is plus
one. So you have to keep that math in
mind. It may not be as easy as you would
think. And then sit of the storm, it
does cost a rune to go into it. And so
it kind of persuades you not to go there
at least immediately.
>> Yeah, it's interesting because again,
both these decks are running three seals
of discord. In fact, the fact that Allan
has one so early is a very good sign for
Samir cuz this is an extremely good card
as Io playing his third the third stack
deck of this game. Just filtering
through the cards as quickly as they
can.
>> Uh Ezreal of course a pretty good
kickoff here for Allen as well.
>> There's a seal on the other side.
>> The seal into Ezreal is so nice and
we're going to have to see if Akaido can
get it as well. It just makes it so easy
to go from seal, pay for the Ezreal, and
then from there, Ezreal will help you
pay for those later uh cards with the
additional costs.
>> Yeah, somewhat innocuous, but second
seal there into the Ezreal. So, again,
paying all these power costs nice and
early, and seal is kind of the thing
that powers these decks in many ways.
You want to do so many different things
with power. You don't really make gold,
but once you get through your deck, you
can just constantly cycle through your
cards. So, things like cold shot,
especially with Ezreal in play, get
very, very cheap when you have a seal,
>> for sure. It reads one power, but with
with Ezreal, it is going to decrease
those additional costs. In this case,
that's the repeat cost and it's just one
more power, but now zero.
>> Yep. And so just have to pay the first
power basically on the cult chart. Seal
does that basically for free after
you've invested that initial bit of uh
of power into it. And uh you get to look
through a lot of cards and draw a lot of
cards very swiftly for the low low cost
of one seal tap.
>> Yeah. And that does not feel bad. I
mean, you it's almost this like
permanent resource if you have seals. In
later games, we'll have to look out for
uh pickpocket, but they are both in the
side decks for both of these players.
So, game one, these seals are pretty
safe.
>> Yeah, certainly. So, and this game feels
like relatively important one to win cuz
uh both there's a lot I think I think
this is the game where players are most
likely to see the most of their deck. I
think it speeds up somewhat in the
postboard games depending on how the
positioning can go. So it's cold shot on
the other side after double raven bloom
student and as you kind of notice a very
different pace of game from what we've
seen. Players have just not committed to
battlefields yet. Just no need to score
points right now. Just want to keep
sculpting, keep getting through their
deck.
>> Yeah, I think that's something that was
really interesting to see especially in
Bolognia. We were watching the few the
actual mirror match with these like
mirror Ezreals and they stayed off the
off the battlefields for a large part
until they had more units in base and
could spread out their units cuz if you
you know just put them all in one
battlefield or all one base, then
Bellows can get a lot of value.
>> And you can see Bellows did exactly that
taking out both of the students in the
backline. Voidgate not needed just
repeated there thanks to Ezreal and a
little bit of initial blue power
committed there by AO. Believe Aico is
running three bellows breath in the main
if I recall the deck list correctly. So
definitely prioritizing the power of
that card which makes sense. You'd have
a battlefield like void gate.
>> Mhm. For sure. Bridget Touch is going to
finish it off. Ezro did get that two
damage on him as well. But he has three
might so he survives until a might
decreasing card like Frigid Touch.
>> Actually saw that exact combination of
cards be very good for Allen in his win.
So makes sense that things are working
out. Ezreal is going to finally take a
trip to the void gate and get the first
point on the board.
>> Yeah. Now that there's no Ezreal on
board and Allen's EQ doesn't have any
other units set up, this Ezreal is a
little bit more safe. We do want to keep
Ezreal alive just because otherwise we
won't have someone to discount those
cards like we want.
>> Wages pretty good card. Deals three
damage to a unit at a battlefield and
gives you a gold. And uh turns out as
well got exactly three might as uh Alani
plays a very special gold token. This is
a uh something that was made for the
Polish community I believe in Riftbound.
It's a little porro holding I believe a
Polish gold coin of some kind. It is
adorable.
>> Yeah, they have some really adorable
accessories. I love the rune sleeves as
well. Um, but to note just because I
mean Kaido is laying out his
>> trash pile so well. We can see he is at
nine cards almost where Rosa is a
zerocost unit to play. So, a lot of
discounts to watch out for here. We
haven't had any battering ram counters
just yet, but uh we'll see some
discounts come down, I'm sure.
>> All right. Unfortunately, Allen has to
trade out his gold zurgen for one.
That's a more feature match appropriate,
but I'm glad we get to see it on stream
at least temporarily. Stack deck going
to go ahead and enter the chain. And I
do appreciate that AO is fanning out the
trash quite so neatly. Makes our job
easier, especially again things like
Fizz, which these decks left to lean on.
>> Oh yeah, for sure. Fizz is such a great
card in this deck. When you play Fizz,
you're allowed to play one of those
spells from your discard pile uh with an
energy cost no more than three. So,
there's so many options. We've talked
about it today. There's so many two
costs and below, but also there's some
that are just completely free as well
John
>> and you do have to pay your power cost
and Fizz does cost the power, but again
between the seals and the Ezreal, a lot
of these things can get pretty heavily
discounted. There's another cold shot
here from Allen. Going to keep on
digging through the deck very quickly.
Chooses a card so quickly I couldn't
even see what the two choices were. And
it's going to be same again. Keeping
them close to his hand. Allan going to
not give away any extra information. Not
even to us here at coverage.
>> How dare he. There's seal number three.
Has to feel good to be the first one to
hit that benchmark.
>> Rosa.
>> There is Rosa. I didn't see how much of
a discount we got. I can't tell too
much, but it is going to be nice to get
that six might unit down. The only unit
currently on either battlefields. And
with six might, I mean, it's going to be
difficult to knock him out before he can
take a point.
>> Yeah, looks like Allan had to pay three
there, I believe, cuz there seven cards
as Allen also laid out his grave. Oh,
that is very nice. that of course again
cost the power but once more we can see
the power of seal of discard and this is
uh Allen's only copy of this card you
see a lot of these kind of purple shells
they want to dig through the decks
pretty aggressively a lot of them play
three two to three raster right it's a
card they're really looking to draw for
and play a lot's like I only need one
I'm going to be able to play it for the
rest of the game if I need to by
recycling it so why would I ever need
more than one of this card
>> yeah I think that's so interesting to me
that uh this game enables right because
a lot of these costs are recycled even
the fizz you recycle the spell after you
play it. So then when you're doing these
recycling, you're getting them back into
your deck, able to play them again
later. And especially when you're
cycling one at a time, you can kind of
start getting an idea of the ordering.
>> Yeah. Even if they're just a couple at a
time, you'll know, right? If it's
randomly two cards on the bottom, you'll
be able to keep track of that. And I can
tell you, both of these players are
keeping track of their recycles. I don't
know if they're also keeping track of
each other's recycles, but they're going
to be very aware of what their stack
looks like at the bottom of the deck
after all this recycling. And if you're
maybe newer to TCGs, this is something
that's just generally very powerful. Not
just knowing what's coming up, which a
game like Riftbound does enable because
you are putting cards on the bottom
pretty frequently, especially in decks
like this. But you can see the players
like fanning out their graveyards. These
are extensions of the player's hands. So
it's like not only is Fizz giving you
access to all the cards in your
graveyard for the most part, but
eventually Fizz is going to give you
access to them again when they go to the
bottom of your deck.
>> Yeah, that is a great point and it's so
cool to see it. Uh I'm really excited to
see how this continues to develop. But I
will say it's one point that makes this
I mean nice. A lot of these players have
learned how to know what card is in what
order, but you also can take notes if
needed in this game.
>> Yep, you absolutely can. And uh we can't
see the players notepads are off to the
side somewhere with the frame, but I'm
sure they're taking some as morbid
return. Not a card you always see that
often, but a very nice oneup can get you
back a unit. And again with Fizz being
able to recurse spells so consistently.
I feel like something I'm going to say a
lot in this matchup. uh kind of gives
you access to uh the rest of your grade,
right? If we consider that Fizz accesses
basically all your spells cuz they
pretty much all cost three under three
energy, three energy or less, then mo
return as a spell gives you access to
your units and now all of a sudden Alan
has access to every card in his
graveyard.
>> Yeah, it's so it's going to be so nice.
we are able to keep that going. But
there's also like a nice loop later in
these games between Morbid Return and
Fizz because you are going so much
through your deck that sometimes you can
get almost like a deck out uh situation.
In Riftbound, it's not an automatic loss
unlike some games, but your opponent
does get a point. But between War Return
and Fizz, you're actually able to kind
of keep cards in your deck depending how
many cards that really is though.
>> And I think that's a good point cuz when
the decks get low, and they certainly
can. And I know players in these match
ups often there's like an invert
timelines running around sometimes as
well. You do not want to hit burn up,
not because your opponent necessarily
gets a point, but because you have to
shuffle your entire trash back into your
deck. And when these players are careful
carefully curating the cards that are in
their graveyard and on the bottom of
their decks and trying to basically
sculpt the perfect deck that they can
continually reuse, you don't want to
miss what happened. You don't want to
jumble that up by shuffling everything
back in. So, you do have to be careful.
>> Yeah. Yeah, and you know, you mentioned
earlier it's okay to shuffle one or two,
but that's you know, 50/50, I know
what's coming next,
>> but when it's 39 cards, 38 cards,
there's it's just a random deck again.
Uh, which, you know, and these decks you
don't want, but both of these players
are starting to, you know, develop their
boards again. They're getting to that
point where they're going to have to,
they kind of seem to like fight it out
in short little bursts, like who can
wipe each other's boards, take the
points, and then you got to rebuild
again. Yeah, there's kind of this this
classic adage in TCGs where in in
matchups like this where it's very slow,
there's kind of a lot of back and forth.
You kind of want to win the resource
worth first and foremost. So, you don't
really usually want to be the player to
commit first because if you if you
commit, then you kind of trade back and
forth with your opponent with all your
spells or whatever you have. Typically,
the player that gets to awaken again and
then go once more is going to be the
player that's going to find an edge. And
these are the kind of matchups where
little edges really matter. So, you can
see both players happily building up
their boards. Last rights getting played
here for Iicado which is a key component
of how much recursion this deck has
access to and then we are going to get
over to the battlefield cuz again Arasa
going to get a conquer here able to play
something out of the trash. Don't think
I see a unit but Lost Rights is going to
trigger it. There's something and hey
it's an Ezreal coming back for more.
>> Yeah, we do love discount so it makes
sense that we're bringing back Ezreal.
Uh we did have to recycle two for it is
a part of the cost but it's a cost.
Akaido and this deck is very happy to
pay
>> especially with all those seals. Oh yes,
sorry. The recycling part. Yes, you're
happy to pay the power costs are not so
relevant when you able to ramp up some
seals. But yes, it's funny that the last
rights drawback where you have to
recycle cards from your trash, which
makes sense because the design intention
I assume is that if you move stuff out
of your trash, you're not going to be
able to replay it indefinitely. Well,
turns out recycling cards from your
trash, putting them back in your deck
actually in this deck is just an
advantage
>> in increments of two at least.
>> Yes, in increments of two. In slow
enough increments that you can slowly
sculpt your deck while still getting
access to your graveyard. So there is
this balance of how many cards do I have
in deck? How many cards do I have in my
graveyard? What do my rosters cost? What
else is happening? How many resources
does my opponent have? There's a lot
that these players are going to be
calculating here. But Raven Bloom
students is going to kick things off.
And again, there's been a lot of yap, a
lot of back and forth. It's now point
number three for Akaido. This again is
not a quick mirror match.
>> Yeah, it's going to be a slow slow burn
to those eight points for sure. And
Raven Bloom student to me has always
been an interesting card. uh when you
play a spell, it gets plus one and you
can have I mean that stack up to pretty
hefty numbers in some of these game in
some of these turns. So excited to see
how Raven Bloom looks. It looks really
tiny as a two, but it can be a lot
bigger.
>> Yeah, interesting as well. Aro put a Vex
in the trash here.
>> Oo,
>> definitely, you know, I would expect to
be pretty good actually in this matchup.
Again, we talk about cost reduction
being good on something as Vex gives you
that in combat and also making your
opponent's stuff in the mirror cost more
also seems quite powerful. So maybe
looking at as a last rights target here
with that Rasa potentially going to hold
at the sigil.
>> Yeah, Rasa if we get that hold off will
be able to choose one of those units
potentially. So while we are able to
discard it now, we could still bring it
back later. Uh so that is really really
nice. And then Ezreal, while we did have
to discard one, we get that two draw and
we can widen our hand even more.
Sometimes your hands in this match can
almost be a little mini deck in itself.
>> Oh yeah, hands are massive. access to
your grave is massive. Like nothing is
ever truly lost in in in this kind of
matchup. Again, players at some point
will be able to get access to whatever
cards they want, whether you're in the
deck, in their hand, or in their trash.
Just a matter of how much time is that
going to take as Allen going to finally
kind of pull the trigger here on a
little play. Try and clear off I think
the backline as Ezreals are going to get
taken some damage and then perhaps have
a fridged touch to follow up here to
shrink them.
>> Let's see. It could also be stupify. We
only need one. It does look like one
stupify is coming down, but both
Ezreal's assuming that is the Yeah, it's
the base do have damage on them. One
more Ezreal here. Will we have another
one? And it is a second stupify, which
is all it takes for the Ezreals to be
sent back to the trash. But if we can't
clear out this Rasa, one of them could
be back as soon as his own turn.
>> Yeah. So obviously Rasa is as big as
each other as both players have access
to the card. But with the shovel, it is
plus two. So eight might currently for
Arcada on the southern battlefield. But
Fizz can maybe shore up that as well. So
Allan's going to have plenty of options
here. And again, Allan is just not
worried about committing too early.
Right now, keep sculpting. Get my deck
to a point where I can start really
refining what's in there. Yes, AO is
applying some pressure, which is good if
you can ever push your opponent to a
point where you're forcing them to make
decisions when they don't want to make
them before they're kind of ready to
really go for it. That's a good thing
for you cuz you can often leverage your
opponent having a bad turn and then
going back and trying to find a way to
win. So applying some pressure is good,
but I'll tell you, three points is just
not a lot in this match up. There's
plenty of game left to play as it looks
like Fizz and Rasa are going to rumble
into the bottom bottom lane.
>> Yeah, it is going to be nine might. We
do though have two runes up which as
we've said it can be so many different
things. One of them though however is
going to be that stupify. We are now
currently trading. It is an eight versus
an eight. But Allen's EQ's own stupify
is going to come down back to that one
might difference.
>> Yep. So a point ahead right now and uh
they're going to win the war. Looks like
Ras are going to trade off cuz again
damage is still being dealt. So even
though the Rasa and the last rights are
unattached from each other and Rasa goes
back to the bin, Allen's going to grab
his first point of the game and we're
going to pass it on back here.
>> Yeah, we do get a hold point, but we
don't have that same drawback as the Lax
Rights bringing back another unit. Um so
we are up to I believe four then from on
Akaido's side.
>> What does he have in hand though? I
mean, he's got probably a lot to um that
he has access to. Wouldn't be It looks
like I could see an Ezreal there. I'm
not like fully sure it is slightly off
screen. Uh but we will have to see.
Looks like he's quickly just making sure
his deck is big enough to play out his
turn.
>> Yeah, if you just want to look in the in
the player cams at home and just kind of
see the size of the player's hands, like
the thickness, you can kind of tell.
There's a lot of cards in these hands.
Allen just played three superfires and
they each replace themselves. So, both
players are loaded up as far as
resources go. But Allan did have to tap
a little low here. So AO should be able
to find something else to play. Have to
imagine though that was hoping to set up
some sort of last rights uh play. Maybe
that Vex, maybe something else. But if
we can get access to that again, conquer
that battlefield that the Fizz is
currently occupying. Then of course that
Rasa can come back at a pretty good
discount. There is currently more than
10 cards in that trash. So you do have
to do be a little careful cuz again you
have to recycle first for the last ride.
So have to put that into your
calculations when trying to figure out
how cheap is Rasa at the moment.
>> Yeah, that makes so much sense.
Honestly, sometimes when I have hands
that big, I almost lose which cards are
there sometimes. So hopefully we'll have
every piece we can find. It looks like a
Fizz is going to come down. So we're
going to be able to recycle one of these
spells and use it. Looks like it's going
to be that fight or flight to bring
Raven Bloom back to our base. It's going
to go that same spell is going to go to
the bottom of the deck. But because it's
ready, it could still see play into that
other battlefield. We'll have to find
out.
>> So there was 12 cards in the trash, I
believe, when I counted before. I'm
going to count again quickly. 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11. Now, last round's obviously
going to mean you have to recycle two,
so it's going to be at nine. So, Ross
are not currently only one power. We
only have to play one more card to get
it there.
>> Yeah, and that's not too bad. Also,
there's other cards we may want to do.
Maybe Ezro to discount stuff. Uh we
could also potentially see Vex somewhere
here in the future, but we will have to
conquer something to get off this
ability. And it is going to be going up
into that Fizz. Four versus three. We
win the showdown. One of the really nice
things about uh fighter fighting your
raven back to base just kind of as a
move uh lets it stay ready so you can
attach the last rights and then shovel
on over to the sigil does not only give
you a point but gives you the ability to
play a unit from your trash. So which
one is it going to be cuz again Rasa not
fully free at this point but I got to
say it feels like one is still a pretty
low number but looks like Ezreal going
to be the choice here. Again so powerful
both the draw texts and the passive text
really power this deck. Yeah, that is so
nice here with that Ezreal being able to
draw two more cards. Depends what we
want to discard though. Obviously, it is
going to be Arcane Shift it looks like,
but uh I mean again you repay the replay
these fizzes and you're able to play it
from your discard pile. It doesn't feel
bad to discard these spells.
>> No, not at all. Again, you kind of get
everything back at the end of the day.
Stupify can hit this easy.
>> Looks like it's going to activate uh
Ezreal here. Oh, draw a card from
Stupify. Sorry. Looks like Ezreal maybe
got to awaken there as well or get ready
there as well.
>> Yeah, we are digging for something here
with that stupify. It looks like it's
potentially maybe this Bellows or
something else, but Bellows is going to
be able to Oh, it just Yes.
>> Yep. Is Bellows in range.
>> Yep. Really nicely done there for Aro.
Pretty cleanly clearing that Ezreal out
with two cards. One of them replaces
itself to dupy and you get to draw a
card for easy. So, doesn't feel all that
bad as the third seal does hit the board
for both Ezreal players now. And Aada's
going to play one more thing.
>> Let's see. And it is going to be another
Rasa. You mentioned earlier, Alan EQ
only playing one was going to have to
find some way to bring back his Rosa,
but ours, we have multiple. He doesn't
need to come back right now.
>> Yeah, seems decent in this kind of spot.
Again, Aada the one applying a little
bit more pressure for now. Five points
is a good lead, but again, no lead is
safe against Q. We'll see if able to
navigate his way out of this. So again,
plenty of options in the hand. Plenty of
options in the bin. In fact, currently
flicking through the graveyard, I
believe is Allen. So, probably has a
Fizz locked and loaded here. And oh,
it's a Vex instead here. The first Vex
sighting of the RQ for us at least on
stream.
>> Yeah, very very exciting. Vex was I
would say almost the MVP of Bolognia.
Uh, I mean, Ezreal has, it's not a
surprise to be seen, but having this
addition of Vex where when in a
showdown, spells of your own are
decreased by one cost and your opponents
are increased by one cost really just
brought home brought home the bacon for
Allen's EQ. Uh, and now we're seeing
more of it being played, including in
this mirror match, obviously.
>> Yeah, it feels like Allen kind of
setting up to do something pretty big in
the following turn or two. A is up to
six, which does feel a little bit
threatening right now. Potentially a
hold can be threatened if we go to
seven. Potentially a double conquer from
either this point or from another point.
And looks like that hold also did mean
the shovel is online. So for holding
there, not only get the point, but get
to play this rasa at a very steep
discount. It cost exactly one exhaust of
your seal of discord.
>> That is so nice compared to the written
price of 10 energy, one
one power. Um, but we are just like
getting such a wide base here. We're
really getting developed and set up for
some of these future turns. And we're
going to try to hopefully probably find
a way to deal with this Vex before it
makes its way to a battlefield.
>> And Raven Bloom going to go back home.
Already scored a point at that
battlefield. No need to do it again.
Seal going to get popped here for
>> Here's Rasa once again back to base. And
it looks like
>> I think AO is deciding, you know what,
six points is enough. I'm going to try
and play for the double conquer on the
next turn cuz what do you realistically
get done if you go to the void gate and
get the seventh point
>> 100% and to some extent it kind of opens
up a you know the worry of could I get
hit with something now it does look like
an EQ will scoop with that
>> and we're going to game two this is the
spice though that Akaido brought and
it's going to be that Mariah Spire
>> Mariah Spire
>> Marai Spire there we go versus Obelisk
of power
>> Mariah Spire. I'm going to try I'm going
to really rack my brain at this point. I
believe Mariah Spire is when you hold
here when you control this repeat cost
you one less.
>> Let's see. I'm going to bring it up in
front of me real quick so that I can
find out what it does. Uh
>> yes, you I think you are correct here.
>> When you control this battlefield,
friendly repeat cost one less. Thank
you, production. putting it over there
to tilt my head sideways because
unfortunately the card viewer does not
have orange for battlefields which makes
a lot of sense. Want cards to be the
right the way they are up 99% of the
time. Obisca power though is going to
channel an extra in for each play here
and Allen is off to the races on the
play here in this game. So Ezreal
already this one of the really nice
things about playing with Obelisk even
on the play or draw. You do get to put
Ezreal down nice and early and uh even
better news seal of discord for Allen
already on the table.
>> That is so nice. Both these players
>> were already playing fast for this deck,
I would say, game one. And it already
took 29 minutes for game one. So, I
mean, Allen's EQ is going to want to
play even faster here. He needs to fit,
oh, sorry, 24 minutes for that game one.
He's going to play even faster here cuz
he needs to win two more to win the
round.
>> I have full confidence these players can
finish the round in time. Also, I feel
like they're the kind of players that
they're playing the stack. They know
each other. They're like they have
enough respect to want to play at the
appropriate speed to try and get how
long it can take
>> for sure. It's just such a long match up
for sure. It's an intricate one.
>> Very, very intricate. A stack decks
being exchanged across either sides of
the table. Each player going to select a
card, put two on the bottom after
looking at the top three. And Raven
Bloom student is going to be the first
unit deployed here for AO's. Cold shot
is going to look real good with this
seal and this Ezreal. And already a
second seal is in play. Alance Q is just
zooming off here in game two.
>> Yeah, we are getting so many seals here.
here is going to set us up really
nicely. I'd be interested to see what
cards did ended up getting sideboarded
in. Both of them did have Pickpocket in
their sideboards and that can be used to
destroy these seals that Alz and Akaido
are both playing, but Alan EQ is the
only one with them currently on the
board.
>> Yeah, I'm pretty confident both players
have brought all copies of pickpocket
they have access to in for this matchup.
Destroying Seal is just such a good bit
of value. Again, it is really the engine
that powers the resources for this deck.
Even though eventually you will get them
back as as we've talked about many
times, there's lots of ways to res to
recycle cards in this deck. Getting them
taken out early is not something you
want to see as we are going to be
zooming through a judge call. So, don't
worry if the uh the time dilation starts
to look a little funky on your screen.
That is completely normal.
>> Yeah, I think it's honestly really great
that we're able to do that. So, we'll
have to we'll see that speed up here in
a second, but it is going to be really
interesting to see what they do here. I
mean, I think Maris Fire is great for
both of these decks. Yep.
>> Uh, obviously, maybe sometimes you don't
play this more against an opponent who
can't use it as well, but when you're
already playing Ezreal, maybe if your
opponent has that Ezreal and you don't,
it's going to be really nice to get back
into the game, I think.
>> Yeah, it can be a bit of a double-edged
sword. Certainly one of the things about
bringing uh these kind of tech
battlefield foods that are good for your
deck, but obviously you expect to play
some level of mirror at this event cuz
there is a decent amount of Ezreal in
the field. Stack deck again here for
Allen going to be looking at a few more
cards. Again, both players happy to
sculpt here in the early game. Lots of
cold shots, especially when you have an
Ezreal and a seal in play. And stack
deck has just been honestly one of the
best uh filtering cards for in Riftbound
since Origins. It's been this card shot
to the moon instantly. Every deck wanted
to play this card that had the access to
it in purple. Yeah, I every single
purple deck loves Caldot. It'll be
interesting. I mean, we already saw how
well it's done in Bolognia. It's
continuing to do so great in this this
regional as well. It's just so many
purple decks. So, we'll have to see if
Kaido can find his own seals and maybe
his own Ezreal. But with Raven Bloom is
going into Marai could potentially
decrease some of these cards as well.
>> Off to the spire here for the student.
That's going to be the first point once
again to AO. I wonder if Aico feels like
got to be a bit more aggressive in this
matchup. We know Allen is very patient
as a player. This deck is again designed
to really control the game to play as
late as possible to get access to your
one-offs consistently. Basically solve
any problem you can you can think of
given a long enough time horizon. So I
think is saying you know what I don't
want to give you too long.
>> Yeah, especially since he already has I
think those seals in place. He
definitely has a bit better on the
resource front. Um, and Akaido obviously
has a lot of those same tools, but he
hasn't been able to get to them yet.
>> Yeah, Stupify here. Looks like there's
going to be a follow-up, you have to
imagine, here for Ezreal.
>> And Superfy again.
>> Keep on drawing cards.
>> We're looking for our pieces.
>> Drawing a card for Ezreal again. Has
targeted something twice. They do get to
draw a card off of the legend exhaust
ability as well. Something that we
actually didn't see that much in this
matchup so far, but is something that is
uh nice is you get to kind of, you know,
anytime you do things your deck already
wants to do, every now and then you get
to draw an additional card, which is uh
some of the sweetest words in any card
game is draw a card. My favorite word
certainly,
>> for sure. And all you have to do for
Ezreal to get a draw is to choose enemy
units or gears twice in your turn,
which, you know, isn't the hardest thing
to do. And especially in these decks
where you're stupifying, you're
bellowing there. These are all choices,
right? or chooses in this game uh since
it's kind of a keyword here and so it is
going to be so nice to get that draw
hopefully find some of these pieces
we're looking for we are going to hard
bargain this wages of pain raven bloom
student is our only unit that we have we
have to protect it
>> and this is so nice a holding this here
this hard bargain repeat cost one less
and that is exactly the amount of rune
that AO had left and exactly the amount
that Allen doesn't have cuz he cannot
cover two twice effectively had to pay
forward to not get that spell counted
unfortunately didn't have the option Now
students even bigger and better. It's
still on the table for Aada.
>> Yeah, that is so nice. And it's going to
stay for the entire turn now. Uh so now
you don't even just have to deal with a
two my guy. It's I think three
>> singularity till they've been there for
Allen. Kind of a I mean these units
aren't so big that you want to
singularity them away. Allan of course
again on a long enough time horizon will
have access to these units but kind of
like a oh that's a bit scary. like what
other cards are in your hand that you
want to keep more than this spell it
could potentially uh do pretty big
damage to boards of almost any size that
ADA could build. Even something like
Rasa can be shot down by Singularity or
at least get it close enough. Yeah,
maybe that's one of the reasons that
Akaido is actually keeping a bloom. I
would say obviously that if he's got a
good enough hand, he's going to want to
load up his board no matter what. But
while he's still trying to find his
pieces, playing Singularity, you have to
shoot two different guys and Raven Bloom
is at a one right now. Uh, and but here
comes Fizz. We're finally finding our
pieces and Bellow from the trash pile.
Going to be able to deal two to this
Ezreal and Mariah kind of acting as the
Ezreal ability here.
>> Yeah, I think it's free to touch. Yeah,
only didn't repeat that Bella's breath
cuz even though the spire reduces it, it
doesn't take the power cost away and
there's not enough blue power in AO's uh
runes right now. So, use the one there
and then our frid touch to sink it down
below with the damage already marked on
it and easy way to kill the Ezreal.
Again, Ezreal, you get a lot of value
when you play it because you get to draw
cards immediately. But both halves of
the card in the sense, both the the
onplay ability and the passive text are
so powerful that it is very much worth
killing them efficiently when you can.
as wages of pain finally finds its mark.
I'm going to take out that student.
>> That is going to be very nice for Alonz
getting that uh getting the Raven Bloom
out of Marai. We are going to be looking
though for Ezreal obviously on Akaido's
side especially now that we don't have
that same effect.
>> Gets a draw from Ezreal here as well
thanks to that. Waiters already taking
out the Raven Bloom student. Dupy is
card number two. Aimed at that Fizz and
you have to think that maybe another
small damage spell in the future here
for this Fizz as it's already been
reduced by one. Also Allen's just
cycling it to draw a card and then
drawing for Ezreal. That's also fine.
Fizz doesn't necessarily need to be
removed here on Allen's side, but he
does clearly want access to more cards.
So happy to kind of cycle a stupify here
potentially as it looks like stack deck,
not even wages going to come out here.
So Fizz looks like it's going to live
for now, but Allen is valuing the
filtering more at this stage. Yeah, he's
looking for something obviously with
that. Uh going through a bit more of his
deck and will be able to choose two to
go to the bottom of his deck as well,
getting it roughly in the order that he
would like. And we'll have to see if
he's found all the pieces. But we are
currently just at one rune versus two or
something like that for Akaido's turn.
And it looks like we are going to stack
deck again, getting three more cards.
Choose one.
>> I I love this by the way. Uh AO is just
awakening while Allen is resolving the
spell. This is the kind of thing you
need to do in order to play this kind of
match up efficiently. They both know
that nothing's going on here. Nothing's
happening out of order. Ako's just like,
I'm going to start my turn while you're
picking cards because we have matches to
play and I know we're not going to
finish them if we don't shortcut a
little bit here and try and speed up the
pace of play. So, looks like I is going
to get access to more points here.
Again, Allan has been
>> pretty much nonchalant about not wanting
the points in the early stages, not
needing them at least as the first seal
finally lands here for AO. As we kind of
talked about, this is a a way that deck
gets powered. uh you do have to invest
the initial power, but kind of once you
do that and the seals stay there,
especially as seal allows you to play
more seals, you kind of eventually get a
larger room base while still being able
to pay the power cost that really power
this very power- hungry deck.
>> Yeah, and it I mean it is pretty late in
the game to see these seals come down.
Allen ZQ already at two just to like
point out how different it is. We're
multiple turns into this game. I think
almost 10 minutes into the match and
we're only getting the first one for
Akaido.
>> Yep. Shovel happening again though. Fizz
is going to pick up the shovel, go
digging over at the spire, get a point,
and get Raven Bloom student back from
the bin. Trash not too filled here for
Akaido. So Rasa is not going to really
be on uh an option for a little while as
I think just peeled the one Rasa and
that trash is very stacked. Cold shot
going to make it even more so here. No
Ezreal, no problem. Just taps both the
seals to pay for the spell.
>> Yeah, that is going to be so nice EQ at
least. Uh but more cards to see and more
cards to select for our hand.
we're just going to get to cherry pick
the perfect hand to win or hopefully
take this game.
>> It's so powerful because the repeat on
cold shot means that not only do you get
to do a bunch of filtering, but you know
this now, you know, effectively free, we
can say with these seals that you have
to invest, but this effectively free
spell at this stage of the game. It only
selects more cards, you just get to draw
two of them. So, you're actually up on
cards even just selecting much. Usually
card selection cards, you think about
something like stack deck. You play a
card, you get one card out of the deal,
right? But you got to look at a couple
extras. cold shot is you get to look at
extras and you get to keep an extra
card. That is absurdly powerful for a
deck that consistently plays this spell
for one to zero power effectively.
>> Yeah, it is so so so nice and really
just like the crux of only almost any
purple deck right now. Last set I would
say the crux was more like towards like
that fight or flight, but now called
shock it's it's calling the shot.
>> It is and it's certainly at its best in
this deck I believe. I think Ezreal is
clearly the best user of this card even
though plenty of other decks we talked
about Aurora already earlier today also
a deck that happy is happy to use that
as well as Alan Mor returns back his
Ezreal trying to keep on chugger
chugging and I would be horrified if I
was a kido because a pickpocket just got
discarded.
>> Yeah, that is rough. And it looks like a
Kaido scooped and we're going into game
three here. This time it will be that
oblisk of power for a Kaido. Uh
obviously they have similar battlefields
as a whole. Uh and in this case we're
going to be seeing that void gate that
we saw game one for Akaido for Allen's
EQ and that obelisk the power that we
saw last game for Allen's EQ for Akaido.
>> Yeah, it's just that spire that's the
difference here. We are going to move
ourselves into game three one a piece
now as Allen's EQ. Can you stay
undefeated once again or is a different
Ezreal player going to be undefeated
here in Vegas?
>> Yeah, we will have to see. I mean, I
think the Vex really took players by
surprise last week, but this week
they've had seven seven days to prepare
for Vex. I mean, seven days is not a lot
and multiple of those were for
traveling. Uh, but they have had some
time. Obviously, Akaido is 4 and 0 with
it. He's starting to play it and
obviously people have been testing with
it all week long. Cana Akaido take the
win here?
>> Yeah, Akaido's been on Ezreal for a long
time. This is the kind of deck that they
love to play. So, stack tech going to
kick things off as Obelisk does at least
get an extra rune here for both players
cuz again we kind of staggered when the
obelisk was happening. Kind of a fun
little bit of like when do you select
your battlefield in this match up and
they are so similar. It's uh you know of
the six battlefields being bought uh
five of them are the same for each
player just one different there for AO
stack deck answered in kindo here for
Allen's EQ as the selection continues
and with 16 minutes left in this round
or so I am very confident these players
can finish this series which is
impressive I must say
>> yeah I'm excited to see it is great to
see these players uh you know top of the
you know playing field already of skill
and we're seeing them just oh my god
>> no one's good at Ezreal he's draw seals
every single game. There's all three of
them already in play.
>> That's what I Oh my god. Like how all
three
>> I only saw two. Kind of put them down
like together like Oh, that's two seals.
That's pretty good. No, it's all three.
It's fine.
>> Yeah. I mean, you can try to
pickpocketed me, but you're going to
you're going to have to play three of
them to destroy all three of these as
well. So, it is going to be a, you know,
hard hard price to pay here. Looks like
Raven Bloom is going to be coming up
into that obelisk of power. We have five
runes. What can we do here on KO's side?
>> She'll be happy to see a seal. Certainly
be happy to see a pick pocket as well,
but it's going to be something a little
bigger than that. This is a five.
>> Yeah, and a power. What will it be? And
it does look like Vex is coming out.
>> That makes sense. I think that's the
only five.
>> That is true. Yeah,
>> I was thinking in my head I was like, I
don't know exactly what this is off top
of my head. But thankfully, question
answered quickly and Vex going to be
deployed to the board here in base.
Stupify going to go ahead. I assume P
got the student, but maybe Vex is going
to be the uh in the eye of Yeah, you can
already see AK's like, "Yep, I got it.
Rocket barrage going to deal enough
damage. Stupify tricky get to four and
rocket barrage one of the few spells
that can deal damage actually only deals
damage to unit in base."
>> Uh but the thing
>> Singularity will and stuff that it is
restricted to base, I should say.
>> Yeah, I was going to say Rocket Rod is
just so strong though because it doesn't
only kill your units in base, it could
also kill a gear.
>> Mhm. And if you repeat it, you get a
little bit of both if you want, which is
really nice. that is so nice uh for
these different decks and it's a card
that I think a lot of blue decks are
starting to use because I mean between
Aurora between these miracle decks
running all these seals it is so nice to
try to take out some of the resources
>> even some of the you know the equipment
decks in Lucian poor gets a lot of
splash damage for all of the gear hate
that's running around even seals again
definitely uh pretty critical pieces of
gear to try and pick off as Ezel going
to get deployed here for AO just draws a
couple cards and passes it on back. So
Allan EQ with the three seal strong goes
Ezreal again going to keep on chugging.
>> Yeah, we will see that Ezreal and Bellow
we discarded the bellows for a draw two
here. Codshot will be able to come down.
Obviously we pay for the first but the
second discounted by Ezreal. We drew two
and we will be drawing two more.
>> Yeah, if you thought that Coldshot using
both deals to effectively pay for the
full spell was good, this is even
better. This is why Ezreal is so good at
playing this spell cuz once you have a
seal and an Ezreal, you could basically
play the cold shot for about nothing.
Yes, you have to commit one of your
pieces of gear, but given uh what it
took to get there, the little investment
you get pays off pretty big as Bella's
breath going to be pointed here at
Ezreal. That's the only target currently
that Alan Zub would have any interest in
pointing at. Gets a card drop off of the
legend as well and going to be going
again perhaps cord shot though first the
second time which is a little confusing.
We're going to go ahead and get even
more cards, even more filtering.
>> Yeah, I'll have to see what we pull
here. We would love something to
decrease the might on this Ezreal so
that it can be killed.
>> Rid of touch would be pretty good here.
Stupify looking good as well. And I
believe the bell was repeated. So that
is enough for Allen to go ahead and uh
take out the Ezreal and draw some cards
there. Stupify pretty good card in
general. Very efficient spell, really
clean. Draws you an extra card replacing
itself. looks at its best in a deck like
Ezreal where not only does it help you
trigger your legend ability to draw more
cards, but there are so many efficient
ways for you to shrink things that
dupify goes from looking kind of looking
like a vengeance, which is a wild spell
to look at when it's just a one energy
spell. Vengeance is a kill spell in
order that no one plays cuz no one plays
order sadly.
>> Yeah, I don't even know what it is. But
that being said, I support it.
>> Yeah, that's okay. We can we've seen
we've seen harness dragon today. It's
kind of like a one energy harness
dragon.
>> That's gigantic or very small, I guess.
True. That was very small like uh but
that being said that is going to be
crazy. We do take out the Ezra before we
can get too much value on a KO's side.
So Rosa is here. We did have to play a
lot more than we would like to for Rosa.
But obviously AO is trying to get a
board set up. We do not want to fall
behind. It is game three and it is the
game to decide the match.
>> Here comes Fizz once again. Here comes
Cold Shot once again. And it just it's
an unbelievable how many cards this deck
can turn to once its engine is going.
And Allan is fully in the driver's seat
with this Ezreal staying alive and all
these seals to help power these very
powerful but power hungry cards in his
deck. So again makes the selections
quickly adds the cards to hand just kind
of leaves one on the table on top of the
runes cuz you know got to do it quickly
here. There's only so many minutes left
in the round.
>> Yeah, only 12 minutes left and we are at
1 and0 points. We have to either let's
just say let's get to eight points, you
know, like but otherwise we still need
to get two point different, but we are
far enough away. Let's get to eight
points.
>> And uh don't be fooled. Uh this this
third called shot of this turn for
Allen. By the way, only two copies have
been seen so far this turn. Fizz managed
to recycle one to kind of make it a
little bit extra. And again, Allan is
just turboing through his pile of cards
right now. I mean, Alan is already like
seven or eight cards big at this point.
I think it's probably close to
doubledigit numbers of cards.
>> Yeah, we will have to see. But I mean,
claw shot can be a three in your deck,
but with his it can be anything.
>> There's that pickpocket. Get the gold.
Take out your only seal. Allan feels
like he's got a pretty good stronghold
in this game and even going to add a
stack deck just to make sure we have
even more cards and even more selection.
>> Yeah, we're going to get to select just
the best one for the situation. Get to
look at three and which of those can
help me in my following turn? That's the
question you're asking here. We're
cleaning up Akaido's board, but what can
we do in these future turns as well so
that we can get set up now and continue
to hopefully win this game?
>> Yeah, trying to look at how many cards
Ar's fanning out. Does seem like a
pretty decent amount, but look at
Allen's hand just barely at the top of
the screen on the right hand side. There
are so many cards in that hand as I
think AO knows that this is not a
position particularly happy to be in.
>> Not at all. While both of these players
really just, you know, growing their
hands, growing their options for each
turn. Rosa is going to come up here into
Obelisk. Doesn't feel great to go on and
start, you know, taking points when we
need to get a lead. And so potentially
two points here with this Rossa into
Obelisk.
>> I think in general, like the way I deck
is built is tough to win if you don't
take points eventually. And I think Aico
is like, I don't think I have the ultra
late game in this matchup. I think Allan
is not only a very skilled pilot, but I
think his deck is built in the way.
Well, I'm a little worried if this game
is going to go super duper late. So, I'm
trying to cut down this board. I'm
trying to get some points on the board.
And uh while, you know, still
maintaining a good amount of cards in
hand as Fizz going to go ahead and buy
back bellows, I have to assume after
frigid touch had a little poke around.
>> I think we bellowed into Bellows. Maybe
I'm wrong on that. I saw
>> very good.
>> I could be wrong, but I thought I saw
Bellows and then Fizz get played and
then Bellows again. So, we were able to
clean out a lot of Allen's EQ side. I
was hopeful for a moment that I was
going to see the combo that I've been t
wanting all all day, which is the
bellows into watcher, but um no, it's
just bellows into fizz into a bellows.
>> Still pretty good as it turns out. Very
similar to to bellows into watcher. As B
gets cleared out, Ato finds the line to
actually take it. Allen's pretty
formidable force in base. So, wages of
pain going to come back through. Going
to go ahead and poke the rasa cuz this
one only targets units at battlefields.
gets a gold gear as well. That one's
exhausted. That one's ready. Do have to
make sure which one is which cuz Allen
might want to use that power this turn.
Smokec screen going to shrink that one.
That's a one of in Allen's main deck at
least.
>> Mhm.
>> And hard bargain. Can you pay more for
it? Allen's like, I can pay more for it.
Do I want to pay more for it is the
question.
>> Yeah. Do you want to pay six
potentially? I didn't see how many we
turn up here for hard bargain, but it
could be up to six uh energy for this
smoke screen. It it was three damage to
Rasa and then with this taking him down
into that range to to die as well and it
looks like we were willing to pay for
that four.
>> Yeah, hard bargain was driven by a but
decided that you know what a price worth
paying here for Allen. It wants to take
out the Ras deploy one of his own and
try and get some might onto these
battlefields and again slowly eek out an
advantage cuz Allen's turns have felt so
efficient in this I mean, just looking
at the rune differential, AO is kind of
treading water looking to build up a
similar size force. Allan's just got so
many more resource. And that's the thing
I was trying to say before, like in
these matchups where there's a lot of
kind of jostling back and forth, but
both players know that they can kind of
solve any problem on a long enough time
horizon. One of the ways you typically
solve those problems is just by having
access to more things in your opponents.
And we know both players have access to
a lot of cards, but then you have to
think about, okay, I can pay things very
cheaply. We've seen how cheap cold shot
can get, but nothing at the end of the
day is going to be free. If you want to
commit to taking out units, you do have
to actually spend resources. And Allan
just having so many more than IO is kind
of making this game a little tough.
>> Yeah, it's definitely difficult. And
it's interesting to see that AO did end
up going into void gate. I think uh
we've seen them largely go into Alaska
Power this game because void gate is a
worry for this exact reason that we're
seeing played here. Wages of pain is
supposed to be three, but it's actually
dealing four here because it's a void
gate. I think for the most part, apart
from Rasa, wages does kill just about
every unit that I was relying on here.
And now Allan's starting to take some
points, which given how patient of a
player Allen is, I would be terrified if
he's starting to move out, thinking, you
know what, I feel comfortable enough
that I will actually commit my units to
the battlefield where they're a little
bit less safe.
>> Yeah, it's not going to feel good to see
the Allen's EQ starting to move in. It
does seem like he waits till the perfect
moment to start taking points. He's not
in a rush to do it.
>> Neither of these players, I think, are
in a rush. and AO can still have pretty
big turns here. So, we'll keep watch
here as the runes get channelled, the
card gets drawn, and still plenty of
options in the hands here for the
Miracle Ezreal player.
>> Mhm. And Akaido is officially at 10 in
his discard pile, just to note. So, Ross
could start being played potentially for
free. Um, but we are going to stack deck
first. Looking at that first rune,
looking at three, you know, for paying
the one energy, looking at three cards,
picking the best, and the two going to
the bottom. Yeah, both these players
play with their hands pretty close to
themselves. So, actually generally
cutting off the overhead view would
otherwise get. So, it will remain a
mystery to everyone, but I right now as
far as what cards are in their hand
going to pay quite a lot here for
something bigger spplitter. Oh, it's
Thousand Tail Watcher.
>> Thousand Town Watcher.
Uh, he is going to decrease the the
units on the board, but I don't think we
paid accelerate or anything like that.
So, it is I mean the Rosa is completely
safe. I don't always like seeing watcher
being played when we're not trying to
kill something that same turn, but you
need to get Mike down on the board. So,
while it doesn't feel great to pay this
power, at least we have seven points.
>> I think a little telling about the state
of Ako's current hand if this is the
play they're making, but F is going to
go ahead steal another point. Now, we're
equal on points between these two
players.
>> Dances on over and currently has uh the
strangle hold on both the battlefields
in the game. Yeah. And he's got the
runes to protect it, I would say,
between two gold, three uh three seals,
and I
>> Is that mind splitter? Oh, it's frigid
touch.
>> I thought I saw minds a second. I was
like, that is very bad news for AO. If
Mindsitter starts getting committed and
potentially cycle through, that's going
to be tough stuff, but Friid Touch
instead. We're going to follow up with
something else. You have to imagine
Stupify again looking for a redraw. Also
gets the draw of Ezreal. And any damage
at this point's going to do it. Fizz is
going to find one cuz that's Fizz's job.
>> That is Fizz's job. I do believe there
is a Bellows in the discard pile. It is
what we are going to go for and we are
going to see that get play at the bottom
of the deck but
let's see a little backwards we like but
I like it and well not really cuz I love
watcher but it is going to clear the
board for us.
>> Little bit of shortcutting I feel from
the players like Alan is like yep this
is what's happening. It's going to
bottom my deck. A knows yes we don't
have too long to play. I'm going to go
ahead and put my watcher in the bin.
Doesn't feel great that Aicada committed
basically all of their resources for
that turn to try and play a bigger might
unit and it just got taken up by Allen
while he still developed the rest of his
board. So Fizz going to try and do some
damage back here. Stack deck instead
digging for answers again just with the
texture of how these last few turns have
gone. Feels like Allen is in complete
control and KO is trying to find a way
out of what is looking to be a snowball
that is rolling down the hill.
>> I would completely agree and I think
that fits perfect with frigid touch.
>> Certainly does.
>> Uh but we are going to play Fizz as
well. There just so many options I feel
like in this deck to decrease might deal
damage and that's all you need in this
game to help you know control where
these cards are being able I mean being
able to survive. Wages of power coming
down to take this Fizz out but it's not
like we're going to be able to get
points ourselves. We don't really have
any units developed here in our base.
Meanwhile, Allen's EQ already at two
units.
>> Again, it's such a little thing. But
just looking at those seals that Allen
played were on turn two, turn three of
this game. Seeing Aico on this late in
the game, we've played so many turns
playing Arasa and still recycling an
actual rune. Still hasn't found seal
disc. I think pickpocket picked off one
of them if I recall correctly, but none
of the other two have been found. And
Fizz is still, you know, roaming free
over to the battlefield and scoring
points as Allen slowly but surely is
grinding away in this game, which is
again something he and this deck do
exceptionally well. Yeah, this is so
difficult. We had four runes up. So, the
fact that we're allowing both Fizz and
Rosa in without having any response.
Again, another tell that says what's in
AO's hand. And let me tell you,
>> now we're all going to find out. And
only four cards. That is not a big hand.
It is Watcher, Bellows, Arcane Shift,
and Cordot with no seals and no Ezil to
speak of. That hand is miserable.
>> Miserable.
>> And it's getting worse. It's about to
get a lot worse.
>> Yeah, we're going to lose one of them
here. And that seven might introduce to
Allen's EQ's board as well. It looks
like we're going to be taking that
watcher out which did, you know, could
have been might and also decreased might
on Allen.
>> Yeah, unlike Sabotage, you can take
anything out of your opponent's tank
with Mindsplitter. So, this is a one of
Allen's deck again for exactly this kind
of situation. When you're at this point,
it's kind of a stalemate. You're looking
to ice the game and take any option, any
hope of your opponent winning the game.
You're digging through your entire deck,
basically find the mind splitter, and
then it only gets worse because
eventually it's going to also get
recycled as that gold just gets picked
off there. Allan's like, "Ah, whatever.
I'll play this picker. Who cares about
the seal? I just want to put more might
on the board cuz he knows this game is
going firmly in his favor."
>> Yeah. And I would say it's so smart to
take out the Watcher because if you
decided to actually go for one of those
spells, it was Bellows, it was uh Arcane
Shift, it was called Shot, Fizz later
can access it, right? And so by keeping
it to the hand, it forces you to
actually pay the cost and you're not
getting that value off of Fizz in the
same way.
>> Yeah. And again, Allen's hand is chalk
full of stuff still on AA only had four
cards when the mind splitter happened.
Going to draw one back up to there. And
again, Ras going to just try and
challenge and uh answer sure you can
take the point. I don't think it I don't
think it matters that much, but you can
take it.
>> Four points. Let's go.
>> I think generally if Al's ahead on
points, it's kind of terrifying. If
Arcane Shift going to try and make
something happen here. Three damage to
the Rasa. Buy back the Fizz and find a
spell from the bin. What do we have? It
is wages to do the other three damage
and try and clear things out. AO is
treading water but trying to fight back
still in this matchup again. Allen's
ward extremely imposing, but AO is doing
everything they can to try and equalize.
>> Yeah, and I will say, we've talked about
it. These Ezreal decks can come back,
right? They always have the ability to
come back. We finally hit that seal of
Discord. One pickpocket is down. Now, we
know at least I think one is still in
the discard pile. So, maybe you were
saying maybe you won't have the
pickpocket. Maybe you didn't think I
would find it and you went on and
recycled it into your deck instead of
having it in hand. And maybe that's his
hope here. But at least we go to go on
and use it this turn.
>> Maybe also reasonably, where are my pick
buckets? You had three seals in place in
turn two. I put these in my deck to do
the exact same thing that you're trying
to do to me. And Aad has not been able
to find the tech as Allen has navigated
beautifully to this point to have an
extremely imposing board. And there are
still six cards in Allen's hand and
probably two of them draw four cards.
>> Yeah, it's going to be insane. It looks
like we finally do find the pick pocket
that you were mentioning though. We saw
that Crack come down so hopefully we're
able to find it. We'll get a gold off of
it as well. And you know, Alex Q can
just have his turn with two two stills
of discord.
>> Yeah, that's a little more reasonable.
You know, they say better late than
never. I think that doesn't apply in
this instance when pickpock had shown up
not quite on time to try and styy the
seals which are already doing the thing
they've been doing all game. No Ezra
required here for Alz to still pay
basically nothing for this cold shot.
>> Yeah, and you know they did turn up
literally turn one.
>> All right. Well, looks like we are at
time between these two players. So,
we're going to play a few more turns.
But Allan feeling pretty good with two
uh with basically two turns left to play
again. Three additional turns starting
at turn zero. So Allan I believe should
be the zero player at this point and uh
certainly has a big enough uh unit in
the mind spplitter to rumble on over and
uh pick off the rasa from that void
gate. Although they have to be a little
careful cuz as you pointed out get to
deal a bit of extra damage. So there are
ways for mind splitter to potentially
get shot out of the air.
>> But yeah, seven might is a lot to deal
with in these decks.
>> Uh we do obviously though have a huge
hand on Allen's EQ side. He doesn't have
to deal with the seven.
>> Ouch. taking out the two units here. It
potentially would take out Yeah, the
two. And they are going to both go to
that discard pile. AO is really trying
to develop his board. He's trying to do
anything to get there. And Allan DQ is
just he's being the defy. He's saying
no.
>> Just cruising right now as Allen going
to rumble the mind splitter in. Seven
versus six is the might right now. What
do you got? A do you have a stupify?
Frigid touch. That's a good one to try
and defend your board. Repeats it as
well. So shrinks the mind splitter
relatively low. Oh, hard bargain. An
absolute dagger to the heart of Ico.
That's going to be two points going to
seven. And Allen's EQ poised to win yet
another game and stay undefeated here at
RQ Las Vegas.
>> Yeah, and this two point difference is
so important now that we are in time.
You need to have two points to win the
match. It not for it just to be a draw.
So, keeping this point disparity is
going to be important for Allen's EQ in
these next what is it? Two turns left.
Pigpocket picks up another seal. And
that pickpocket, I believe, can still go
over and claim the point at the obelisk.
I don't believe Allen has scored there
yet.
>> I don't think so either. So, it's
definitely an option. Make that point
stretch just a slight bit larger. And it
looks like we're going to protect this
mine spplitter with a hidden card that
could potentially just be, you know, uh,
oh god, fight or flight or another
hidden card that could keep KO from
going into void camp. Yeah, both fighter
flight and weight is a pain are cards
you can hide here on Allen's side.
Bella's breath try and clear out the
back line here.
>> Actually, I guess could hit both. I
think that's actually what happening
here. So, going to have a shrinking
spell here as we're going to draw a card
yet. Did pick both cuz you can see
drawing a card immediately off of that.
And I just doesn't have it. Allen's EQ
going to take a win and stay undefeated
here once again on Ezreal looking to
repeat in a different country less than
a week later.
>> 5 and0. Fantastic job. It was so cool to
see these two different decks. That was
a I I think this kind of thing maybe for
some players is kind of an acquired
taste, kind of slow, very back and
forth, lots of little edges really
matter, but that is the kind of
riftbound that I personally very much
enjoy.
>> It is so much fun to watch these two
players uh play. They obviously know
their decks so well. Uh obviously Allen
has had some more time with it. Uh but
they did a great job.
>> Yeah, AO still looking good. And you
know what? We'd like to hear a little
bit more about how they were. We have an
interview with the winner coming up
right now.
All right, we had a Legends of Rune
Terra grudge match between IicO and
Allen's EQ. Y'all fought in Houston
early on. I know you'd got the better of
him. Once again, you're kind of bullying
IO in the mirror, but I mean, how did
you feel he played this Ezreal mirror?
>> Uh, better than Kaisa in Houston. Mirror
we played. Uh, I definitely see the
improvement in game one. He had a better
deck for mirror. However, a post
sideboard, I think I'm favorite and the
only thing that matter was just if we
can play all the three games in time.
>> Yeah. I mean, how have you been feeling
about the day overall? You able to pick
up another win. Now you're 4-0, still
undefeated going into the next round.
Have things just been continually as
seamless as they were in Bolognia?
>> Yeah, pretty much. I would say it's even
easier in Bolognia. I think my day one
was harder than my day two.
>> All right. I mean, fair enough. Now
looking forward towards you know day two
and going forward you think you might
get another rematch with AO in the top
eight.
>> I mean hopefully he can make it uh that
far and I'll try to get him a good
tiebreakers.
>> All right, thanks so much for the
interview. Good luck with the rest and
we'll send it back over the desk.
>> Always great to hear from Allan. I think
AO is a player we'll almost assuredly
see again on day two. Very confident on
this deck. Really loves to pilot this
Miracle Ezreal. Allen of course is just
the kind of player that it's really
tough to bet against. And I said this
already. If you're looking to win a best
off here at any original qualifier that
Alan ZQ is attending, just don't play
the legend he's playing. That's about
the only advice I can give you.
>> Yeah, I remember he made a tweet before
Bolognia where he was going for all of
the Ezreal's this set. We'll have to see
if he's able to do it successfully, but
he has the games. He's been playing it,
I've heard, for a long time, even before
Spirit Forge actually came out because
we've had the cards for a while. And so
it is so cool to see that practice
really converting into all these wins.
>> Yeah, if you ever get an opportunity,
maybe talk to Cassin over ask how how it
went testing out and they'll tell you
didn't go all that well. We are going to
throw to a break cuz we got more coming
up. Riftbound round number six is coming
through as we see that the sights and
sounds of the feature match area.
Players are battling as much as they can
trying to find their way through what is
looking to be a very tough field. Their
original qualifier champions, there is
action. There is everything we could
hope for and more. We found Las Vegas
yesterday. It's been a treat so far.
>> It has been so much fun watching all
these fantastic games.
Heat. Heat.
Yeah.
Hallelujah.
Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat.
Welcome back to coverage of regional
qualifier Las Vegas here for Rift Band.
And if you like what you're seeing, you
maybe want to get yourself get your feet
wet in some riftbound. You should go to
your local game store and play a Nexus
Knight ear. Was the last legend you
played at Nexus Knight?
>> Last legend I played with actually I
think Annie. I got top four. So I was
very happy about it. And Nexus Knights
are so much fun. Growing community is
such a huge part not only about this
game, but card games.
>> Yeah, absolutely. It's uh I think the
best part about card games is getting to
meet cool people and uh sling some
spells and just have fun. And next
night's kind of do a mix of both.
Whether you're a bit more competitive of
a player, whether you're just a bit more
casual, maybe you're just trying to, you
know, make your silly deck work. That's
pretty much what I'm trying to do
anytime I'm brewing in a card game, our
next night definitely the place to be.
>> Yeah, I think it's such a great place to
not only like learn the game, but get to
play some of those more fun decks. And
then you can come here and if you're
interested, you play maybe one of those
more difficult ones that you think will
make you into day two or not.
>> Yeah. So, we've seen our five rounds so
far. We have six of our eight rounds
today, I guess, coming up. Round six is
coming through. So, more than half of
the rounds now are done. We have a lot
to learn still about what the metag game
here and what the the texture of the
field is going to be like here in Las
Vegas. But so far, I feel like I've been
pretty happy with the different decks
we've seen. But understandably, the the
players, the names we know before, every
time I check the standings, I feel like
I see people going as we have a look at
them right now. In fact, we already know
Allan Q is undefeated, but here are
undefeated prismaticism still
undefeated, top in Bolognia. And uh the
undefeated are only going to get more
recognizable as we scroll through these
pages. There are a lot of players still
here at XNO. Yeah, it is so cool to see
those same players making it into uh you
know going undefeated as well. We love
to see that and there's so many really
great players here today that have
multiple results.
>> Yep. Looking to get to 18 points I
believe is X and2. So pretty close for
these players to lock for day two, but
of course you'd like to stay undefeated
for as long as possible. As we take a
look here, there are some funny names
sticking out to me.
>> Yeah, I do love some
>> Swagalisk. What a great name. Yeah, it
is so cool to see some of those summoner
names from League of Legends coming in
here. Maybe ones that you enjoyed or
people who are new to the game making
their own new names as well.
>> We have even more 5 to show you. Don't
worry folks, we got still a whole other
pages here. Alq, as you noted, just saw
him on stream. Still five and zero.
Stayed undefeated in Bolognia for quite
a while. But another member of the
Bolognia top eight, Randy down in 45th
place. I don't worry, they're all
they're all tied for first right now in
the standings. also five and zero.
Looking to make another top eight in
again about a week between different
countries.
>> Yeah, it would be so cool to see I know
Randy had a really interesting version
of Miracle Draven at Bolognia, but we'll
have to see what he has here. I'm not
sure if we've seen his list just yet,
but a lot of these players have some
great tanks on the deck
>> and still undefeated players here. He
swapped the 5 O's after 59 players, but
40 and one with a draw. That is the last
column that that is still technically
undefeated. Not quite as strong as it
would be if you hadn't lost. if you'd
won games, but still undefeated at 40 Z
and one for a bunch of these players as
well.
>> Yeah, I mean just so many great players
still fighting with this X and O and
they're really hoping to make it not
only into day two cuz they're almost
there, but take it home into that top
eight.
>> Yep. Three more rounds left here after
round five. We got six, seven, and eight
or Kona will be handling the duties for
round six. And I am very curious to see
what we've got coming next cuz I'll
admit to you all, I knew what was coming
up in number five. And I was very
excited with the two players we had. I
have no idea what's coming up for this
future match.
>> Yeah, I'm so excited. It will be a
little bit more surprise. Maybe we were
in the back watching the last one as it
went. Not exactly the plays, but seeing
the rough idea of the game. But this
one's going to be so much fun. I hope we
have some more fun decks. But I really
did enjoy the miracle Ezreal. Well,
let's find out cuz we're going to kick
things off with Ari Nightingale with uh
my original favorite legend. As soon as
I started playing Riftbound, the first
time I saw Ari, I was like, "This is
exactly how I want to be playing the
game."
>> I did too, actually. Played a lot of her
in set one, especially really early. But
it is going to be so interesting to see
how it plays here in set two. And
interestingly enough, we do not only
have that one chosen champ, but there is
the other one in the sideboard that we
could see come out in those future
games. Yeah, Ari inquisitive definitely
feeling like the more uh better one on
average in terms of prow level, but Ari
alluring certainly some spots you can
find there. Lots of really interesting
card choices in this deck. Ser gauge we
see a decent amount, but brutalizer not
a card I see in a lot of AR lists. Uh
all three watches obviously a card we
often see, but not always all three.
Azir is something we started to see pop
up in some of these other decks, but one
Sona definitely a card that's very
powerful if she can hold a battlefield
for you or just stick on there. and two
Janna. Not the card I was necessarily
expecting to see, but one of my original
mains back in League of Legends a very
long time ago now. Excited to see this
card play cuz I think this card is super
sweet. But we have something you've been
asking for us today.
>> I am so happy actually now. I feel
slightly bad. Uh but I am so excited for
this deck. There was actually a Zir in
the Ahri list as well that I found
interesting. But I think Azir is my
favorite deck right now in set 2 and I'm
so excited to see that Sacred Shears
here. Sacred Cheers was not originally
in some of those Azir list in the first
couple of Chinese regionals, but we did
see it in the one that it got second
place in, and it is so nice giving death
nil. This deathnil is a draw. So, it's a
much is uh similar to the Watchful
Sentry.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah, in that case. And so, it helps
cover some of the resource management
with with Azir, where it's kind of hard
to make sure you have a good full hand.
best card really covers that.
>> Yeah, it's nice. It kind of turns your
sand soldiers, which you're making a lot
of obviously. That's what his legend
ability does. Uh turning them into
little card draw units as well, which is
always nice to see. With that though,
I'm super excited to see how this match
is going to go. We're going to head on
down to the feature match area cuz I
have never seen this match up before.
We've seen a lot of Karm Legends on
stream. I'm very excited to get two that
are not Aurelia. It is Ahri by Night and
Gale as Streay is going to be piloting
Azir, Emperor of the Sands. This should
be a blast. and Forge of the Fluffed
already mixing it up in the battlefield.
Ferrari,
>> yeah, it's going to be an interesting
one. As is Hall of the Legend, I will
mention maybe something that's people
might have noticed in Azir's list is
it's not running any two drops, but that
is a lie. That's a lie.
>> That's a lie. Why is that?
>> Because Azir, if you can play a gear,
allows it to create a a sand soldier
with weapon master as well. So, a lot of
those gears are also going to create
your first unit of the game. So, as long
as we can play a gear that is within the
amount of runes we have and leave one
up, we'll still be able to get our turn
one play.
>> Yeah. So, interesting for these
battlefields. Forges of the fluff to
read it real quick. While you control
this battlefield, this is Ari's
battlefield. Friendly legend you control
have exhaust attach an equipment you
control to a unit you control. Ari not
known for her equipment prowess, but
certainly Dingale valuing the power of
the equipment in this set and wanting a
way to attach them even easier without
having to waste precious power that
these come decks do like. H of legends
on the other hand when you conquer you
may pay one. If you do ready your legend
when your legend makes a sound for only
one. That is a pretty good bit of text.
>> Yeah, it is so nice. It does look like
we're going to be starting with that
guardian angel here. It looks like we
did go first. So, we did miss um on turn
one. We held that gear to be able to
still create a unit on our turn two. So,
we do create the sand soldier. We have
weapon master and could attach guardian
angel, but we're probably going to save
this for a later turn, more than likely
when we bring out Azir sovereign.
>> Yep. So, sand soldiers have weapon
master and you make a sand soldier as a
but you can only do it if you played an
equipment this turn. So, really
interesting mix of kind of making token
units like Victor, but needing a bunch
of equipment in order to make that
happen. and kind of awkward cuz forge of
the fluffed might also be good for Azir.
>> It I think it will be. And to note, it's
not just the ones that Azir makes from
the legend that has weapon master. If
you create any sand soldier, it has
weapon master. So, you're going to need
to watch out for this card guard, which
is hidden. And you can use it to create
sand soldiers later in the game. And
also for I think it's a desert call,
which can be repeated to create up to
two sand soldiers. Yeah, certainly a way
to flood the board and kind of use your
equipment to make it happen as Sacred
Shears hits the board today. Could not
be happier with how this round is going.
>> Yes, I clapped my hands together a
little bit, but I hopefully it was not
picked up by the mic. Uh, but Sacred
Shears is going to come down. It does
have a power cost, but this is going to
be so nice to make sure that we maintain
a good healthy hand. And Ari did start
off strong getting out that Stout Lindor
Stout Stoutland Porro. Uh he is three
might when defending but that's a good
amount.
>> Yeah I can just run actually soldiers
but no shield is plus one. Soldiers have
two might. So it would be a trade if
studio wanted to run in here but
honestly run in trade draw a card. Not a
bad deal for a unit that you didn't have
to really uh pay for to get all that
much. Instead going to be over to Forge
of the Fluffed. Going to go ahead and
take the point and put the sand soldier
onto that battlefield instead. I see a
coal in hand for strew day but not sure
what they want to fire off next but
something's going to cost her and is in
fact going to be coal a week weak so
sacrifice something probably not the Ari
you just invested a bunch of resources
into star power is going to hit the bin
>> yeah but to note that will mean is now
basically unsafe when you are running
against a yellow deck the one thing you
want to keep up is a second unit that
can protect it from coal there's
probably more than one coal in this list
and so we're going to need something
else to now defend Ari from that type of
card.
>> So, actually a cloth armor, I believe,
being played there in uh an action
window that night and gale had from that
little exchange. So, Ari got a little
bit of equipment attached now as well.
And uh should be moving over to awaken
now soon for Nightingale. It looks like
players are just kind of managing their
boards and making sure it stays nice and
clean, nice and easy for people to read.
>> Uh yeah, it is so nice. One thing that I
really love about equipment, it's
happened multiple times, but really
going to be utilized here with Azir and
also Ari is that even though your unit
dies,
>> the gear, the equipment continues.
>> Yeah, it can get a little awkward
sometimes if you can't, you know, attach
it to a unit you really wanted to.
That's actually where funnally enough
for could come in cuz you can exhaust
your legend to move and this passive is
just always on your your legend doesn't
have to exhaust at all to do anything.
So giving your legend kind of an extra
ability through battlefield is kind of
sweet. This whole of legend's going to
be the thing here. In fact, you could
even get really wild with it and
sometimes exhaust your legend, go to
Hall of Legends, and then ready your AR
to pre-attach equipment. I don't know
when that would ever come up in this
match up, but it is something you can do
as Azir going to get cast here, but not
on the Azir side.
>> Yeah, really interesting. And it's
actually the Azir that Azir doesn't
play. Yep.
>> Uh, so this is the green Azir. Um, and
what he does is he actually has action
for a green power. you're able to choose
a unit control and move me to its
location and it to my original location
which would really be really really nice
to kind of save some of these different
units.
>> Yeah, if it's equipped also you may
attach one of its equipment to me. So
you kind of see what Niguel is doing
here. Cloth armor very good on defense
right goes minus one. It's a very cheap
source of shield too. Doesn't give any
extra might but on defense you can get
it going. Now Azir can kind of swap in
pick up the equipment and be defensive
after the AR trigger has already
happened. In fact potentially after the
inquisitive trigger has already
happened. So all of a sudden trying to
break through this wall seems impossible
on the Azir side. So we're going to the
other battlefield.
>> Yeah, it's going to be I mean really
really interesting to see what this deck
does, but I think Azir has some options.
So sometimes Ari does like to hold and
in set one we kind of even saw that her
ability as a leader is to decrease one
might of every single unit that comes in
down to one. So sand soldier can still
be decreased unlike Victor last set. uh
with his recruits. But the big thing is
is I remember in set one you had to wait
till the big push turn like if you were
playing ghee looking for maybe like the
green dragon and in this case it may be
that sovereign turn. So when we play
Azir we can accelerate it and you can
move as many sand soldiers as you want
that turn wherever Azir goes and that
may be where we try to break the AI
hold.
>> Obviously the champion in the chosen
champion zone here for the Azir player.
So, Hidden Blade going to come in here
and try and uh target that Ahri that's
guming up the works on the battlefield.
Zony's going to say, "I don't think so.
I'll save my Ahri instead." And it's a
beautiful AI, too. You want to make sure
you save that extremely blingy looking
card.
>> Yeah, these spirit blossom arts are
absolutely gorgeous in the Riftbound
set. I have been absolutely in love with
all of the arts. I was actually able to
get a couple boxes here and I am going
to be pulling I'm going to be opening
all of them. I hope to pull a Spirit of
Glum Mari.
>> I hope you do, too, cuz that is a
beautiful looking card. And if you want
to play Ari, a very powerful one as
well. Aziz is still hanging out on the
other battlefield though. So Azir has to
make some decisions how to bust through
the other side. Four points to three
right now. And Desert's Calling to make
some more sand soldiers.
>> Yeah, I didn't see if he paid for it.
No, we do pay four and we're going to
get as I said that repeat to make two
more. They're not ready just yet. Uh but
we will be able to attach to both of
these. Shears going to one, but we're
not we are kind of lacking in different
gears here. We're looking for those
brutalizers. We're going to be looking
uh for our sword. We have a couple. We
have so many gears in this deck. And
where are they? Azir, where are you?
>> Not sure, but he's going to be a card
hidden at the battlefield there under
that little sand soldier. So, Raven
Bloom student going to have to think
twice. Poor tsling in. Going to
discipline right away. Raven Bloom's
going to get bigger. Card's going to be
drawn. And uh Stu says, "Okay, so that
Raven Bloom student right now is a five
walking walking on over to this
battlefield. He is a big soldier. But it
does like look like hidden blade is
coming down. I think though the really
interesting well maybe not so
interesting but a lot of times the zir
you almost want to kill your own unit
with hidden blade. It didn't cost a lot
to create but if you're not getting
enough cards you can just kill your own
guy and draw two.
>> And that's exactly what went for there.
Does mean Nightingale is actually
threatening to win next turn at six
points right now. could double hold for
the win, which is not something we see
really ever in games of Riftbound, but
you have to think that Azir is going to
try and make a big turn here. So,
Brutalizer going to turn on the ability
of uh Azir's legend and then of course
that Azir hiding in the champion in
plain sight could make a pretty big
attack here on one of these battlefields
and you do need to dislodge at least one
of them
>> and I think there is the option for two.
So, what you would do is you would bring
the sand soldiers in against one of
them. We're choosing the Azir up here.
And you when you hopefully win it, you
can still bring in the ascendant Azir,
the yellow one to be able to move it
then into the other side if you need if
need be.
>> Yeah. So, looks like there's equal power
I think, but Ari made it an unfair
fight. So, discipline going to try and
get over and on guard is going to turn
that right back around. Azir at eight
and I believe after calculations now
it's going to get a little bit bigger.
Those double discipline should be
enough. I think it was six versus six
and then minus one thanks to Ari's
legend ability. caught five versus six
now.
>> Oh goodness. Now 10 versus six and plus
four. Sorry for five plus four is nine.
So I think Azir is winning this fight.
Indeed does at the end of it all still
going to draw a card. But my goodness,
that was a lot of combo tricks to count
very quickly.
>> Yeah, that is so painful. And now we
have I mean two still up. I guess two
that are ready, but we would have to
spin our runes to be able to attach them
now that we wouldn't be able to really
use weapon master in the same way. Not
enough to pop Azeria from the champ zone
into the other side as well. So looking
like at least going to be point number
seven. And Raven Moon student by the way
in amongst that all also got absolutely
massive on that side. So Brutalizer
going to be moved on over. We have to
try and fight here. This one is a five.
Two plus the brutalizer getting plus
three for reattaching this time.
>> Is it six?
>> Wait, is this plus four on the Raven
Bloom?
>> Yeah, Raven Bloom's massive. Oh, you're
right. And also AR is reducing it. So
Jon is going to push that one away and I
think we might have a double hold win.
Oo, that is exactly what Ari wants. This
deck or at least the leader really leads
towards defending. Um, and so it's going
to be really, really nice. Does look
like that's going to be what we do.
>> Yeah. So, Nighting Girl just pass the
turn. He's like, "All right, I'm going
to move my AR back to the champ zone cuz
we're shuffling up for game number two."
>> Yeah. And it is going to be a really
interesting one. We do see Vilema in
Ari's list. I'm not sure it's going to
be the biggest concern though for Azir.
I assume it is more angled towards those
purple decks with uh fight or flight
where you would want to push back and
forth. But the only real time that I
would see maybe it could do something
but Azir kind of counteracts it. It
doesn't matter. It just moves if you
battle.
>> Yeah, I think both Azir actually it's
funny cuz each player is playing a
different Azir. I think green Azir can
dodge vile as well with the action
ability and I believe also yellow will
dodge it as well by moving the units in.
It's not uh you know it's not quite the
same I believe. So, I think that all
works out as intended for these players.
Arena's Great is going to trigger here
as Stud is going to kick things off on
the play this time.
>> Yeah, I think Arena's greatest is a very
interesting one. We didn't see it in the
Chinese lists as much. Uh, and it's
going to speed up the game. So, we'll
have to see how it goes. We are going to
have a really strong start though here
for this year. We do actually hit that
turn one gear and it's actually going to
be a minion gear. So, it does plus zero.
You don't get any extra might, but when
you move it, we will be able to create
that one might recruit uh which can
slowly build up into a nice mount.
>> Yeah, for starting with two runes,
getting to activate your legend and put
a gear in later that gives you
additional value. Seems pretty good to
start off the game, especially on the
play. So, Azia going to be off to the
races already has the point range is
greatest. Going to go ahead and conquer
here for another point. And uh even if
something does happen here, the movement
still makes uh the recruit thanks to
either hero cuz when I move, play a one
recruit unit token here. So wherever the
wherever the unit is going, whether
that's back to base, you get a unit or
to a battlefield, you get one as well.
>> And the interesting thing for a weapon
master is you might think is that Eye of
Herold stuck now on Vilesm. But if we
can create a second Sand Soldier, even
if it's not from that leader, we can
actually detach Eye of Herald and attach
it to the new sand recruit in base. So
it's not stuck in biom at all.
>> Kind of makes sense. We have an ability
called weapon master that you would be
able to move weapons around quite
freely. Makes sense that Jax obviously
does a lot of this and Azir as well with
the sand soldiers specifically arming up
the sand soldiers and getting on the
battlefields and trying to again make
this game pretty pacy on the Azir side.
It looks like Ning girls just
considering maybe doing something here.
But with only Stwart power and one rune
up, not a whole lot that can be done
here. It feels like
>> yeah, it's going to be interesting to
see what they decide to do. There's so
many things, I guess, on both sides.
Obviously, it's a little bit harder for
Ari to DC different units once they're
in a battlefield because her ability is
very strongly leaning towards defense
over offense. But once in, she is really
hard to remove, just as we saw last
game.
>> Yeah, honestly, uh, Ari looking very
impressive in game number one. So many
things I don't think I' I've personally
ever seen in our list before. Really
leaning on equipment, have a lot of
tricks going on, really kind of moving
units around to to efficiently hold and
get points. Very impressive stuff. Kind
of how you'd imagine Ahri to be when you
look at the legend and think, how can I
make this really defensive, really
powerful passive ability work. Players
are talking about something, but all in
all, I think it should be relatively
straightforward unless Nightingale has
something for this one energy that I'm
not thinking of.
>> I think it's the arena's greatest
potentially. M that would make sense.
You do get a little more leeway now to
remember your triggers,
>> but we are into turn two is the thing.
So, both players have passed their first
turn. Um I'm not sure if that's it. And
it's just like we're lagging on the
points. That's completely fine if so. Uh
but that's my guess here with the fact
that we took the first point and then
we're having this call.
>> I think you're right.
>> Usually see the players point to the
battlefield when the turn begins.
>> I don't think either. And uh well cuz
well you get to wait for each beginning
phase I believe. So Ari has a little bit
of extra time to remember. Definitely
going to remember now if that's the
conversation they're having.
>> Yeah. Oh I was mean. We're both into
turn two now. I think
>> oh does it trigger beginning of turn or
beginning of game?
>> It's the beginning phase of turn the
first
>> bring up arena's greatest and have a
little read of the old battlefield.
>> Yeah. Is that it should be only the
beginning phase of the first turn. uh
because obisk as well uh both have that
get extra point.
>> I think you're right. So it looks like
we're maybe just thinking, hey, did uh
we accidentally missed this. It does
happen from time to time. In fact, uh
famously in Houston, uh none other than
Allan ZQ missed a arena's greatest
trigger
>> 100%. At the start of each player's
first beginning beginning phase. Yeah.
>> So Nightingale will wait be able to wait
till uh his beginning phase.
>> It's the second turn though.
>> First beginning phase. He's not a turn
yet.
>> He has.
>> Oh,
>> he's on turn two.
>> You You're right. Pass back and missed
it. Interesting.
>> We recruit weapon. Yep. I mean,
>> yeah, you're right. Play the poor pass
back.
>> Yep. And then that's how we're moving
on.
>> All right. We just play a regular game.
It's just a blank battlefield. Don't
worry about it.
>> It's just a blank battlefield. You can
still score points on it.
>> Can certainly score points on again. All
Battlefields let you score points on
them. I do not want to see the
Battlefield that says when you go
through this does not score any points.
That would be miserable. Isn't there
some battlefield in set two where it's
like until x amount of turns have passed
or something?
>> You can't go there for three turns. Rock
four.
>> Oh, you can't go there. Okay,
>> so there's units can't be played here.
That's a battlefield. And there's one
that you can't go here until the third
turn. Looks like the judging staff are
rushing on him by the way trying to
resolve it. And we'll see shortly what
happens cuz either the point to is going
to go up or they're going to stay
exactly where they are.
>> I mean, either is a choice. I'm down for
a full game of Zir. I don't think Azir
is down for that as much because he he
wants his battlefield to work. Um, but
we'll have to see how this goes.
>> Well, looks like I had my my
battlefields mixed up. Rockall is I
think the one that says you can't play
units here. It's forgotten monument is
the one you were thinking of. Can't play
until your third turn. It's kind of a
fun thing to track. Looks like both
players did get their arena's greatest
points by the way. It's currently two to
one. Let's go. Judging staff making sure
you know what it seems fine. I think
both players likely happy with that
outcome. Does feel a little bit bad when
the game doesn't play out as it kind of
should. Obviously, as a reminder, we are
pretty late into the tournament so far.
Still some rounds to go, but these
rounds are grueling out there, folks.
So, give players a little bit of grace
and everyone's going to kind of go back
to the situation. I think everyone would
rather be at cuz at the end of the day,
yes, it's a competition, but generally,
you'd rather things go, you know, about
as they should when you're trying to
compete again, especially win prizes
both for best offs and of course
potentially that qualification and in
the top eight of this event as well. So,
lots to play for here as we do finally
get our reset and we're back to the
points as they should be. Yeah, round
six I feel I feel like my where I always
get really tired in tournaments is like
round four if I mean right after the
lunch hour is what gets me makes a lot
of sense and uh round six I I don't
think I'm mentally there at that point
>> and all these players still undefeated
by the way also another good spot where
they're sitting in round six so it's
power over with the brutalizer does get
get into vials files mo file moss layer
excuse me to get that second point for
conquering and then going to hide a card
there as well So pretty good battlefield
to kind of bunker down in is Vom's there
cuz once you're in, you don't get out.
And instead is going to walt on over to
the other one. Keep making recruits and
keep moving sand soldiers to the places
that he wants them to be, which is
anywhere this porro isn't right now.
>> Yeah, he is a big boy. He's got I mean
he'll be a four normally s well three
normally sitting around and then
defending will be a four uh now that
that first turn of brutalizer has
passed. I'm really interested to see
what that hidden is, but it does look
like Ari is going to be coming. The
chosen champion Ari is going to be
coming in and the chosen champion a
little bit different from that leader
attack or defend is going to have that
minus two and that's going to be so nice
to take out both of these units.
>> Yeah, quite quite good on offense and uh
you can kind of add the numbers up there
and say you know what there was three
might over there I only have three might
but minus two is going to make most of
the fights unfair as Raven Bloom student
going to be deployed. So Nightingale
using a decent amount of resources early
to to get these powerful units out and
kind of spend some power recycle some
runes but feels valuable here. still has
enough tricks at, you know, one and two.
Can already see an ong guard flashed in
the hand. So, this already going to be
pretty tough to kick out. And funnily
enough, so is stalwart porro.
>> Yeah, I love stalwart poor especially
during set one. I always called him uh a
mini boss.
>> A mini boss
>> in Ye. He was a two cost that was a five
absolute mini boss. And with his
brutalizer attached, he's he's won
again.
>> I mean, with the Ari legend passive and
uh the equipment currently going on,
Stal is kind of back to being a five. So
seems tough there as uh looks like some
weapons are going to get deployed over
to the sand soldier and sh can't pick a
fight there. BF sword one of those
pretty nice pieces of equipment. It's
very straightforward which is like it is
in uh in League of Legends. Just a lot
of stats makes your attacks hurt more.
Yeah, it is so interesting as well in
Azir because you're running brutalizer
and the BF sword and so brutalizer can
help you kind of swing in with that
increased damage, but because you're
having to get only get plus three on the
turn that you attach it, it kind of is
awkward with those same sand soldiers.
So, it'll be interesting to see what the
Azir does, but BF sword always plus
three, which is going to be really nice
uh to just concretely know what might
that you would be able to swing into
these AI battlefields with.
>> Yeah, it's kind of nice to have a good
mix, right? Cuz Brutalizer is a bit
cheaper, BF swords a bit more expensive,
but again, so much of the ascend
soldiers is equipping units cuz again,
if you your units have weapon master and
basically all your units are sand
soldiers, you probably want things to
equip them with. So, mix in a mix try
and get might totals up to a different
point. At the end of the day, Azir is a
deck that really does want to do one
thing, and it's just make big units for
cheap and then put them on battlefields.
And that's exactly what Stir is trying
to do here, fighting for game number two
as they are back into the game, six and
five now. Still what Porro has been
holding on to the Bom's Lair and the
points are racking up quickly here.
>> Yeah, we want to get as many gears down
as well because we have a really fun
signature spell called Arise. It is six
runes, so we don't have it right here.
So fun for me when I'm playing Azir. But
uh it does create a sand soldier for
every single one. Doesn't look like
we're just seeing it just yet. But we
are going to be bringing in some of
these different units. This sand soldier
though looks absolutely monstrous.
I don't know what the word I was looking
for, but
>> monstrous.
>> Monstrous. Yes. It's got it's five six
and also bringing in this recruit that
might does not get decreased because
it's already a one.
>> Yeah, recruit does uh does perish in a
bit of collateral there as power is
going to go down that death group
actually moving another sand soldier
over. Kind of a nice bit of tech again.
Death group a really cool card very
efficient replaces itself but not a lot
of decks can utilize it to its full
potential. We saw it already today in
Leona that looked pretty sick in the
baited hook deck. makes a lot of sense
in a zero as well. And you have a lot of
kind of efficient might just lying
around your base every now and then.
>> Yeah. And you can kind of manipulate it
with those different uh equipments and
then still regenerate it if you're able
to find a gear that turn or desert claw
or or guard or something like that. So
we are going to be able to take both
battlefields now. Ari again a little bit
more difficult to attack with, but both
of these players are threatening getting
close to eight points.
>> Yeah. kind of curious what the line is
here now that we're I feel like Azir in
general wants to play to conquer for the
most part cuz again that's kind of what
your deck says to do. Uh Ari we know can
play for holding. We actually saw that
from Dinguel in the last game winning
game one by holding both points from six
to eight which is a very rare fit in
Riftbound. So if maybe something like
this Ari can stick on the battlefield
for a while could see Ari potentially
holding someone like Delair. So going to
be shrink shrink shrinking the sand
soldier here excuse me. currently a four
and that's going to be enough cuz uh
four minus two is a six and that all of
a sudden looking looks very imposing on
the other side as this is going to power
up the student as well and that's going
to try and get both points here that
would be the win I believe if you double
conquer
>> it does look like it's going to be the
win and I think this is you know one of
those things where it's kind of
difficult for Azir you would like to
play multiple units to these
battlefields and try to hold right on
this last turn but Azir actually can't
create them to the battlefield his
leader specifies specifically that it's
only to the base. So, it is going to be
a 2 and 0 for Ari, but really great job
by
>> we're in round six. Ari is still
undefeated here at day one in the
regional qualifier in Las Vegas. I did
not expect that at all. I was so excited
to see what other legends were kind of
around the top tables. Ari was one of
them. We kind of saying, "You know what?
If this player keeps doing well, let's
make sure we get them on feature." And
I'm very glad we did. That is a really
cool looking AR build and I will be
stealing it immediately.
>> Yeah, I might have to try it as well. I
definitely did not think about running
so much equipment in Ahri and so it was
so cool to see again spice that these
players are bringing to our regional
open. So cool.
>> I think uh making sure to utilize like
one of the major mechanics of the set
right spirit board obviously introducing
equipment didn't have the mechanic
before in Origins. I think some of these
more spellbased legends, I think a lot
of the calm uh like legends kind of fit
into this category. Felt like yeah, I'm
getting a lot of efficient might for
this equipment and it's nice that I can
use it over and over again. If my unit
goes down, I still have the gear. Didn't
necessarily feel like Ari had these
things where Ari wants to play a bunch
of spells. Lots of dreaming tree in
these kind of decks. Nightingale just
kind of figured out actually, you know
what, these equipment are just so
efficient. This is a better way for me
to get might even if I get it, you know,
not in combat as much. Even if they do
it a little more slowly, these cards are
just worth playing. And some of them
have quick draw which also means them
act like combat tricks. So really really
cool list. I mean I did not expect Forge
of the Fluffed AI to be uh two currently
and still undefeated in Vegas but here
we are.
>> Yeah and it was so cool to see them two
Azir as well. Really happy to see it
again in 5, but really great job by that
Ahri. I am so happy to see it succeed
even in this following set. I really
thought blue and green was so strong in
set one and so it's good to see it kind
of doing well as well today. after
agreeing. You know what's even better
about us speculating about it? Hearing
from the winner themselves. We're going
to go down with the winners interview
after that match.
>> I'm here with with Nightingale now 60 on
AI. I got to ask you why why go with the
Ari choice coming in cuz it's working
for you so far.
>> Uh in set one I played exclusively Ahri.
Um, I had a anti- meta
uh deck that's uh continued a time warp
build with I use green masteries uh in
that deck. So, I just was really
familiar with uh Ari and decided to just
continue using it in set two um since
this is my first event uh of this
caliber. I just was what I'm comfortable
with.
>> Yeah, that makes sense and it's it's
working great. Uh I I wanted to ask you
a little bit about the matchups. You
said you you originally built kind of
like an anti-meta Arya build. I assume
you've kind of gone a similar direction.
Have you been kind of hitting the
matchups you want to see?
>> Uh
sort of. I've dodge Ireelia all today so
far, which is the worst matchup. Um but
uh it hasn't been an easy route. I've
won I actually won two matches by one
might. Uh I beat a Kai'Sa by So I played
a Jinx Miracle, Kai'Sa, Driven Miracle,
Driven mid-range, and then Azir. And
then in the Kaiso and Driven mid-range
match up, I won by exactly one might.
So, it's been a very, I would say, fort
fortuitous and lucky uh uh journey so
far.
>> You have any shout outs that you'd like
to give before we send it back?
>> Yeah, I'd like to shout out um my
friends on the secret server and Togg.
Uh Togg actually helped me build this
new version of Ari. Uh we I just found I
my original deck I was going to bring
was functionally commander deck. when
you went on Poto over archive it was six
rows. Um but I changed it to this one
and I feel much uh better because when I
was playing talk he told me the
equipments were really good. So yeah, I
I I would like to really thank Tog for
helping me build this deck. All right.
Well, with that sixth win, you've locked
yourself for a day too. So good luck
tomorrow as well and the rest of your
round today and we'll send it back over
to the desk.
>> Well, Tog, I don't know who you are yet,
but I'm going to need you to build all
my decks as well cuz that deck looked
amazing.
>> Yeah. So so cool. And I absolutely love
the fact that he said this is his first
regional qualifier. He's 6 and0. He said
he's been playing Ahri. I mean only
Ahri, so he's been having fun learning
the game at Nexus 9 at Summoner Skrishes
now 6 and0 in the regional qualifier
which does mean he is signed up for day
two.
>> Yeah. And looking to obviously play for
that best of maybe even more in the top.
But you know what's better than feature
match today? Second feature match. We're
going to take a look at the deck list
here. We have a backup match we're going
to be launching into in just a moment.
And it is of course Draven to start
things off.
>> It is Draven and it is going to be
really set up for this Z war. I'd love
to see if it uh if we start with it, but
I don't think you're going to be happy
about these runes here. Pastry.
>> Ooh, 84 split. I'm uh for everyone that
doesn't know, I'm the person that says
66 or 75. There are no other splits.
Obviously 12.
>> Oh, 120. Yes. Obviously, if you only
have one power cost, running mono is
fine. But you know what? Lots of
different runes have been uh more
successful than I've been at my nexus
nights and they're here at the regional
qualifier. Really interesting build of
Draven here. Again, kind of the standard
shell here with things like Ros, seal of
discord, fizz, uh stack deck, but couple
of fans, one shovel, three nocturn. So
again, a very malleable shell is Draven.
We've heard about mid-range D, Miracle
Draven. This is kind of a mix of both of
those things.
>> Yeah, it's nice to see noturn again. I
mean, we've seen miracle Draven, but we
haven't seen really the Noturn version
of that. And I think it's going to be
something for people to watch out for
which when you draw cards that are not
drawing the hand. So not draw cards when
you look at cards if it's there. So like
called shot stack deck you can play it
directly and then still draw the other
card. Easy.
>> It's funny to think especially with
seals obviously cuz you do have to play
one rainbow power to do that. And of
course all the seals that these decks
are running already to play things like
their cold shots means Noctturn comes in
very cheaply. It's funny when when this
kind of show was brewing, people were
excited about the uh the Noctturn, but
Noctturn kind of got pulled to the
wayside. But we're going to have to talk
about that later because Sup Fiesta is
playing a legend I did not think I would
see undefeated anywhere throughout the
RQ. And here's Jax, Grandmaster at Arms.
>> Yeah, these runes are set up a little
bit more as you would be happy with, but
uh yeah, I think Jax is one that we did
not expect to see. He's had some really
interest he's got some really
interesting uh text on his legend.
Actually two different ways to play him.
And so that's going to be something to
look out for. You can pay an energy and
exhaust him to attach a detached
equipment that you control or just
exhaust him to attach an attached
equipment you control to a unit you
control. And we can see how strong that
was even in that zir match we just
watched. So we're just going to set this
up. Great.
>> And something to note here, this is
really important if you want to play
decks. I think for some of the Jack
players, this actually kind of changed
how they think about it quite a lot.
Brutalizer, if it's attached to a unit
you control, and you activate Jax to
reattach it, it counts as being attached
again that turns. You get the extra
power that Brutalizer gives you when you
attach it for the first time. That is a
very powerful thing that pretty much
just this deck gets to really make full
use out of.
>> Yeah, it's going to be so nice and it
synergizes well uh with some of these
different Jaxes that maybe we'll get to
see. So, let's see. We are going into
game two here.
>> Yep. So, this is game two. Armando on
the left. Draven Glorious Executioner
Soup Fiesta, which is an incredible
summoner name playing Jax Grandmaster at
Arm. Still undefeated here
>> so far in the Rube.
>> Yeah, we got to see Sunken Temple a
little bit earlier, I think, with an
Ireelia list. Uh, but you get to draw
one if you pay an energy if you have
conquer with a mighty unit. So, a lot of
ifs, but I think Jax will be able to use
it. And on the other side, we are using
Candlelet Sanctum. We did miss the Z
game, but Candlelet Sanctum, I do
believe, is another card that really
kind of harnesses that Noturn that we're
seeing in Arando's list.
>> Yeah, pretty uh stock standard index
decks to play Noctturn cuz it's just
another way for you to consistently find
the card cuz basically anytime you see a
Noctturn, we look at the top of your
deck, it's like you won the lottery.
You're so happy to slam that down,
especially if you have a seal in play.
So, we'll see how things go cuz the
first game did go to Draven. I'm sure
Supfiesta has hit some Dravens already
on the way to five and zero, but perhaps
this is the one that stops the perfect
record.
>> I mean, you don't need a perfect record
to make it to day two. So, I would be
excited to see Jax there if they can
make it. We do get that lonely porro
down on Jax's side. They are going first
here. And now Draven has to find
something. It looks like our first card
is going to be that stack deck. No turn
just yet, but we will get to hand select
one of three cards to be putting into
our hand.
>> Yep. Again, still good. These Raven
decks still all want to filter through
the deck pretty aggressively. Whether
they're more mid-rangey, you're going to
try to play, you know, quote unquote
more fairly or if they're miracle and
really trying to turbo through the deck.
This selection stack deck basically
makes the cut in all of these decks,
which makes a lot of sense as lonely
porro. Going to go to the candle sanctum
and have a look at the top cards of the
deck. Seal warmogs and sea defy. Do we
want to keep any of these on top? That's
the question.
>> Yeah, we can put one of them at the
bottom of our deck or I think both
potentially.
>> Have a little
>> It's either one or both. But I'm not
sure if both are in the if both of those
two are in the text. That being said
though, it does really help us get
through the deck. We may not get to
stack it in the same way that uh our
Draven can, but it will help us curate
what we're going to be drawing in our
future turns.
>> Little reminder for everyone at home for
Candlelet Sanctum. When you conquer
here, look at the top two cards of your
main deck. You may recycle one or both
of them. Put those you don't back in any
order.
>> Let's go. Plus one for Ursay.
>> Plus one for Ursay. Nice little bit of
selection. Again, good for the Nocturn
player, but you know, not bad for either
player here. Happy to take the extra.
And of course, with no mighty units to
try and take advantage of the sunken
temple. Not really somewhere Super
Fiesta wants to go early on as Traveling
Merchant has been the early play. And
the first seal makes an appearance here
for Armando. Usually a good sign for the
Draven side.
>> Yeah, he is not unhappy about the seal.
Uh, and we can see some more discard
here and drawing with that traveling
merchant. Interested to see exactly
where it goes. If it's going into candle
lit, which it is, it could also trigger
that death on Lonely Porro.
>> Spinning axe already into that traveling
merchant potentially.
>> What's up?
>> Ooh, looks like maybe something. Oh.
>> Oh, he has to discard draw first.
>> Have to resolve it now. Spinning axe.
Yep. Good. Good catch by Jax making sure
things are resolved in the order they're
supposed to. Spinning axe plus three
onto the traveling merchant. And most
importantly, Draven draws a card. Yeah,
that is going to be I mean happy for
Draven, but Jax gets to draw a card too
off that Lonely Porro. He did select I
think one to stay on top of his deck and
he knew the exact card was going to be
because of Candle at Sanctum and he's
going to get one card further to find
the exact cards he wants as well.
>> That's true. So check the Warmogs Endify
on top. I think I spy warmogs in Super
Fiesta's hand. So I imagine that's the
card that was kept again. Jack kind of
like Azir does care about gear. Has a
lot of weapon master going on. as the
shovel going to come out for uh I don't
know what time this day, but we've seen
a lot of shovel today. Last rights going
to hit the table here for Draven.
>> Yeah, Draven. I mean, I don't think he
wants it just yet. There are literally
only two cards in our discard pile, and
we want to get it to tin if we're ever
going to replay this Rosa for free. Uh
but going on and developing it is really
nice.
>> See if the spinning axe does stick
around. Lucian here going to go to the
G8 equipped thanks to Weapon Master
that's native on this card. Then the
first time I conquer each turn, ready
me.
>> That is going to be so nice to be able
to protect Lucian means we can go up
into a battlefield, take it and retreat
back. A lot of the time when you conquer
any battlefield, you kind of resign to
the fact more than likely this guy's
dead. I He's a part of the cost to
actually taking the battlefield, but
because of his ability, he can go on and
retreat back. So he's not a part of the
cost this turn.
>> No. And thanks to I'm glad you explained
all that cuz that's exactly what
happened in Delusion. Thanks to first
mate coming in there for sfiesta and
readying that Lucian. So a point scored
and quickly scurryies back to base to do
it all again next turn. But Armando
still there with the traveling merchant
going to get the point for holding on
the sanctum going to stay with the
spinning axe attached which is where you
want it to be. It is temporary if you
ever if it ever drops off. Much like
Draven in the game don't want to stop
catching those axes.
>> Yeah, you got to keep the loop going. I
will say this may be the largest
traveling merchant I've ever seen. It's
only a five, but I wouldn't want don't
normally expect him to be that big.
>> Yeah, I played this in Yaso and I've
pumped it before. I don't think I've
ever got five and I'm playing a bunch of
com cards as Nocturn going to be seen
off the stack deck and that very
convenient seal of disco. It's going to
make that discount feel pretty nice.
>> That will be so nice. And to note that
does mean traveling merchant is a mighty
unit. So if he moves in his sunken
temple, I've never called Traveling
Merchant mighty before in my life. But
we will potentially be able to get that
draw which
it may be literally the first traveling
merchant ever to do so on
>> I think certainly one of the first to
ever do it on sen temple certainly on
this stream I have to imagine but you
can see this equipment really efficient
as far as giving stats especially the
spinning axe as a reason it has kind of
a catch if you can't catch it as it were
but seal of discord going to come back
does have to actually recycle this time
because we already found a knockdown
that didn't cost any power so you know
you know little bit of here a little bit
of that it's totally find his battering
ram also going to be very cheap this
turn.
>> We don't have a counter this time, but I
do think it's going to be a very cheap
battering ram.
>> 4-1. I think
>> it is 4-1. I had I saw him under
counter. Stack deck. Oh, counting again.
Perhaps stack deck nocturn. Uh seal is
three. Maybe
>> it was two. There's two turned as well,
but still
>> players will resolve it, I'm sure. Looks
like Amanda just going to pass it back.
Whatever it was was cheap enough for
that matter. Pretty good price to pay
for five might. And uh Draven kind of
doing the Draven stuff here as we see
what Jax has up his sleeve. I see a
counter-strike Jax's signature spell in
hand. That is three copies in the main
of that one as Warmogs going to get
deployed here. Nice efficient gear to
play. Jax is going to get exhausted.
Lucian's going to come rumbling on in
once again.
>> Yeah, and Jax really makes attaching
these so cheap. It is the one thing that
hurts in his ear sometimes. you just
lose all your your runes. But here, all
you have to do is pay an energy and
exhaust that Jack's leader and you can
still attach it without having to pay a
power, which is going to be great. And
Lucian mighty, we get to draw sunken
timble. He is ready again because of his
ability.
>> And where does he go from here?
>> Yeah, it doesn't have ganking
unfortunately, so can't go ahead and
visit the sanctum, but again is going to
go and retreat. Warmogs when you conquer
buff me and give plus one natively as
well. So, in essence, a very cheap piece
of equipment that can give you plus two
might, which is a pretty good deal for
piece of gear that I believe costs only
one energy. And with Lucian, as you
noted, can equip it very efficiently
with sorry, with jacks, I suppose, just
by exhausting that legend and moving it
on over.
>> Yeah, that is so nice. And they're doing
such a great job at narrating how many
cards they have, things like that.
Really, really nice, especially when
you're playing closer to the chest with
the cards, which is really good in card
game, not so great when you're casting.
>> I see a challenge here as well for
Superiesta. That Lucian is pretty big at
this stage. So maybe you want to
challenge something. Maybe the Noctturn,
maybe the Battering Ram, maybe the old
mighty traveling merchant has got to be
taken down a peg.
>> Yeah. And it might be I sometimes I'd
like to say like battering ram would be
good here, but kind of getting rid of
spinning axes in general would be nice
as well because if we can get rid of it
during Sup Fiesta's turn, he'll have a
fiesta because it'll dissolve.
>> Well, that is exactly what's happening.
Challenge is happening. Lucian's going
to go ahead and fight the traveling
emotion. And just puts them both
straight in the bin. That is not
technically how that works, but in
essence, that is what's going to happen.
>> Yeah, exactly. A little bit of a short
shortcut, but for the best.
>> Lonely Pora going to see the sanctum
again. Sees a punch first, and I believe
that one is snapped to the top for
SFiesta.
>> Yeah, you may kill this Lonely Porro,
but if you do, I will have plus five
might in my hand.
>> There will be a reckoning here. Siesta
up four to two points. And again,
Amanda's board pretty nicely. This
Noctton and this battering ram on their
own. Nine might between the two. That's
not counting the plus two might from the
potential shovel, plus the other tricks
that Amanda could have, plus the extra
units that may be going to get played.
So, it's a cold shot here again. Tap
those two seals and repeat it. Something
we've seen a lot there. And I spy an
Ezreal. That's going to make it even
better the next time.
>> Yeah, I was going to
>> Hey, look, another seal.
>> Oh, that is nice. I was going to say we
were not able to discount the repeat
because we don't have an Ezreal. So, we
had to pay both up with the seals of
discord, but we hit the Ezreal.
>> Yeah, next time it's going to be even
better there for the cold shot. And
again, like you mentioned in our Ezreal
mirror, it's not just Ezreal that gets
to do. It's all the purple decks if they
want to, I don't know, go through the
trouble of putting Ezreal in their deck.
>> I mean,
>> maybe if card draw was strong in card
game, this would be good.
>> It is both in the name of each of those
things. So, that does kind of add up to
me. Seven cards or so fanned out in hand
for Arando, including another copy of
Spinning Axe.
>> That is so nice for Arando. Maybe not so
nice for Fiesta, but we will have to see
here. We are potentially moving
Noctturn, but to where?
>> Yeah. Again, also a couple things up.
Karm is a pretty tricky uh domain. So is
uh body honestly as far as tricks go. We
know about punch first on the top of the
deck. We know it could also be in hand
potentially. And certainly Armando going
to be thinking about it when trying to
rumble in, but decides, you know what,
this open sunken temple with my
conveniently mighty battering ram seems
like a good place for me to travel to.
Yeah, I think that is a great choice and
we are going to draw one. Keep looking
for these different cards that'll help
us move in. We don't have as much side
draw on Jax's side, but if he decides to
kill this only Porro, we will be able to
at least access some of our draw here.
>> So, we're going to keep going through
the cards. Scrap peep going to hit the
bin thanks to Ezio. And that's going to
be draw three after discarding a card,
which uh is just something that feels so
good whenever it lines up.
>> Yeah, we have so many nice pieces here.
We're able to obviously have our seals.
We're able to discard scrap heap. Our
hand is growing and I mean Draven's game
plan is succeeding so far. We are at
three versus the four, but our base is
just getting more and more developed.
>> Yeah, I think Commando happy to kind of
sit back and give a couple points away
here and build up an even more imposing
army. On the other side, CPS is like, I
need to get this game over with as
quickly as I possibly can because this
person is drawing like six cards a turn,
it feels like, and I cannot keep up with
that on Jax.
>> Yeah, that is one downside I would say
of JS uh or non-purple decks right now.
Um so hopefully we can make a move back
in. This illusion is pretty big and he
is able to maneuver around the
battlefields pretty swiftly. Um, but
he's going to need to keep it up if he
wants to take the win here.
>> Yeah, Lucian currently is six. So,
either battlefield right now seems like
a decent place to go. Lonely Por going
to get challenged by the nocturn. What a
super he has to have. It's Counter
Strike.
>> The signature spell of Jax coming down
here is reaction speed and you get to
choose a unit. The next time that unit
would be dealt damage, prevent it and
draw one. So, kind of a stun.
>> Kind of not really. And that Nocturn
will be bounced back and we're going to
get a card draw meaning hello punch
first.
>> Hey, got that card that we knew about
already. And uh getting a cycle that
counter strike feels pretty good there.
So Lonely P going to hold on which is
nice given that we know Lucian is almost
assuredly going to be able to take the
top battlefield. So Z Fiesta looking
like maybe going to be five points here
on this turn. No, instead going to
threaten six, which with this Lucian and
kind of the the way things have been
going feels pretty good. So another
battering ram going to get added to the
pile. Yeah, our Lucian I do believe it's
four, five, six right now. So, we will
not It's going to be harder to take out
uh the battering rams now that we are
kind of beefing up the top battlefield
up to 10 might, but I wouldn't be
surprised if Jax has a way.
>> Jax certainly has something. We know
about the punch first. That's already
enough on its own.
>> True. True.
>> Turns out plus five when you're one
might over two fives. Yeah, looking
pretty good there to try and take up
both the Rams. So, Raza going to be
deployed, but this time actually to the
base. not willing to reinforce and that
may be a very small error that costs a
point here for Armando.
>> Yeah, and I will say because we decide
to play Rossa here and our back and our
discard isn't big enough that it's free.
We actually are tapping out on Draven's
side, there's not really anything now
that Supiesta has to worry too much
about. There is a hidden card obviously
that we have to watch, but it's, you
know, that really decreases the number
of cards it could be.
>> I did manage to catch it. It is a fight
or flight as it's kind of the the the
best guess generally when uh you see
purple hide a cardartite at a
battlefield. So 10 might and a fight or
flight for supiesta to try and go
through already. It feels like Lucian
without getting too reready next thanks
to conquering because you're going to
get pushed up before that happens. Going
to feel tough to take that point away.
So we'll go to fight here thanks to
Lonely Porro's heroic hold on the candle
at Sanctum. But maybe not so much luck
here on the sunken temple.
>> Yeah, sunken temple's going to be more
difficult. But Jax has so many runes. We
are looking at eight which doesn't only
mean punch burst. We could have defies
because it is green. I think it's on but
I'm not completely sure if I'm confusing
different games. Uh and so we'll have to
see what exactly happens here. He is
moving into that sunken temple with six
like we mentioned earlier against this
tin and a hidden in uh in the
battlefield.
>> Does the buff fall off?
>> So this is really interesting because uh
>> I was told no cuz he just recalls with
the equipment on him. the G dice.
>> Okay, really interesting. The buff is
not going to go away when the Lucian
gets killed to the G. So, Sufi has to
decide I don't want to commit anything
here with your hidden card. I'm just
going to go and try and take them out
one by one. Lucian is going to live
thanks to the G will shrink a little bit
and that does undo some of the damage.
Doesn't get through the battlefield, but
I think a decent exchange given that you
are pretty sure it's a fight or fight
under that battlefield even though I can
see the card and I know Suit Fiesta
cannot.
>> Yeah, he doesn't have the same bird's
eye view as we do,
>> which is good. That would be very bad if
a player had that.
>> That would be very bad for sure. But it
actually looks like we're going to be
changing using the leader to change that
equipment over to the first mate. This
card is not as high a priority as our
Lucian is to keep alive. So with this
discipline, we're going to six and we'll
have to see what Amanda has. It is a
fighter fight, but we still have six
runes up.
>> Okay, is going to go through though.
>> Yeah, there were certainly draws there
for CPS that could have counted this
fighter flight. Defy comes up. Not so
fast comes up, but didn't manage to have
one of those even after the draw of the
discipline. So unfortunately just going
to get pushed back, which means Draven
wins a combat and Armando likely gets to
hold onto this battlefield for a little
bit longer as Lucian number two comes
out.
>> Yeah, second Lucian into play. Is there
anything else going to do otherwise
Arando will be going to four with this
hold and we are still have three of our
units in the base that are going to
become ready this turn.
>> All right, so channeling two more runes.
Armando up to four points now. Slowly
but surely catching up. Lonely Porro
still hanging out on the southern
battlefield. I have bad news for Lonely
Porro. I don't think he's going to make
it through this turn.
>> We still have punch first in hand.
There's options. I do think obviously
there is a lot of might here in Arando's
base. We have I think 13. I would assume
we may still want to keep Ezreal safe in
that base while we only have one of it.
But Armando may not expect the punch
first and could potentially not play for
it. Oh my god, we're going to hit a
knockturn though. It looks like off of a
cold shot.
>> Yeah, a cold shot that only costs a
single power thanks to Ezil being on the
board. And then the second seal man to
knock into play. So an extremely
efficient cold shot. Basically pay two
power that you already had in play from
some seals and get a bunch of cards and
a Noctturn onto a battlefield. That's a
pretty good deal.
>> That is going to be so nice. We saw him
see that thermoban. I saw a pause when
he pulled Thermob beam and I almost was
wondering if he was going to decide to
play it because Jax is really built
around those equipment and equipment's
just not equipment. It's also a gear in
this game and Thermmo beam can wipe out
every single one of them with a single
play
>> right now. Not that much gear to speak
of. So instead, the last rights is going
to get equipped to Rasa or cycle a
couple cards back and make the Rasa that
much bigger which should help in a
potential tussle with this lonely porro.
That's eight M right now. We know punch
first is only good enough for plus five.
That would make the power a seven. But
as Suti has to have anything else in his
Amanda going to bring any other people
to the fight.
>> Yeah. I'm trying to think about if we've
only seen two disciplines or or how many
disciplines we've seen cuz it's also an
option.
>> I think two. And Nocturn's going to come
for the ride as well just in case. And
Lonely Borrow is going to die alone once
again.
>> Yeah, with 12 might coming in. We don't
have enough even if we have the best
hand really. So, we are just going to
take that death nil draw. Not the worst
either.
>> We're going to draw from Draven as well.
Again, this is the thing. When Draven
starts rolling, once the combat start
happening, if they go Draven's way, the
snowball does keep rolling. So, Arando
now tied with points, drawing cards off
to Draven, setting up the base, getting
basically free might deployed to these
battlefields. It's looking tough out
here for Jax to try and crack these
Draven built battlefields.
>> Yeah. And Kendall, that's going to help
us set up for just, you know, whatever
we want to draw. Going to be so nice.
Doesn't even cost anything, honestly.
>> Yeah. Just a little trip to the
battlefield. That's all you need to do
as long as you win the combat. You draw
a card and then candle it happens. In
fact, if you order them, uh, you get to
maybe pick the card that you get to draw
on top. Although, actually, no, combat
happens before conquer. So, Draven
cannot do it that way. There are other
effects where you can, but Draven
specifically does not let you do that.
>> Yeah, but there's so many things that
went well here. We get the draw off
Draven. We get to select our card for
the next turn. We get that last right to
return from the graveyard as well. And
now we're also pulling up Ezreal to help
protect because we could be holding to
seven points next turn. Yeah, I'm under
it has a casual nine cards in hand right
now. Straven
>> just casual.
>> Not bad.
>> Yeah, it's a it's a Saturday. Just a
whatever time it is on a Saturday. Easy.
>> Bunch of runes being floated away here.
Enough to for this Draven to be played
from the champs. And again, Amando
adding to the army whether it's on the
battlefields or the base. It's all might
that he wants to try and get these last
few points away from this Jax. So soup
fiesta wonder what Dax is going to have
in terms of tricks as another card gets
hidden under the sunken temple which is
I think a really nice battlefield to try
and maybe overly fortify a bit because
that's also not only the way that
obviously super has to get some points.
That's a way to get a bit more card
flowing which is definitely the thing
that compared to Draven feels very much
stifled on the Jack's side.
>> Yeah, Jax does not have him draw. That
is going to be for sure here. I feel
like
um let's see here. But Jackson with so
many runes on his side, I will say as
well, we have some options of things we
can do on our turn coming up. And uh I
mean hopefully we just have them in our
hand.
>> Yeah, 15 on the top side, 13 on the
bottom side as far as might totals go.
And it's 34 in the middle for the first
mate, three on the Lucian, and then four
on the other Lucian at the top of the
playmat. So not a lot of might to play
with here. What? That's 10 currently on
Supra. There's more than 10 on both
battlefields right now for Arando. It's
definitely going to be a rough turn
here. Festa has a lot to overcome, but
earlier we saw a turn where we overcome
40 something might. So, it could still
be done.
>> It is possible. Brutalizer going to
certainly help the case here.
>> Mhm.
>> Getting to reattach and get a lot of
might very quickly. Looking like we're
going to exhaust the jacks.
>> That would be plus three to someone.
>> Yeah. Has to pay an extra energy here
for the top jack which you actually
haven't seen activated yet.
>> Mhm. That is very true. We will have to
see who we could potentially attach it
to. Uh obviously illusions can protect
them at some point. So yeah, it looks
like he is going for that first mate. I
don't think first mates usually see this
much action in the game, but this first
mate is a special mate for sure.
>> Yeah, got a G as well. And I think Supa
deciding that I'm actually just going to
recycle the rune here because I want the
extra energy. I feel like I'm going to
have to play quite a lot this turn to
get through the things that are in
Amando's hand. Again, Amanda has nine or
10 cards in hand. Even with not that
many runes, there's certainly some
tricks that could be played. So, trying
to cut down the might slowly but surely
here for Jax.
>> Yeah, and keeping up this legend also
does mean he can reattach one of those
uh gears equipment to one of these other
illusions to buff them to go into the
other battlefield as well. So, really,
really smart play by Sup Fiesta and
hopefully we'll get to see it come to
fruition as well.
>> Yeah, you're right. Actually, sorry,
it's not a guardian angel. I believe
it's uh the brutalizer that we saw and
the wars that's been ticking around. We
saw a G earlier, but Superfest are not
playing it just yet.
>> Yep. Can I can just barely make out the
text of brutalizer. I can't exactly read
it, but I can see there's enough lines
of text that that's what it says.
>> Yeah, I feel like it's always the little
might sign that that helps me figure it
out.
>> True.
>> All right, so going to be trading off
here. First mate's going to go down. As
you mentioned, there's more where that
came from here to re-equip and get it
going here for Jax. Punch first Guardian
Angel Ruin Runner I believe in hand
there for Supfiesta just spying the
cards and Aphelio the last card in this
fourcard hand.
>> Yeah and Draven's actually really down
on runes it looks like here and his hand
could be covering it to be fair.
>> Oh no, there's only two.
>> Okay, there's only two runes. Uh not
great only to be going four next turn,
but two up is still some options that
the Lucian is having to play around. So
I wouldn't be surprised if we see these
Lucians move one at a time to try to
bait out whatever those two runes are.
notably won a combat two for Draven as
well. So, of course, I'm going to get to
draw another card. Think Sufi just said
like, "Yeah, whatever. It doesn't
matter." Knows knows they have to do
something regardless. So, uh you know,
there's already 10 cards in there.
What's a couple more?
>> Yeah, for sure. Uh but that hand is
gigantic.
>> Lucian's only a seven right now. Three,
four. Yeah, only a seven versus the
eight with the shovel. Rasa just says,
"Okay, yeah, whatever you got." Oh,
never mind. Spinning axe.
>> Oh, spinning axes as well. We're really
committing to sorry is a bit bigger. Uh
so set seven's actually a nine. Here's
punch first. That's going to get us
through and uh super fiesta
>> going to at least be able to get a
trigger here. Get a point and get some
things off the battlefield.
>> And that is actually just like such a
strong play as well. We committed that
spinning axes to Rosa. Now, it's going
to have to go away because because it is
Sups's turn, we won't see it reattached
here to something else where, you know,
that spinning axe could be looped uh
more more efficiently.
>> Here's Lucian readying up. They're going
to go back to base.
>> Mhm.
>> Got a big stack of cards to keep neatly
over there. I appreciate that. Uh Sufi
has to clearly a season Jack player,
keeping the buffs and equipment very
well aligned. And now, Aelio is going to
come down. Another unit that benefits
from equipment. And you best believe
that Amados has to read that one cuz I
don't think you see a lot of Ailios.
>> I would have to read it as well. So,
thank you so much for putting it up on
screen. When you attach a equipment to
me, choose one that hasn't been chosen
this turn. And there's three options.
So, you actually could do this three
times technically in a turn.
>> Ready to run to channel one rune
exhausted or buff a friendly unit. A
kind of nice selection here. Uh lots of
different things. Not so much in combat,
but more for kind of getting giving you
more resources, which is nice. I feel
like at this stage of the game when Jax
has to really punch through these big
battlefields, it might be tough to get a
lot of value out of a fellow, but
there's also four might for four energy.
So, not a bad exchange there either.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. And you can see
probably so many different attachments
with that Jax leader, so we could see
some chain runes. We used just so many
runes to offer all those attachments
last turn and uh also buffs to help
potentially grow our different units
hopefully to be enough to break through
these battlefields and not go out 02.
>> So kind of a nice thing here for
Armando. Oh, Raster coming out from the
trash. The last rides
>> and all of a sudden I was going to say
we're up to seven points. You can maybe
hold one of these, maybe play for the
double conquer after saying I'm pretty
sure I've got this game. And I'm just
going to try and put as much might as I
can on these battlefields and see if you
can break both of them as second Rasa
enters the southern battlefield.
>> Ouch. Yeah. And we're going to have to I
mean this is like one of those problems,
right? We're doing a great job spreading
out the might and Lucian's not the
largest. Oh my gosh. Over hidden as
well. Armando, he's saying I dare you
and I'm not really sure is going to have
it.
>> It has to be D.
>> I don't see how you can break through
this. This is just the thing. And Draven
is going to win the game. Sufiesta gives
the fist bump to Arando. And Draven is
going to continue undefeated. Still live
for day two is our Jax player, but
finally takes a loss in round number
six.
>> What a fantastic game. I did not expect
Jax in. There's so many actually I did
not expect here uh for this round going
in 5-0. We saw Ari 5-0, Jax 5-0, Zero
Zero 5-0, Azir 5-0. So many great decks
here. And what a fantastic job are these
players.
>> Yeah, really cool deck. I think Jax is
something that people are going to like
look at, have fun with, maybe try and
explore a little bit more. Again,
awesome to see that a Jax is still alive
for day two. At the end of the day, we
can kind of see why Draven is the most
represented deck. It's pretty powerful.
>> Yeah, I mean, even without Miracle, he's
drawing so much with these different
combat wins. I mean, we didn't get to
talk about over Zas fan, but it's just a
fight or flight, and it can cause you to
draw more with Draven. That deck is so
well built to profit off of that
leader's ability.
>> Well, we've talked about Driven Well,
let's hear from the winner themselves uh
from that match.
>> All right, A undefeated took down jacks.
How did that match up feel?
>> Um, it was my first time playing against
it. Um, I guess that it was had a lot of
equipment. First time seeing that, but I
guess a lot of the bodies that I pushed
don't really care for the equipment, but
it was pretty interesting to play
against for sure.
>> Cool stuff. So, Draven, why Draven?
>> Um, I come from a Yu-Gi-Oh background,
and the miracle Draven just reminded me
most of a Yu-Gi-Oh deck, just comboing,
drawing your entire deck, and just
playing as many cards as possible.
>> So,
>> I love the folks coming from other
games, kind of just bringing what them
with you. It's It's so cool to see. How
are you enjoying the event overall?
>> Uh, the event's amazing. There's uh a
lot of things to do. There's a bunch of
stuff to look at, but um I wish we could
figure out time a bit better cuz it is
running a little long, but other than
that, I think we're good.
>> That's great. Awesome. Well, good luck.
You're undefeated. Keep on rolling.
>> All right. Thank you. Thank you as much.
>> And we are back. And I have bad news for
us today. It is unfortunately our last
time in the booth today. We will be back
tomorrow, but I have to say it's been
incredible so far for the rounds we've
covered. Yeah, I had so much fun getting
to Cassie today past Pastry and so many
great different decks to watch. I'm so
excited though to see what we're going
to see in day two and get to see those
awesome decks.
>> We're not going to get to day two just
yet cuz we're going to go play cuz we
have two more rounds still left of
Swiss. The hall has been packed with
people playing Ripbound. That is the
main event shot you just saw by the way,
but there are side events happening.
There's cut scene happening. Travis
Gaffford is playing too with people on
the side of it. I've seen a lot of
really cool folks and a lot of great
games of Ripbound. so far. So, I'm
excited by what's been happening. And
the best news is there's even more to
come.
>> So many awesome games to watch.
>> All right. Well, it's been a lot of fun
at Las Vegas. There's still two more
rounds of Riftbound to go. Don't go too
far away because there is many, many,
many more games coming your way.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Hey.
If you're enjoying the action here in
Vegas and you want to get involved, your
great first step after your Nexus
Tonight is a summoner skirmish at your
local store where you can play to win a
buy in an upcoming regional qualifier.
Go beyond and begin to qualify. Check
out
uvsgames.com/ribbound-organizedplay-organized-play
or use a QR code if you want to type
that in. It makes a little easier, too.
All right, welcome back to round seven
of the regional qualifier here in Las
Vegas. I'm Jim Davis. That's Kasanova.
We are now in the stretch run of players
trying to cement their place in day two
and to make for a really deep run.
>> I mean, yeah, this is kind of the the
end of the road, right? If you are X1
right now, you have to finish the job.
You've got to make get it done, right?
You cannot lose two more here. Being X2,
that's going to get you there, right?
Six wins, 18 points. There's weird cases
where you can have a bunch of draws, but
realistically, six wins, that's the
magic number that everyone's trying to
get to to make it to that day two, to
have a fighting chance to make it
towards that top eight. So, let's see
where our players are currently at with
our standings. Now, we've got a lot of
players at 6 and0 and uh at number one,
not a bad name.
>> Yeah, not a surprising one, let's be
honest. I mean, Prismaticism has been
popping off over and over again. Made
top 64 in Houston playing Teemo. And
then in Bolognia making that top eight
on the Miracle Draven on it once again
at the top of the standings. We saw
Manen earlier uh also, you know, playing
that Victor once more, still undefeated.
as we go through some more of these.
Talion, a really cool one. He he played
the entire uh China circuit uh coming
down playing uh a close teammate with
Randy. Going to be playing the same list
as Randy uh who has made you know the
top eight of the Bolognia regional as
well. Awesome. Do we have also Awesome
Ross is a a magic magic pro.
>> Nice. Cool to see that too. Page two,
what do we got?
>> Well, we still have Allen's EQ
undefeated. And also speaking of Randy,
Randy is undefeated. Uh, so the three
players who top aided Bolognia and have
now come to Las Vegas are all currently
undefeated here going into round seven.
>> Wow, weird skill game.
>> Who would have thought?
>> So, we see our 6 players dropping down
to 27th place. These are the players who
are playing to still be undefeated. We
have some draws also uh at 50 and1. A
great record, great place to be. Uh, but
the draw bracket can be a little weird
as you uh get paired with other players
who have draws. Might be slower decks.
And uh let's see if we have any more
players here on our standings board. Top
32 sounds good. So these are our 27
undefeated players. Uh they all want to
finish this day undefeated.
>> Exactly.
>> Of course. Uh making day two is great,
but you want to go in with that perfect
record so you have a little bit of
breathing room on day two and you can
kind of feel really good. You have a
great meal tonight, get a great night's
sleep, and come back tomorrow and try
and win the whole thing.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I mean, that's what
you're looking for, right? because going
X2 on the day might even eliminate you
from top eight, right? It's possible,
right? Some some amount of X's will make
it, but your breakers are going to be a
lot better if you take those losses
later in the round. So, every single one
of these players looking to uh escape
those losses for as long as physically
possible.
>> Yeah, absolutely. You always want to
keep your fate in your own hands. You
know, going into that last round or or
after the last round and feeling like,
oo, my breaker's going to hold, I don't
really know, is a really, really
stressful feeling. So, keep the ball in
your court, you know. So, we got a great
match for you here in round number
seven. We're going to hop down and see
what our players are up to as they walk
into the feature match area. Love the
stage here. Love the core. Good stuff.
And our players will be getting ready.
We'll see what decks we got for you.
Coming in with Draven. Draven. Pretty
good deck, right? Yeah, it's a pretty
strong one. We haven't seen a ton of it
today on the the broadcast. We've gotten
a little bit throughout the the day. I
mean, in the last match, we just saw one
take down a Jax. This is uh going to be
that mid-range variant, right? That is
characterized by not playing Ezreal and
Called Shot. Instead, having more room
in the deck for combat tricks, right?
So, you get to play three of fight or
flight, three of spinning axe, right?
You're getting to play the hard
bargains, the ride the winds, the
rebukes, all multiple copies of these
cards instead of where the miracle
variant has to make cuts. They start
trimming the number of these combat
tricks and trying to just find the
single copy that they need to close out
the game. see the dynamic duo here of
Kaisen Darius, but Pouty Porro kind of a
hold over from Origins, right?
>> Yeah, I think uh little Pouty Porro
trying to rear his cute little head uh
because of the amount of Ezreal uptick
that we're starting to see. Getting a
little bit more of that deflect in your
base is going to help out quite a bit.
>> Cool. So, cool. A little bit of
technology here for Spicy Noodles. And
Spic's opponent is going to be also
playing Draven. So, we have a one of the
more important matchups in the format in
a mirror, but not a true mirror.
>> Yeah. Uh so this is going to be the
miracle going up against that mid-range
two copies of Bushwack. We've been
seeing this more and more. I especially
like the two copies when you are playing
the uh noturn variant. Uh because you're
having these additional setups that you
can make, especially in the second cycle
of the game where you put the nocturns
back on the bottom via your last rights,
your shovel, which we do see in the
sideboard. Uh then you try and reummon
them, but you play it as a combo where
you get the bushwack out. you know the
noctturns are there when you cast the
call shot and then you're able to flood
the board with these fours that are
pseudo accelerated by the bushwack.
Yeah, this is really cool. One of my
favorite things in this game is that
when you think of a legend like, "Oh,
I'm playing Draven. Cool. That's my
deck." But seeing the the huge amount of
variation between two different Draven
decks now see them go against each
other. What kind of makes the matchup,
you know, where you have mid-range
Draven versus Miracle Draven? What how
does it go? Yeah, I think one of the big
things that you see is the uh the
miracle variation gets to kind of like
for lack of a better term here because I
just vomit a bunch of might on the
board, right? Like that is kind of where
they go. They they just put as much
might on the board as possible. Uh
however, there are just more combat
tricks available for the mid-range
Draven. So, sometimes they're able to
chip away at the might with very
favorable trades uh instead of like just
going for a full trade. like they'll be
on less might baseline, but maybe
they'll get a spinning axe trade where
their Draven gets to kill off, you know,
a uh battering ram for free. And then
they're going to acrue value in that way
and continue to draw and find more of
these tricks to try and steal more of
these fights throughout the game. Uh
because they're not going to win just on
the sheer numbers. They're going to win
from the trickiness.
>> Would you say that the the miracle
version has a higher ceiling and a lower
floor?
>> Uh yeah, I mean I would say so, right?
Like if you miss your draw engines in
the miracle version, it is possible for
you to break. It's pretty low odds of
that happening. The deck just has so
much like redundant draw that you end up
getting there and the card selection
helps you kind of find the next draw
piece to continue on. Uh but the floor
of missing that early on,
>> you're going to kind of get run over by
the mid-range Draven just going two into
four into continuing to develop the big
things, especially if they can start
finding uh mind spplitters. That could
be really important in the matchup.
Trying to start stealing some of the uh
like card draw engines and stranding the
miracle hands.
>> All right. Well, we got a fist bump. We
are off to go here. We've got ZH Warren
on Kalor's side and Revers Row on Spicy
Duel's side and rocking and rolling
getting all ready to roll and Galore
with just two runes and a pass. Yeah,
but I did see a seal and a called shot
being picked up in that hand. So, I
think we're kind of off to the races on
the miracle side of things. You can skip
turn one. Who cares? You're just looking
for Ezreal uh as soon as possible. And
realistically, turn two can just be
Draven. Turn three, the ideal for Kor
here is going to be play the seal, play
the Ezreal, play the cult shot, and
then, you know, ram, ram, ram, and we're
we're going.
>> All right, sounds great. And then we got
a little more modest on uh on Spice
side. We got Overzealous Fan, little
stack deck action. Nice to have the the
ability to play the stack deck and the
two drop on the draw. But as you said,
here's Draven. So Draven kind of the
scripted play for turn two and then turn
three is the possible fireworks. Yeah,
it really is like when you look at
Miracle Draven, it it is pretty
formulaic for how it likes to start,
right? Turn turn one you you can play a
two drop if you've got one. Uh often the
decks are very light on it. It's maybe
like three copies of twos. Some of them
are more on like six, but it's not that
many. So, you'll miss fairly often. Then
on turn two, you just play Draven from
the Chancellor. Don't think about
anything. Don't try and get fancy. Just
play Draven from the Chancellor. Turn
three and onwards, this is when we can
start to combo off. This is when we can
start to consider trying to really go
for it. It's not always correct to just
go on turn three. Sometimes you just do
a light develop continue from there and
wait until you have some more runes to
really explode. Uh or more pieces of the
combo. Like I actually see a hopeful in
hand. So there's a chance that he just
kind of goes like stacked hopeful
hopeful pass and then next turn looks
for the really big play. Uh but three
and onwards is when you can actually go.
>> So kind of a interesting turn here for
spicy noodles. uh playing Kai'Sa
unacelerated instead of Draven. Uh
>> yeah, generally it is just the Draven
going for the Kai'Sa because wanting to
keep up in cards often you'll fall very
behind in miracle when it comes to card
advantage and so I kind of like the idea
of just going for the Kai'Sa though.
Let's take a look at this miracle turn.
It looks like he decides to go off uh
it's stacked double seal. My my thought
is it's very likely that there are going
to be some amount of rams in this hand
which is why he's going for this already
especially cuz we're not seeing an
Ezreal. So this is a a full cost called
shot that's coming through and it looks
like that was an Ezreal choice next to a
seal. This next choice called shot and
I'm look I I missed the other card but
the called shot was the clear take
>> quickly taken as well. So kind of ready
for that firework turn. We got double
seal
>> stack deck called shot.
>> We got a noxious hopeful coming in
>> and not done yet. How about another
noxious
>> hopeful play this turn
>> and counting the cards played
>> looks like five to me.
>> So we got a ram coming in for one. Of
course it can never cost uh less than
one which I think is a good good balance
knob to have on there
>> and Draven just staying home passing the
turn. So not a lot of aggression here in
this first few turns for either player.
>> Yeah, I would say not the the craziest
pop off but having the early seals is
quite nice. And then this is still a
development of 13 might which is you
know quite powerful for turn three. It's
It's nothing to scoff at, but uh you
know, when I saw him starting to go for
this without an Ezreal, I was actually
expecting a bit more. I was expecting a
couple more Rams potentially when you're
going to go for the double seal pre-
Ezreal uh go for the called shot. Uh but
considering the amount of cards left in
hand, it feels like he's stuck on this
like kind of double hopeful play. And
instead of waiting one more turn and
just going stacked hopeful, hopeful, and
then kind of play from there, decides to
to this is the time to try and get the
ram out as well.
>> 13 not enough for you, huh? Not to be
honest when I when I when I'm talking
about the this miracle deck. Not really
cuz I actually think if he saw knock
turns in these called shots I I'm not
even confident that he should tread his
runes for it. And I that's why maybe
would have liked to wait like an
additional turn because if he saw the
noturn turns I really want to play them
but because you're going on this turn
that you played the seals it ends up
meaning you're going to burn more runes
to your your recycling at that point
instead of being able to use the seals.
>> Okay. So we see we see Kai'Sa go into
Rever's row.
>> Yeah. conquer draw a card. Now we're
seeing a ride the wind to go into the
zon. So reavers row and then into zon
wars and then back out.
>> We're going home. Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely
love uh using the ride the wind like
this. Uh you know you're not outiting
and this uh informs us why the Kai'Sa
was played on the last turn as well. Has
the ride the wind in hand already. I
would I can assure you. And looking to
go for the double draw, get a little bit
of filter with those on Warren. Get to
go home and then he's just going to look
for a development turn. uh you want to
just keep building your board. If you
can get as close as possible to the
might of miracle, we already talked
about how you're going to have more
combat tricks, you're going to shred
less runes, you're going to have more
runes, and you'll be able to actually
start playing these fights efficiently
to take better trades even if you are
less might baseline.
>> So, the the counterplay for regular
Draven or mid-range Draven is kind of
okay, you do your thing, you put a whole
bunch of stuff in play, I can do that,
too. I might be able to do it. I have to
do it a little bit more slowly. Then
once we actually get into a combat
scenario, I have the advantage. Yeah.
Yeah. Like you're on four runes, I'm on
eight. Here's my spinning axe. Spinning
axe. Oh, you spinning axe one. I'll
rebuke your guy. And now I'm I'm in
there cuz you don't have enough
resources uh that are going to be
helping you in combat when you just have
the flap might, right? So, the math
problem becomes easy for the mid-range
Draven because he gets to see all your
might and the math problem becomes quite
difficult for the uh miracle Draven
because uh his opponent's might is
obscured. Okay, so Noodles has now gone
through and drawn a couple cards. And it
looks like Draven is coming in out of
the champ zone. That is a little more
and a stack deck. Why not? So, a little
bit more setup. Happily uh getting set
up in the back row here with a decent
amount of might and resolve a stack deck
and then pass on through and we'll see
what Callor's followup's going to be. It
was a pretty explosive turn. Question is
going to be more fireworks.
So noodles of is of course is up 200
here with the early point lead.
>> Yeah, not seeing the choice from spicy
noodles, but I think if he has units in
hand, the big thing you're looking for
are the spinning axes. And then from
there, I would say like fighter flights
and rebukes are pretty nice overall.
Like rebuking battering ram uh is is
generally quite okay because
>> it's it's expensive to like rego off and
and replay it. Uh but especially if you
can hold on to something like a rebuke
for when your opponent plays that
spinning axe to try and blow it out.
>> All right, so fireworks are here once
again. Here comes Ezreal discarding a
fight or flight draw two. Now we see a
called shot. That cost reduction from
Ezreal and uh the cards just keep on
flowing.
>> Question is, can we see more might add
to the battlefield in somewhat dramatic
fashion like last turn? Yeah, didn't
discard an Octturn and then we haven't
seen an Octturn and we've done a lot of
looking. I think we probably are going
to be able to find one soon enough off
of more of these searches.
>> I think I saw one in there and that's a
that's a good call out.
>> Yeah, maybe not. Okay, never mind.
>> Yeah, I I suppose not. I I saw Rosa was
in that decision. I'm wondering if it
went back to the bottom.
>> All right, so still churning through
here.
>> Now it's time for some combat. Rand
comes in on warrants.
We got a point. We got more churn,
discard, and a draw.
>> Scrappy.
>> Scrappy. So, draw two more cards.
>> The velocity of this deck is
unbelievable.
>> Yeah, the
>> ability just to see so many cards over
the course of these, you know, first two
turns.
>> I play called shot and stack deck only.
>> Okay. Really looking to find ram. He
said he played stack deck and called
shot only, but I believe Ezreal was also
played on this turn.
>> Correct. So, that' be three. This would
be four. So, he should be able to go ram
ram with the last two energy. You can
>> saw Rossa was the pick there.
There's another Ezreal and a scrap peep.
Don't like seeing those together. You
really want to actually be able to grab
the scrap peep off of this called shot,
but if he has no Ezreal in hand, then
not going to get that chance. Uh but
yeah, two energy should be ram ram if he
has it. But it looks like it's going to
be stacked instead. So just one single
ram going to come down.
>> Noturn, where are you, my friend?
>> There's the last ram. Can add it to
hand, but this is, you know, another
turn where you played a lot of cards and
you're not going to have another good
chance. I saw the spinning axe that
starts to look a little bit more
attractive to try and match some of
these fights. Uh as of right now, this
ram might just be forfeit unless you go
for a bigger stack and we are going to
see second battering ram come down. I
think you're going to have to commit
more than that if you want to try and
hold this on Warren. And this is where
things get dangerous. Miracle tap out no
energy. You're going to pass to all of
these runes for mid-range. And while
this is 18 might, that is a very large
number. There's already 10 here for
spicy noodles. And what are we going to
be? Eight runes.
>> Wow. Yeah, this is this is this looks
risky. Um yeah, very unsafe
>> possibility for disaster. And then uh
the Draven stays home, not going into
Reaver's Row. Is that just Galore saying
I don't want to give you a card?
>> Yeah, I think generally uh trying to
deny the cards from the mid and Raven is
going to be good. That's like where one
of your big advantages is. You'll be
just ahead on cards. You can try and
starve him out. I also think that point
tempo doesn't matter in this matchup.
It's just control. It's just like board
control. If your board position is
better, you're going to win. There's
you, especially when the points are this
low. If someone's been really racing it
and pushing the tempo very high, then
you have to start thinking about it. But
we're one to two. It really is just
who's going to get the board position
and then they're going to be able to
close out the game.
>> Yeah, very cool to see. We've seen a
number of uncontested battlefields this
game, not moved into. So, both players
kind of recognizing the pacing
>> and we got a discard of a noturn. This
is for the the warren, right? Uh yeah, I
must have missed the trigger earlier.
Judges have them correcting it because
this is a mandatory trigger. Skipping it
can be considered, you know, like
advantageous for you to skip it.
>> Correct.
>> There plenty of times Riot saw Warren
and did not want to discard a card.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> I had to move in. So,
>> so first move for Spicy is going to be
Kai'Sa coming into the reaver's row.
Going to get a point and a card. And
again, like you mentioned, there are
eight runes available and a good amount
of cards in hand for Spicy Noodles while
Kamor is just uh kind of exhausted. My
initial bet is that he actually can't
break 18, which is why the Kaisa has
gone into the reaver's row. Uh the the
other side of that is that uh you know,
you could just be looking to draw more
cards and you're not worried about uh
galore just having like one turn hanging
out on Z on Warren. The the big reason
that if you think if you can break it,
you would is because of the fact that
like okay, your opponent is tapped out
this turn. So if I can break 18, I will
trade like a good amount of my board to
just like break this 18,
>> right? because so much of the work that
has been done in the last few turns is
that it's just drawing the cards to get
the rams in play, get these uh noxious
hopeless in play, too. So undoing that
is kind of nice.
>> And you can't full trade. So he would
need to be better than 18 for it to
actually feel good. If you just go 18
into 18, you don't get the Draven draw
and then your opponent is still on
Draven Ezreal backline and they're
playing shovel. They have you you do
have to be ready for like three Rosses
to land on the board immediately on this
next turn. There's definitely 10 things
in the bin at this point. So, you know,
breaking it is not free. You are going
to have to do some amount of trading and
it's really about finding a good way to
break it where you're going to get to
gain some resources, not burn too many
runes. There's a lot of factors that you
have to consider when you go to break
this 18.
>> All right. Well, here's a uh a Darius
ready to rock and rollied up and pumped
up. So, we've got potentially seven on
the Darius, potentially six on the
Draven, and do a little math here.
Little little finger tap math. The TCG
player classic.
>> Yeah. So stack Darius, I mean Kais
already ran in. So this is uh 6 plus 7
13 uh spinning ax isn't getting there.
Rebuke uh can get you to a tie, but uh
as we said, tie is not good enough in
this spot.
>> Fans hanging out also, so the fan could
come in, but it's still a pretty
devastating loss of resources. Was it
Draven and Darius
>> and then leaving the fan on the warrant
just to get eaten by
>> Yeah. and you're you're having to burn
another red rune to do this anyway. Uh
it's it I would say it's probably not
worth it. I would say just continuing to
develop. Like if he's got a two drop,
I'm just like jamming the two drop and
saying you can draw off of pushing my
heist off of Reavers and let's let's
slow down the game. I'll find a better
spot. Uh unfortunately, you might not
get another chance whereas completely
tapped out, but realistically you're
still going to be overall ahead in
combat tricks and rune volume as the
game continues on.
All right, so Spice D is really thinking
this one through. You know, we are in
round seven. These players have been
playing for a long time and uh that edge
the weight of feature match area. Also
being five and one, you you kind of know
you're on the edge. You kind of know if
you take that second loss, you might be
in a spot where you're, you know, even
if you win out, you're on tiebreers. So,
it's a trustful spot. And we're going to
see decision being
>> I mean hopeful is like best case
scenario in my mind right now.
>> Yep. Just just numbers.
>> See just like the the best numbers that
you can get here.
box is so good.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Okay. Falling star. I
>> It's not like I don't like it. I just
don't like damping this much.
>> Going to say, yeah, that rune advantage
is no longer there now. Down to four
runes. Does take down a Draven. Uh but
at a pretty heavy cost.
>> I mean, yeah, the rune advantage is
entirely gone. Your own Draven cannot be
pumped. So, you just have to go for
something like this. I like uh the idea
of the Overzilla's fan. Um you are
denying just like an immediate pivot
though. I will say, you know, Bushwack
is a hell of a card in this miracle
deck. We've seen the entire deck pretty
much at this point. I have to imagine
Bushwack multiple Rossas is within the
range of what can happen on this turn.
Uh we did just see it get drawn. I
actually don't see that many Rosses in
hand. I think was looking knows this
game goes long looking for the second
cycle roses which I think is very
reasonable uh when you're playing
against mid-range Draven. Um I'm not
entirely sure what the whole bin
collection is for this Fizz. So we're
going to see
>> a peak.
>> Well, that one makes sense.
>> Going for call shot. All right.
>> Yeah, I could have guessed that one
actually.
>> So few more cards. There's a knock. All
right. Finally found the knockturn.
>> Yeah.
>> And just again more numbers on the
board. get to play Noctturn when you
reveal it.
>> They have power. Put that thing right
into play. Very fun.
>> Another one.
>> Oh, yeah. So, I mean I mean this makes
sense, right?
>> Yeah, we knew they were coming.
>> Yeah, we we've seen a lot of cards for
not seen these yet. Uh so, no turns are
coming in and uh definitely a high
variance card. One that's quite
explosive. Fits the bill for this deck.
>> Less variance when you have
>> 16 looks,
>> right? For for sure.
>> As you saw, you know, we went through a
number of turns that without finding
one. So,
>> so just added, you know, just a casual
eight might to the Z warns.
>> Yeah.
>> Now we see another battering ram. The
third copy.
>> 13 might this turn.
>> Yeah,
>> those counting at home.
>> Just 13 again.
>> Yeah,
>> you know, lucky.
>> We can add a little more. We can do a
little better than that.
>> All right. How about uh a hidden card as
well. So
>> now a hidden card on Amazon warrants and
uh glor's at two, I believe, not one. Uh
yeah, cuz the hold should be at two,
>> right? So score and then hold. So So two
and noodles at three now. What is plan
as far as stocking this battlefield up
so heavily being behind in points.
>> Um so the nocturns have ganking. Uh
little did some people know. I know some
miracle players who played an entire uh
tournament at Bolognia didn't realize
that their knocks had ganking. Uh they
found out after they were like, "Wow,
that's crazy. I still made day two. Um,
but I I I think that is a way that you
can continue to look to attack this
reaver row. You're stacking really well.
You've got the noctturns there. If your
opponent crashes like all of their units
in to kill your noturns, you're probably
still having a good time. Cuz if we look
at the base, it's 16 might. Like 16
might is going to be able to contest
reavers row in most cases. I think right
now there hasn't been enough development
on the side of mid-range Draven for me
to feel very good about the spot. and
Galora has been able to find
positioning. Uh this is a huge stack.
You're not getting free trades here.
That is one of the big things that you
need to be able to find with mid-range
Draven are these favorable trades where
you get to push over, you know, the 10
might of two batting rams or 14 might or
even that 18 might spot that's beatable
by Draven. You can get there, but you
kind of have to take find those
opportunities and be able to get over
the top and deal with some of the units
before we hit this critical mass. This
development turn is like exactly what I
wanted to see on the previous turn.
Right.
>> Yeah. Now it might be too late. We'll
see.
>> Yeah. A hunter, a noxious, and uh and a
fan. I mean,
>> played a similar number of cards to call
to the board, but they're all much
smaller.
>> Yeah. And this is where cards like
Switcheroo really come into into play.
Like your treasure hunter is a really
cheap unit that later your combat tricks
get to really increase the value of
where that switcheroo becomes a eight
might swing into a batgram or a 10 might
swing into a roasa which is a great way
to start breaking some numbers.
>> All right. Well, Ezra will get played at
this uh very popular z warrants. It's
the place to be. Yeah. you know, it's uh
party's over here and we see the third
seal still a grip full of cards and Glor
is looking pretty good in this game and
these knock turns should be ready. They
can just gank over uh if if he wanted to
be able to to conquer the reaver's row
on this turn. Yeah.
>> Um but if not, you can also just kind of
send a Fizz in or an Ezreal in and just
grab the point. Um I think allowing the
draw at this point to start getting onto
point cadence as the Miracle Draven is
actually quite reasonable. I'm I'm okay
with maybe giving one draw to to Draven
in this spot. Um unless he wants to
start to full commit to a double hold
because of the amount of might, but that
feels a little bit risky, a little bit
soft to the amount of might that's on
the board for Spicy Noodle.
>> Okay, so
Galore is uh going to best turn. So we
got no uh Revers Row, the party's
happening is on Warren. Reaver row
revers row is uh kind of sitting there
twidding the thumbs waiting for somebody
to show up, you know. So back noodles
his way. Bunch of units in play. We got
a fan, a Kai'Sa, a Noxful, treasure
hunter, a Darius. That's Draven hiding
under there, right? And then another
Noxville, but Kaisa's coming in. So
Kai'Sa says, "I'll start the party of
the Reapers Row.
>> I'd like to draw."
>> Yeah.
>> Draw another card. And a fistful of card
for Spicy Noodles. And like you were
saying, a lot of tricks, a lot of runes
up now, too. We've kind of redeveloped
in the last few turns.
And now the question is, how do you
break this ridiculous stack of
partygoers in the zone?
>> Yeah, I'm not seeing a good way in hand
right now. Still some kind of more
units, not as many tricks as I'd like to
see. Uh no switcheroo, which is really
notable cuz it starts to make these uh
treasure hunters look pretty sad, right?
That that that's just one might unless
you find a switcheroo. Then suddenly,
oh, that's the best card in the game is
there is your treasure hunter at home.
So I do think developing the mind
spplitter makes sense. I'm not sure how
I feel about uh developing it to
Reavers. I I feel like now you're kind
of
>> committing to losing one of these units.
Uh it'll still trade for some amount of
might. Miracle usually doesn't get the
like free trades to come through.
They're going to give you some might for
it, but they're going to get the better
deal at the end of the day,
>> right?
>> So, we're going to see uh spinning ax
and responsive mind.
>> Y
>> going to come down and before the uh
>> discard happens,
>> it's going to hop on over to one of the
knock turns. So, a little ganking action
perhaps.
>> Yeah. And I agree, it does seem a little
weird to play this mindsitter onto the
reaver's row with the Kai'Sa unless
there are plans to move other things
there too maybe and like kind of start
start noodles his own stack.
All right, so one Rossa in hand. Fizz
can still find another called shot and
I'm pretty sure he finds Rosa Rossa on
this next called shot. Uh based on some
of the earlier bottoms of cards, I don't
think we saw one discarded. Uh they must
have gone in some of the early looks
that we didn't fully see. Um so
It it feels like with the redundancy of
the bushwacks, you don't really care
about those. You're going to leave
those. I really think that you want to
deny further looks. Like this is what
you're already dealing with. You
probably just have to get rid of Fizz.
Uh cuz if you get rid of Rossa
reasonably, there's still two more
Rossas coming from Fizz being played and
getting the draws. Then you're going to
find the other Rossas. They're going to
get bushwacked in.
>> And so this is one roster you have to
deal with. Two more that are in the deck
that you'll find later. Uh, but the
bushwacks are a lot less exciting when
the board is already like this. They
don't really do anything. And then the
traveling merchant, I mean,
>> you know what? What's that guy going to
get? He's he's a little too dropped
>> compared to what's happening. It's a
little late. Yeah. So,
>> you know,
>> Fizz is the correct choice. I think
>> him and treasure hunter are hanging out
in the corner of the party like, "Hey,
do they know that we're here, too?"
>> Yeah. They're both looking for their
little pet gremlin switcheroo thing,
whatever that is. And if you can't find
it, then they're not doing much.
>> All right, it's pileup time. So,
Noodles, Noodles is at five and Galore
is at three. So, now you've got this
kind of split board where each player
has a ton of might stacked up. A little
hard to count uh Noodles numbers cuz
they are they are stacked up pretty
well. Look at that. It's almost like you
heard me. And uh but now but now what?
So, Noodles is at five. Kalora is going
to four. So, if this were to stay
exactly like this, Noodles would win.
So, what is the what's next step?
>> So, of course, still having the
Noctturns there that can gank over. So
that is 11 might that is currently on
the Warren that can be added to what's
at base. So we have 11 there. We have
another 10 from the battering rams.
That's 21. You add another six from the
two there and that's 27.
>> That's a lot.
>> Uh I think that's already currently
winning uh the the send in. Now of
course overzel's fan gets to push back
the seven which is your biggest amount.
Puts you back down to 20. Uh then it
gets a little bit closer after the fact
and there's a spinning ax in the hand
for spicy noodles. Plus, he knows that
doesn't have any tricks that actually
are going to affect this. However, I
wonder if he did the math of bushwack
into Rosa into traveling merchant an
additional plus two. It's it could be
relevant when you're looking at just
this big of a fight. But uh without
going through and doing every single
point of math for both sides, my uh
expert opinion here in this moment, Jim,
is that uh I do think Galore is overall
going to be ahead. But we are seeing a
uh traveling merchant played then moved
to get rid of a second Bushwack.
>> Did he know the top of his deck? That's
the big question for me. I didn't have
the full count of the stack, but I know
we have Rosses coming up. So the
merchant, if the goal there was to draw,
could have gone into the reaver's row
and attacked the fan.
>> Absolutely. He should have, but I think
he did know there was a Ross on top cuz
he did just rip one, which is going to
add to this. I I I'm fully with you.
Didn't want to give a card draw, but I
don't think that matters. I think you
could have absolutely sent it in. Just
said, "I would like to kill the fan."
And then you wouldn't have to deal with
it. I I'm 100% with you. I think that is
a just maybe a slight mistake trying to
play too fast. Probably knowing that he
had the Rasa on top and wanting to be
like, "Oh yeah, I just want to get this
Rasa." and he was kind of playing too
quickly and not thinking about that uh
exact play line with the the fans at
>> too busy counting up all of these
numbers. So we got the party the parties
moved houses. All right, the cop showed
up at the the zone wars that broke the
party up and now party's over at
Reaver's Row and we've got Noctturn,
Noctturn, Raza, Raza, Ezreal, double ram
a Fizz air under the bottom of the stack
and a spinning axe on there too.
>> I can't count that high. I'm sorry.
>> Yeah. No, it's a lot. Um my my experted
opinion is it's a lot. Okay. Uh yeah. Uh
I do think this was cool for Calor. I I
was pretty confident the Rossas were the
next few cards. I and seeing the the
speed in which he decided to go bushwack
traveling merchant move it and then uh
you know discard draw rasa. I I feel
like he did know that was the Rasa. And
so uh we we did see them bottomed early
on in the game. This is this is really
really well done. uh making sure that he
knows the stack and getting ready to
play that second cycle game that you
kind of need in the miracle Draven
versus mid-range Draven matchup where
the game likes to bog down a lot and you
need to know what your next cycle is. We
might even see the last rights come in
and you can even play for that second
cycle uh setup of knockturns with the
bushwacks as well which is really really
good and really potent when you can pull
it off.
>> Yeah. So make clear second cycle means
the cards that were bottomed on turn two
on turn three of these called shots and
these stack decks
>> a really good player can kind of keep
track of that
>> kind of keep it in their head okay
what's what's down how many far cards
down am I and they'll know on turn six
and seven what's coming up be able to
plan for that which is a very difficult
thing to do uh something I'm not very
good at uh you know uh but these players
are in the future match area for a
reason and doing a great job and really
stocking up that might with that
bushwack so big kind of combo turn huge
combat
And just eyeballing it, it looks like a
much bigger number on the right side of
the screen.
>> Yeah, it feels like the guys on the
right side are larger than the guys on
the left side.
>> Yep. Yep. Yeah.
>> And being big is good.
>> So, uh we'll see. We'll see how it all
shakes out. We got the the splitter
there in there also. Uh
>> is it Darius? Is that a D? Is that D?
Dven also. Yeah, D is also. So, we we
got a D.
>> Oh, he's hiding underneath there. He's
under the Overzel fan.
>> He's sneaky.
>> Yeah. So, as we expected, overzealous
fan pop. That's going to send home the
Noctturn. That was for seven. That was
the largest unit there with the the
spinning axe on it. Um, from there, I
mean, Draven trigger, I assume he's
taking that. So, it's going to go to
six.
>> 31 to 32.
>> 31 to 32. Wow. It's closer than I
expected.
>> Yeah, I expected.
>> Draven the SP is pretty big, too.
>> And uh there is two energy available for
Spice. Here comes the spinning axe.
Okay. So, if it is if the 31 31 to 32
number was correct as we heard in our
our earpieces from our players, spinning
ax seems like it goes over that.
>> Now, these guys are bigger than those
guys. The ones on the left are bigger
than the ones on the right. And we know
that just doesn't have anything here,
right? We we saw the hand from that mine
spplitter. Spicy knows it too.
>> Just kidding.
>> Where did this rebuke come from?
>> Found a rebuke.
>> Where did this draw? What What draw did
I miss?
>> Target is going to be
>> I mean drop for turn. The merchant draw.
Yes. I miss it. Yeah. Draw for turn.
>> So, we are factoring in the merchant
draw for the Raza, but not the uh not
the
>> There it is. Okay.
>> And there you go. You uh you can't mind
splitter of the top of the deck. Uh so,
a puke comes in, breaks this all up.
>> So, now the guys on the right side are
bigger than the guys on the left side.
>> We We need a little seesaw, you know,
like.
>> All right. And now with Spice totally
exhausted, combat's going to go down.
It's not going to go down very well. So,
you have to pick the things that uh that
will be killed going out.
uh but going to be a point for and kind
of a dominating position.
>> Yeah, I mean from here it becomes very
difficult for mid-range to ever crawl
back and there's the snowballing factor
of Glorious Executioner as well where
Glor is now also going to draw a card uh
off of this as well and and Spicy Nules
losing all these units, exhausting a lot
of the resources. Uh it is his turn if
he has like if he could play another
unit uh then he'd be able to equip the
uh the spinning ax or sorry it's not his
turn so he can't like the spinning axes
are just gone right there's no way to
actually get those reattached anything.
>> Um and from there still has a large
amount of might left on the board.
>> Right. And Noodles's deck a little more
pace doesn't have that miracle engine to
kind of just wow here's a bunch more
stuff. So I agree it's going to be a
tough spot.
>> Noodles.
Yeah,
>> little uh time and space there.
>> He's he's not able to go Ezreal. Uh call
shot call shot uh ram ram ram knockturn
and then try and try and win from here.
The deck just does not get to do that.
>> Yep. So also that huge knock turn still
in base two. The hidden card still on
the on the zon. So here's Kaiisa. It's
going to be accelerated.
>> So coming in and going to threaten the
knock turn. We'll see reverse row
trigger happen first. No turn scared.
Want to retreat potentially, you know,
little combat trick here. I can only
assume a spinning axe probably in the
future.
>> Yeah, I have to assume there's
something. You can also just kind of
bluff it as spicy noodles cuz you're so
far behind. You just say, "Yeah, yeah,
this is a spinning axe." Yeah, it it's
definitely a spinning axe. Trust me.
Trust me,
>> it definitely is. So, we see three axes
in the graveyard. No, I'm just kidding.
But, um, so now decide, okay, uh, am I
okay point? Probably are. I think even
you know even if it's a bluff I think
it's fine right a lot of might in the
back row concede the card
it is two cards to be fair kaisa draw
draven draw still a lot of cards in hand
for spicy noodles but only two energy
available right now kind of hard to just
deploy stuff fast enough
>> yeah it gets really difficult here uh
losing the energy earlier from the
falling star definitely a big deal uh
there is still the fact that it did
clear a Draven. So you you cleared six
might that could potentially be more
gold generation could be just even more
might potentially if you have to have
multiattacks in a single turn, right?
And so the falling star is often still
quite good in the Draven matchup, but I
feel against miracle, you know, spending
two runes, recycling two runes to deal
with one unit that this deck puts out
feels pretty underwhelming. and I'd
rather kind of have like this vast
amount of runes to to continue to
develop through the game. I don't think
that's the difference maker in this game
entirely, but we are kind of hitting
that point where you're trying to refill
the board. And uh wouldn't you love to
have four runes here to play like
another Kaiser, another bigger unit or
two hopefuls or you know something that
a little bit more substantial.
>> Yeah, falling star mostly going to be
effective against the kind of filler
units, the traveling potions, the Ezreal
have already kind of done their job
>> and uh we're going to see no here.
>> We're going to see a hidden card also.
So Noodle is going to make the last
stand here at the Reb Row it looks like
with the hopeful and the Kai'Sa and the
the hidden card probably a fight or
flight
>> I would imagine so uh the other the
other option really being the the
switcheroo um you know it could be edge
of knight I don't think we saw one in
this exact version uh this time around
I'm trying to remember but
>> I think there was one
>> yeah if there's one yeah it could be
edge of knight as well the ranges on the
hiddens for D mid Draven are always kind
of difficult to play around cuz it's
like fighter fight okay that's just a
push that's fine And like I know, you
know, all my might from that one unit is
gone.
>> Well, we're going to find out right now.
So, Nocturns aren't being shy here. They
are coming right in.
>> And that is uh 4 8 9 11 might
>> coming into eight. So, you know who's
going to act first. It is fighter
flight. Surprise.
>> Bargain uh does just say no thank you.
>> Okay.
>> Trade offer. Uh you don't play your
fight orflight and I win the game.
>> That is it.
>> Well, I guess he takes the trade offer.
>> All right. Great stuff for Color.
>> That is a hard bargain. And uh yeah,
really really cool game honestly getting
to see the Miracle Draven D kind of
really do its thing. Really put a lot of
might in play and great stuff with
Knockturns too. They were a little late
to the party, but they were fashionably
late.
>> They showed up precisely when they meet.
>> Exactly. All right, so we're going to
game number two here with Galore up a
game. Obelisk of Power going to be the
battlefield of choice for Galore into
Targon's peak. Obelisk of Power is is a
weird one. Talk to me about Obis Power.
Yeah. So, usually just in in Draven in
general, Oblisk wants to be your go
second battlefield. So, you can start
your first turn by just playing Draven.
Uh, so after you win a game, you present
Obisk. Uh, we see this in kind of both
variations because Miracle also would
just love to side out all their twos to
then play instead their sideboard cards
that are good for for tech. Uh, and so
for this go second game, you know, your
first turn, I'm on four runes, I play
Draven, I need no twos in my deck. Twos
are bad. I get rid of twos. We don't
like them.
>> Okay. Well, you're here for Noodles. uh
not being on those magical four runes.
It's Tally Merchant, I'm sorry, treasure
hunter, sorry.
And we see as as predicted, turn one,
Draven.
Draven comes down early and often
typically.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Is just going to come
down immediately. And then now, I mean,
this is turn two that you can start kind
of looking for your your big combo
turns. Uh again, I'm I'm kind of bigger
on waiting an additional turn in a lot
of matchups, especially the ones that
are a little slower. you can play for
that next cycle which the midtering
draven match up tends to be a little bit
more slow and methodical. I do think
that Glor going off worked out totally
fine in that last one. The double seal
ends up accuring a lot of value and I
don't think he had double hopeful until
he started going off and I think that's
you know that's where he probably didn't
have enough things to fully play in hand
and wanted to find things cuz he had a
lot of draw to him. So it worked out
quite well as we are going to see
treasure hunter just going to grab that
target's peak. targets peak really good
go first battlefields for Draven so that
you can refresh the runes and play
defense a lot more effectively.
>> Yeah, speaking to the fact that there's
more tricks, more things available, a
little little bit of Annie action there
where you get to to ready up two and
then have all those two energy tricks.
But see gold up the hunter and then next
step four runes available. Draven of
course is hanging out in the champ zone
but
little pump fake there.
Going to think it through down a game
high pressure match again. 5-1. These
players are playing deep into the day.
Want to make good run tomorrow. Big
match for both players and we are going
to see. Don't pump fake me again. Spicy
noodles.
All right. Overzealous fan joins the
party. So just a fan and a hunter.
>> That's surprising.
>> And then we're going to see the Targon's
ready and a pass.
>> So declining the Draven, leaving up
these runes for possible interaction.
stacking up two rather weak units on one
battlefield which feels risky.
>> Yeah, a bit of an underwhelming develop
for that turn, right? Uh gonna have four
runes available. Yes, probably going to
dissuade Color from moving into the
Targon's Peak. But I think if I'm
playing Miracle Draven on the other
side, I just say, "All right, that's
cool. I'll just avoid this for now. I
mean, you got four runes up. Clearly,
you got something." and I'll just kind
of play my game, redevelop, develop kind
of a a massive board and say, "All
right, well, you kind of just wasted two
runes on this last turn." Um, I do
think, you know, there's some scariness
to developing Draven onto the peak, even
just untapping two. Often, you're
flipping the game in the mirror when you
decide to kind of go for that develop
aggressively onto the board instead of
just developing backline and and playing
slower and a little bit more
methodically. Uh, but against Miracle,
sometimes it's less of a flip because
they won't have as many combat tricks
and you might be able to get away with
it.
>> All right, we'll call shot. He's calling
through.
>> Believe that dice there is showing how
many cards were played this turn. Track
for the Rams.
>> Floating Energy.
>> Floating Energy. I'm sorry.
>> Yeah.
>> Then we got a stack deck.
>> Seal
the seal in the window. The stack deck.
>> Sealed called shot are That's a tough
one. Uh, the seal is probably the taken.
I think it was called shots going to go
to the bottom here.
>> First seal is really important.
>> Yeah, it is.
>> Third card played.
>> All right. So, again, these Oh, okay.
So, done playing stuff for the moment.
And uh D going to come in get that first
point as now one.
>> This feels like he wants to develop onto
Obelisk.
>> Okay. Well,
>> I guess not.
>> Hopeful in the back row.
>> Yeah.
>> Again, kind of the start of the big
turn. Looks like a
>> Okay, so it Yeah, there's there's some
amount of wanting to be playing do
obelisk. Some amount of playing at home.
>> All right, that was a pretty good turn.
>> Ram ram. I mean, yeah, there's a 14
might.
>> Yeah, 13 to me. Nah,
>> 14 that Hey, that's a good mic total.
That's a good That's a good turn. Uh,
turn well turn two this time.
>> 13's unlucky.
>> Yeah, you wasn't unlucky last game. I
guess there were double 13s, but uh 14's
pretty nice. So, we see a hold on the
fan and the hunter on the uh Targon's
peak. Important to note also with the
peak as far as when you conquer it, are
you going to use the energy or not? And
then if you're holding it, you can't
conquer it. It's a little bit of
interesting play there.
>> Well, turn three mindsplitter is on the
docket here for Spicy Noodles. I
actually really like the concept to go
home, jam spplitter,
grab any card that says draw cards in
Galore's hand and try and deny him from
continuing to build up on this board.
>> And no more fireworks turns. That That
was a pretty good turn. Going to stop
the second round of a show.
And seven mightes a lot. Oh, nope. Going
to be a Draven. Okay,
>> Draven. I wonder what's going to go
alongside with this because if you're
not going to use these three runes, I
mean, it really should just be the
splitter, but I could understand not
wanting to dram. So, if there's, you
know, maybe like a hopeful or something
else to go alongside this, but but no,
>> this is tough, though. So, now we've
seen uh in the previous turn, there were
two unused runes. Obviously, two were
untapped Taragons, but now two unused
runes. Now, three runes here. Will they
get used? I mean, there isn't really a
lot that Noodles would want to do.
There's a ride the wind, but I feel like
that is a little suspect to kind of go
ride the wind and ship it here. And
>> uh potentially could have splittered
away this Ezreal if there's no other
card draw in hand and denied a
>> Ezreal scrap heap draw three. You know,
like this is the kind of thing you're
trying to avoid. You really want this.
You want to stop the bleeding before
this kind of keeps happening.
>> The firework uh box has been loaded back
up.
>> Going to follow up with a merchant to
see.
>> Oh, I love just going home here.
>> Come home. Yeah, that's great.
>> Current score two to two.
>> Again, definitely feels like a match
where, like you were saying, this is not
as much about the point tempo. It's kind
of just what get in, get big, win that
big combat,
come out with more mights
game. But going back,
>> yeah, I mean, for galore, you get to
just dare it.
>> You say, "Oh, would you like to enter
these battlefields?
>> Come on in."
>> Uh, I would love if you allowed me to
enter combat uh as the attacker. So
falling star takes out the merchant and
the right. So
>> I mean killing two things is nice but
those are not exactly the high impact
units on the board. Ezreal's good
obviously. So but
>> well here comes the splitter. Okay maybe
I mean I I'll say that every turn until
we play this realistically
there's a world where it's not because
if you do end up wanting to push to four
here you want to actually hold up
interaction. Like I can understand that
on this turn,
but do I want to push in here?
>> Is there enough interaction to really
overcome all the might on Korea's board?
>> So there's a switcheroo in hand, and
that's that's the big one that like
starts to lead towards like maybe we can
play for this because treasure hunter
switcheroo is very potent.
>> Uh you know, the full swing of might,
especially if say Draven pushes in, you
pump six, switcher is going to come out,
that's going to be a 10 might swing.
That's a big deal. Um, and so there's a
world that the hold can happen. It's
just how much further behind do you end
up going
if you don't spend these runes? And then
Collia says,
>> "Yeah, okay. Here's 18 more might or
what, you know, like are you really
winning in that case?" And and I'm not
I'm not convinced that that's
necessarily happening, right? The wind
going to be cast just treasure hunter
getting more gold and then the potential
to go home. I mean, I like the
conceptually I like ride the wind, go to
four, don't put any of my might at risk,
but if there is not a development to
follow this up,
>> then I don't like it anymore. You know,
that's not something I I I this board
needs to get bigger. It needs to be
>> bigger numbers. You know, we said it
best in the last game. So eloquently,
the right side's guys were bigger than
the left side's guys,
>> right?
>> And that's the story that we're having
once again,
>> right? Yeah. a one might unit, a two
might unit, then a four or six might
unit against
>> all that.
>> Does get in the treasure, which is kind
of cool. Uh but hopeful is good. Hopeful
is one of the best numbers cards uh in
the deck.
>> Oh, for targets.
>> Uh and just kind of passed it. Bunch of
>> three more.
>> So, this is eight runes that we've lit
on fire in this game,
>> right?
>> Yeah. Cuz you you're just not really
going to use these interactively when
you're not on a battlefield. Unless
you're just going to be fighter fighting
some random unit.
>> And I'm not going to count the peak
runes here, right? This is just three
that were wasted on five, right? Cuz
like the peak runes, I mean, that just
is what it is. You conquered Dark Peak
this turn. That's fine,
>> right?
>> No, as you said, there's what when are
we we're not using them here. Uh this
look has an Ezreal, so the the draws can
continue on,
>> but I think it was bottom. I didn't see
the other card that was grabbed, but
bargain hopeful. So, this is just going
to be, you know, as I was thinking for
Glor is like, we're just going to keep
putting light on this board.
>> Yep. uh you're already ahead of the
curve on it, so just keep just just
placing as much might as possible.
>> All right, there's the Ezreal.
>> Explains putting an Ezreal at the bottom
if you got another one in hand.
>> Y so only one seal this I'm sorry, the
second seal of the two, right? So two
seals, but still recycling happening
notably uh out of chaos runes. So
>> uh he drew an Ezra, so I must have uh
missed which one got to the bottom
because uh that would have been
>> third Ezra. So he must have grabbed one
off the cult, but that is what it is.
>> Fourals.
>> Yeah. Four. It must have been another uh
you know, full art epic card.
>> Yep.
>> All right. So we got another rim.
>> Yeah.
>> And just again, here's all my stuff.
Your turn.
>> This is what I fully expected from
Korea. It's like, as we the points don't
matter that much. It's entirely board
control. Now, I will say Spicy Noodles
getting to go to six is a boon because
that means you do just have to find one
slip up, one turn that you can kind of
push through and get that double conquer
in the game, right? So, it does open up
some opportunity and I think, you know,
splitter finally coming down is quite
nice. You've got these extra gold so
you're not going to dramp. You're going
to have a lot of runes for that final
push turn and this hand is a nightmare.
>> Double knock turn.
>> Ezreal gets to go away. You always you
always just you immediately you click
the one that says draw cards.
>> Yeah. And uh here is the uh the downside
of a noctturns. Uh the one place you
don't want to see them is in your hand,
which where they are and not even
playable. I mean, I guess next turn
would be playable, but with these all
these chaos runes. So, all right. Uh so,
we're going to see Hunter's coming in
once again. This this brave hunter, you
know, in the face of all these huge
armies just going in getting the gold,
scoring some points up to five. Now,
we'll see. Um I think if you're going to
five, you're going to six here, right?
>> Of course. So,
>> always. So fan comes in and now there's
uh a decent amount of might in noodles
back row.
Love to develop anything else here also
another hopeful or something like that
if possible but
and now galore. Galore is two things.
Galore is one kind of out of cards
realistically and two on the board with
all just numbers. You know these
battering rams noxious hopefuls. These
are just stats. They are nothing more
than that. So, just a bunch of numbers
in play and a bunch of uh dup not blanks
in hand. You can just cast Noctturn, of
course. Uh but not very exciting.
>> Yeah, I I I think that's a hidden
switcheroo. Try and get some value out
of the treasure hunter. I'm having to
lose the fan is a bit unfortunate cuz
that's going to be nice if you wanted to
go six conquer one side, try and play
for a hold to eight. The fan was
actually pretty high value. However,
when we look at the rest of the board, I
mean, I don't I don't think you're
throwing away a hopeful to keep a fan.
So, it's kind of makes sense is what you
have to go for in this spot for noodles.
And uh maybe at best you can deny one of
these uh bigger units from getting on to
the obelisk of power. I actually think
for it does make a lot of sense to
potentially just send Ezreal first into
the fan. Uh so that if they want to
push, they're pushing your lowest might
unit. And if they want to commit
something like a spinning axe on this
turn to kill an Ezreal, I think you
might kind of be okay with it. like it
ends up being like a a fine trade for
you to take. So, I'd like to see that
out of galore. I'm not confident that
that's 100% the line he'll take because
realistically he's going to want to look
for a bigger hole, but
>> I think that could happen. This is a
great way to attack into switch.
>> Okay. Yep. So, we have all three ramps
are coming in. Yeah, they're all fives.
>> So, we can see a switch.
>> And will we? Yes, we will.
>> So, you switch, but now treasure hunter
is still a five and then you're 155. So,
all it does is switcheroo gets to trade
for a treasure hunter. We'll see a
fighter flight as well.
>> So, this will hit one of the uh the
larger rams. I can only assume we now
have a five ram and a one ram against
the five pressure hunter.
>> Still looking pretty good.
>> What was the purpose of that fighter
flight?
>> I don't know.
>> Is that an acceptable answer here?
>> That's a fair answer. Yeah. I I also
don't um because it doesn't really
change the I mean it it keeps the one
unit off the battlefield for next turn
if N's looking to conquer I suppose.
It's just a chance to play fighter fight
and spend your energy.
>> Um
but does give a lot of information to
also
>> you know cuz now Kore knows okay well
that's not there other things might need
to be there.
>> No you are right you are you are right
there there actually there is a small
there is a small little uh amount of
merit making sure that these runes get
spent. Yeah, like that. Like just
ensuring like especially if the hand has
a lot more spells that are going to be
utilized on this next turn. Like
>> you just need a double break next turn.
This just means five might is guaranteed
to not be there. That I think that is
actually quite valid. And it is uh
honestly that's the only thing I can
also think of. So I think you're right.
I think that has to be the idea here.
And there just wasn't a better
opportunity. You in theory could wait uh
until Oblisk is pushed and then you can
still just cast it on whichever side
that you wanted to. Um, but I I still I
think that does make sense because this
uh would have absolutely blown out if he
held on to the fight or flight. Um, by
going for this piercing light, you
actually avoid the showdown uh and going
to be able to punch through and actually
get the Draven down.
>> Pretty brutal. So, two units down and
now uh Spice has got a whole lot of work
to do. I mean, has more energy to do it
now. There's a bunch of runes available.
There's a lot of cards in hand also, but
>> going to be a lot to overcome. Ezreal
moves in also. Ezreal and Noxious are at
the obelisk. You've got Fizz and the
Ram. Dravens are coming there, too. So,
looking up for looking for a stack up
here to defend with Spicy at six. Glor
to be extra sure that there's not some
sort of big and huge double conquer here
to kind of take a game where he's
definitely ahead.
>> So, this is the turn. Can Spicy use all
of these runes and these cards in hand
to break at least one of them?
>> Is that just two cards in hand? Is it
only two?
>> That looks like just two cards in hand.
>> That's not a lot of cards.
>> Yeah, that is not a large number of
cards.
>> Yep.
>> Well, there will be more.
>> All right. So, you get to trade a
fighter flight for a new card. So, the
ram's going to get eaten. That's going
to be a combat win. So, I mean, if
you're going to chain some draws
together, this is a good way to do it to
start.
>> There's fighter flight draw off Draven.
And now, what's the next step? Does
there need to be a number more steps?
There is a path here for Spicy.
It's a tough path, but there is a path.
>> 15 might on Oopsis. 11 might on board if
Ride the Wind is something that we look
at.
>> Mhm.
>> Axe doesn't get there. Two cards in
hand. So,
>> right.
>> Not a twocard combo that is allowing
your 11 to beat this uh this 15.
You can tie it with a rebuke or push.
>> Yeah. Is Darius axe enough? It's only
14. So
>> yeah, Darius Ax is 14 into that 15
still.
>> So a little bit short on that. Yeah.
>> So hold becomes the option. Yep.
>> You're at seven. Glor is not winning
immediately.
>> Yep.
>> Eight might at base. You can put 11 on
Taruns. You're going to untap. It would
be great if it was honestly something
like Mindsplitter,
>> right? You just you just push hopeful
into the Taruns. play minds spplitter
and then you you get two runes back from
the targets peak and then having some
kind of defensive measure there is kind
of perfect plus you get to deny clore
the best card from from the hand so
there's a hidden card is one of them
could just be a push once again could be
the uh edge of knight could be the
switcheroo switcheroo needs a smaller
unit to get out there
>> not so good there with the seven so and
then the knock has to go to the tarp
bronze right I mean on seven points. If
you're committing to just trying to hold
here, like is the one knock so in the
back row going to really matter if this
splitter gets broken?
>> So, the idea I suppose is maybe to just
push the mind spplitter home uh in
response to anything uh being cast from
>> uh with a hidden fighter flight.
>> Okay,
>> let's take a look. We're on way in the
driver's seat, but still definitely uh a
lot of possible pitfalls to fall into
here. So, I'm going to take a second and
go through. We are in game two and there
is uh a little over eight minutes left.
So, this has been a complicated game for
sure, but for noodles, if you go into a
game three, you know,
>> you know, it's kind of tough.
>> So, we got Fizz and the Ram coming into
the splitter 8 to seven. And we see
fight or flight
and
>> fight. That's fine.
>> Go to push back the ram, not the Fizz.
Yeah, I there was a part of me that just
felt like this was going to be wanting
to bring the Rebuke uh bring the bind
spplitter home, but I I see maybe hoping
that Glorious doesn't have a an answer.
Rebuke is going to be able to to pop
that back. Uh it feels like maybe the
the card is hard bargain with Repeater.
At least that's being bluffed right now.
Uh, however, Kalor can pay through that
easy enough
>> and
whatever it is. Looks like it's coming
in hard bargain.
>> So, this is just going to be exhaust
four runes.
>> Imagine this is a a thing you want to
choice and not not get countered. So,
>> bounces a splitter. Bargain is paid.
>> Good.
>> And Fizz is in. So, up to six now. It is
six to seven.
>> Draven draw. Still a lot of cards in
end.
Great spot for Galore. Looking to close
it out and go to six and one here in
round seven of the regional qualifier in
Las Vegas.
>> Yeah, Galore knows that the only card in
Spicy Noodles hand is Mindsplitter.
Heard him say Darius.
Darius plus Splitter is 12 runes. So, if
you do leave less than seven at the
obelisk, uh assuming spicy noodles is
going to 12 runes, I believe he is.
>> Uh then you could randomly lose to
Darius top deck. So, just making sure
you play around it, but then bringing
everything else home so you can
reconquer uh any attempt to hold makes
perfect sense.
>> All right, so looks all set up. Okay,
>> you could hold cast scrappy draw a card
and
>> recycle and play that third seal.
>> All right, so passing two ready two for
Targon. Now it is time for Spicy Noodles
to make something happen
with black deck.
>> Is that another bargain?
>> There's the Darius, but that can't be
cast in conjunction with the mind
spplitter.
>> Yep.
Hard to find a two-card combo here when
the one card in your hand to start the
turn is a seven drop.
>> Now, there was another stacked if we
want to keep fishing, but I'm trying to
find what card actually saves you here.
I mean, you know, Darius off the top
would have been a nice idea, uh, being
able to kind of push in and at least
have a little bit more might with the
hopeful, but at max, you're still
sitting on nine. Nine's not beating with
the basic lore.
>> And amusing, too, cuz if you do cast the
second stack deck, now you're off being
able to even play with Darius. This is
now Daryus going to be the third spells.
So no readying. So tough choices here.
Not looking too good for spicy. Try and
find out. Glor patiently waiting
and hopeful into Fizz. Got to start
somewhere. That's where it's going to
be. Pretty sure there's an axe in Kore's
hand.
>> In fact, there is.
>> We got a pass. It's time for the axe.
Going for a spin. And uh definitely a
bit of a sigh of resonation there for
Spicy. Tough spot.
Been a really tough match. You know,
again, we are only in game two. This has
been a grueling one. But
>> here's Darius.
>> Darius will enter ready at seven.
>> All right.
>> Coming in seven Darius onto six Fizz.
All right. So small victory.
>> You'll see
>> draw two. So, we'll see a draw off of
the the Draven Executioner Legend as
well as a draw for the the seventh
point.
>> Knocking up the axe is pretty cool, too.
So, a little extra value there. I mean,
>> ride the wind axe ties
>> in the bottom here. You know, that's
actually pretty heads up from Kora to
leave 10 value uh just in case of some
like really crazy outs that can come
through.
>> So, we're going to see a hopeful
reinforce and an aisa reinforce. All
right. that is able to actually beat
what has at home. I mean, that is no
slouch of a draw is getting two big
units. You know, Spicy Noodles should
have two runes ready for Tarun's Peak,
but we know the card in hand is mind
spplitter, so it does probably not
matter.
>> Yep. Yeah, that was that was honestly
drawing the maximum amount of might with
the energy available to use every single
piece. That's huge.
>> I don't hate it.
>> Yeah. And now Galora's got to break
this. Otherwise, we're gonna see
>> I think it's just Fizz rebuke.
>> Okay. Oh, sure. Okay.
>> Yeah, I think I think we're just gonna
see a good old Fizz rebuke.
>> All right. So, Fizz
>> going to go get piercing.
>> Oh, this one works even better. Yeah.
>> All right. And there it is. Galore takes
it down in the Draven pseudo mirror of
miracle versus mid-range. Spicy Doodles
>> at now five and two. Not necessarily out
of it. So, still going. And uh Galore,
great stuff. I guess so.
>> Yeah,
>> Draven Mirror is uh you know, you when
you see Draven them as the most played
deck, you might think to yourself like,
"Ah, Draven Mirror." But like that was
actually really awesome.
>> Yeah, that was sweet. And that number
that you were looking at, that was the
uh the number of might put on the board
by Corey.
>> So big. I can't count that high, so I
believe you.
>> Oh,
>> all right. So, really, really great
stuff. Uh again, really cool mirror
match. Really cool to see the different
versions of the deck. Of course, both
versions are quite popular and doing
quite well. kind of cool to see the
difference. It's kind of cool to see uh
a m a match too where the players aren't
just vying for points. You know, there
was so many times in that match where uh
a player had a shot at an open
battlefield and just said, you know
what, that's okay. The game is not about
this. Uh which is really cool to see
different games, different matches being
about different things. Cool stuff.
>> Yeah. I mean, when you're watching
Aurelia, it often is about uh can you
count to eight? And when you're watching
some of these Raven Mirrors, it is not
that at all. It is very much a board
state game where you are just entirely
trying to posture for positioning and
then you get to the point where we do
start counting might instead of points
and we have to figure out who's going to
have uh the bigger side. Good stuff. So,
let's hop down and hear from our winner.
>> Hey guys, I'm Ursy and I'm so excited to
be here with Kor who just won his match
live on stream with Miracle Draven.
Would you like to tell us about your
deck a little bit? Uh yeah, absolutely.
I come from Toronto, so I'm going to
give a shout out to Prismaticism. Uh
majority of the deck looks very similar
to what he uh built out at Bolognia uh
last weekend. So I just made a few card
tweaks for my preference. Uh he's from
Toronto as well. So yeah, a big fan of
his.
>> That is so cool. And I did see you
chatting with some of your friends right
after the game here. Did you come here
with people from your local or anything
like that? Yeah, there's uh so my two
friends offscreen are uh
been cheering me on all weekend. They're
awesome friends. Uh we're all from
Toronto and there's a massive Toronto
TCG scene in general. There's like
probably like 15 people I know at least
here from Toronto. Um and they're all
friendly. So, it's been awesome.
>> That is so cool. I love when the
community comes together to come to
events like this. How are you feeling
with your deck? I'm feeling really good
to be honest. Uh it's felt very strong
both Friday and today. Uh I definitely
had a little bit of stream nerves. Uh I
missed a trigger here and there. Uh but
like overall I think the core of the
deck is really strong. Uh I think the
the hardest part about playing the deck
is uh time. It's a lot of cards to draw.
So
>> yeah, I would say while everyone's
learning these miracle decks, a lot of
people are going to have that problem.
Uh, is there any matchup that you're
worried about today or tomorrow?
>> Uh, I've historically done pretty well
into Ireelia, but I think every single
time I play against Ireelia, it's like
seven points to eight points. It's the
scariest matchup ever. They have like
purple Draven charm. They have all these
like crazy tool boxes. They never give
me combat, so I don't get to draw with
Draven. So, uh, definitely one of the
scariest matchups is there. I really am.
>> Well, thank you so much. Is there
anybody you'd like to shout out before
we end here?
>> Uh, yeah. Uh, I'm going to shout out to
Ponzor. He's, uh, watching from home and
he's a really good homie. So, uh, wish
he was here.
>> Well, thank you so much.
>> Thank you.
>> I love seeing players come with all
their friends. They come with the team.
It's so cool to see the groups, you
know, occasionally they'll be all be
wearing the same shirt, same jersey or
whatever. Uh, but just just so cool to
see, you know, it's like, you know, oh,
it's the the Toronto crew and it's the
New York crew and like that's just such
cool stuff.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I mean it's it's it's
really sweet. I know there's a whole
Utah crew all in these jerseys that were
sponsored by all the different LGs's and
I think that's really sick that that was
there. We also had him shouting out
prismaticism and the miracle deck and I
was like, "Yeah, that does look
familiar." I think I've seen that one
somewhere and especially the the ratios,
he had some some cool tweaks in there,
but the noturn version definitely
showing up big for him. Even drawing a
couple Nocturns in the second time,
showing that they're still pretty good.
Uh you know, they they'll pay their
dividends. They'll arrive when you need
them.
>> Yeah, no problems at all. So, that's
going to do it for round number seven
here. Round number eight is coming up.
Our last round, perhaps our most
exciting round. Don't go nowhere.
Oh,
hallelujah. Oh,
that's scary. Heat.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
You want to get into the action. It all
starts at your local game store for
Nexus Knights where you can play in a
nice casual, relaxed environment. Super
fun. I love my local Nexus Knight. It's
great. Check it out. Uh locator.refound.
Earthbound.sgames.com/events
to find stores in your area that are
running next to nights.
All right, welcome back to the booth
here at the regional qualifier in Las
Vegas. I'm Jim Davis. That's Kasanova.
We got round eight for you, our final
round. We see what players are making
day two and possibly setting themselves
up for some really deep runs. Yeah, I
mean, this is the the the pedal to the
metal, right? A lot of win ins going to
be playing uh on this round. A lot of
players looking for that their hopes and
dreams to make that day two to keep
fighting for their best of to keep
fighting to make that top eight, try and
become a winner of a Riftbound regional
qualifier.
>> Yeah. And it's a battle of attrition,
you know, where it's a long day. These
players have played a lot of long
rounds, a lot of tough games. And uh you
get into that last round, there's an
element of you're not just fighting
against your opponent, you're fighting
against yourself. A little bit of
fatigue. cuz it's always nice to see uh
what players can kind of step up and do
uh and get it done. So, let's see our
standings and see what players we have
at undefeated.
And uh we got some uh some pretty
familiar names up here in the undefeated
list. To no one's surprise, the uh the
top eight players from Bolognia, the
three that are here, Prismaticism,
Allen's EQ, and Randy all still in that
70 bracket. We have Talion, who is a
teammate of Randy's as well. kind of
practiced a lot together, played in
China together at that 70, playing the
same list on top of that. Pretty insane
that these guys are all still just kind
of undefeated, not losing any matches.
>> Yep. Also got Awesome Ross in third
place. Awesome. Ross is a longtime Magic
Pro and cool to see. I think he had kind
of retired from card games for a bit.
Cool to see him back out uh in a new car
game, which is super cool to see. And we
also see that our undefeateds now only
go down to the top 13. So, uh, we could
have seven or six undefeated at the end
of this round, barring any weird draws.
Uh, and then we get to our draw bracket.
And of course, uh, you know, with these
Miracle Engines going really, really
deep. The games are hard. The games are
long. Draw bracket is pretty deep. Uh,
going down to 18th place. These players
are air quotes undefeated. Uh,
>> you know, and and at 16 there was Funk
Monks. He's actually part of that same
team and he's playing Teemo uh, in this
event. He's still undefeated, you know,
with that that one draw, but 601. Still
big shout out to Funks for kind of
making it that far with that Teemo. I
know also LS is on Teemo at 6 and1 in
this event. Uh really really well done.
He is now part of Fly Quest TCG. I saw a
tweet that go out uh today. They now
have an official TCG roster and LS is
one of the first players on that roster.
So very cool to see him come from League
of Legends and even before that a Magic
the Gathering Starcraft background and
coming all the way here now uh to doing
Riftbound and at 6 and one on Teemo.
Yeah, two Teemo players absolutely
crushing. Really really great to see and
uh these X1 players you know have a
little more work to do as far as really
want to get a win this round. Really
want to go into day two at X and one uh
and just you know get themselves set up
for a good run tomorrow. You know the
these XO players X1 players are are are
locked up already.
>> Yeah, they're locked up for day two.
That's cool. But you can't just like
check that box off and be like, "Okay, I
made day two. I did it." Uh, still
another really important round to go and
going to be one of the most difficult
rounds you can play because you're
playing against all the other players
who are undefeated or X and one too. So,
got to be a great round to watch. So,
I'm looking forward to get down to that
right now and see what our players are
up to and as they sat on and I think
you'd see the fatigue a little bit, you
know,
>> slowly meandering towards the feature
stage.
>> Yeah.
>> And uh, you know, and that's a big part
of it. tournaments. I I love that aspect
of tournaments where it is a bit of an
endurance test also. So, we're going to
see Broken Honor here. Little uh Lucian
the purifier. Yeah, bring some Lucian
back. A few interesting oneoff choices
that we did not see from Mos earlier. Uh
going to be the Rengar. This allows you
to be play him at reaction speed from
your hand when you are attacking to
where you are attacking. And he has
assault too. So this is three for kind
of plus five into a battlefield with a
unit body to go for it. Very very cool
card. And then the vein that you can
continue to recur. She comes in ready
when your opponent owns a battlefield.
She has assault three. So that little
measly two turns out to be a five when
you're attacking in and when you conquer
with her, you can pay one energy to
bounce her back. So you can kind of
recur this value and get her off of the
battlefield. Kind of nice against Draven
if you can conquer with it to not give
those combats back. So, kind of some
cheeky one-offs here that are pretty
nice for this uh Lucian deck for Broken
Honor. And we'll see if they're able to
kind of come into play during these uh
first few games that we're seeing.
>> Yeah, both cards good against purple
decks. Rengar especially good against
fighter flight and rebuke. So, you kind
of like refight into that battlefield.
We also see Hexte Ray here joining
Falling Star as a rule spell not usually
seen outside of Kai'Sa.
>> Yeah, kind of nice to deal with uh
things like Overzilla's fan if we end up
in a Draven matchup. Uh it hits things
like Ezreal, it hits Fizz. There's a
there's a decent amount of stuff at
three. I think four has been really the
magic number of Spirit Forge, though.
So, Ray has kind of fallen a little to
the wayside. Of course, Kai'Sa still
plays it because it's just very good
value in that Kai'Sa deck and you still
have Stupify to kind of combo with it
and, you know, still beat those fours.
Uh, but we'll see if this Ray ends up
being really strong. I think the biggest
thing uh if it ends up being, you know,
like a Draven match up or something like
that is you're going to get to deal with
the fans, but going up against Victor,
uh not as many targets that you're going
to be really excited about.
>> Yeah. So, Danx playing Victor. We've
seen Victor on camera a few times today
and definitely a different list. We list
We saw earlier. We see two copies of
Singularity and uh two sharks as well,
the Riptide Rex. And uh but again, kind
of a a a list focused on units that
actually get into combat. We see the
Honest Brokers. Uh we see the
pickpockets as well. Uh so what's going
on? We see consult pass too. A little
bit of a little bit of a hidden action
uh package too.
>> A bit closer to what we saw out of
Ghostaster Driver in Bolognia. Uh having
the full suite of Sanjao uh the full
pickpockets uh as well having those in
the main board dealing with the Ezreal,
the miracle Dravens, killing all those
seals, the pesky seals running around.
Uh the pickpocket is going to go
clubbing them. So they're going to be
just fine with that.
>> Sounds great. So, we got Victor versus
Lucian coming in in round number eight.
Danax, our Victor player. Get our
players all set, all ready to go. We got
Danax on the right, Victor, herald
dealer, Arcane looking at treasure horde
as the battlefield, and Broken Honor,
Lucian Purifier, Forge of the Fluffed as
the battlefield. Yeah, I mean, Lucian
does not have an exhaust ability. So,
Forge of the Fluff is going to be able
to get some really good value. You can
tap Lucian to equip one of those weapons
and not D- ramp yourself. Very very nice
uh battlefield for Lucian.
>> Good stuff. Let's pop down. Round number
eight. Let's go. These players are both
51 and one. So this is a effectively a
knockout match for top eight. I do not
believe 52 and one be good enough for
top eight.
>> Not even good enough for day two. So
right. So this is, you know,
>> so that is true.
>> This is a true win in. But also the win
here, this can be the start of a
submarine miracle run, right? you win
out from here and you're essentially
guaranteed top eight at X1 and one. Uh
but you know, uh a loss here, you don't
even make day two, right? So, this is
the big, you know, this is the big pedal
to the metal. X1 and one being the maybe
scariest but also very exciting uh
record to be at here, right? You can't
lose anymore, but if you keep winning,
top eight is well within your reach.
>> You don't want to lose anyway.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Who wants to lose?
>> Just don't lose.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. Doran's blade comes in.
Broken heart broken honor here on the
play. Danx, our Victor player is going
to be going second. And we're going to
see one little recruit token. And is
there a second play to go along with it?
There is not. So just a recruit passing
back broken honor's way. Couple more
runes and I think one too many. That's
okay. A little whoopsie there. And then
uh
little shuffle fix maybe. Maybe not.
That's cool.
>> All right. So
next step here is going to be fire the
Lucian weapon master for the blade. Kind
of another scripted chosen champion
where you're playing Lucian on turn two
a lot of the time.
>> Yeah, this is exactly what you want to
do in Lucian. You want Dorne's blade
turn one, Lucian turn two, start playing
the game, right? It's a It's a little
bit annoying that you kind of have to
waste a rune with this curve, but it it
just is what it is. And it's still a
very powerful kind of one-two punch that
you get to play with this deck.
>> Now, the Victor deck has a lot of
removal spells. So, it's kind of able to
even though Lucian can kind of get in a
hit and run, the Victor deck will be
able to use hidden blade, cold week,
find other ways to kind of deal with
Lucian outside of combat. Like, you
might just see a hidden might just see a
cold week right now, right? I
>> I think we will. Right. Uh, you've
already been able to use this recruit,
get the conquer, get the gold. You just
rip this call the week. Don't even
bother letting this Lucian get a lot of
value. And there's not really any other
plays in the hand that I I'm very
excited about. So, let's just kill the
Lucian. Let's just go ahead and make
another recruit most likely and just
kind of keep on keeping on with what
Victor loves to do. Keep the board
clear, build your base of recruits, and
just keep conquering with these recruits
over and over again to build a large
point lead. So back broken honor's way.
Need to rebuild. As we were saying
earlier, not a lot of accelerate in this
deck. So kind of got to get back on the
board.
>> Sure.
>> Never mind. Just kidding. We got
confront.
>> Well, there's not a lot. You are right.
>> And it's not not technically accelerate.
It is enters ready. So that was right.
Technically right is the best kind,
right?
>> Yeah. But confront is still, you know,
the great way that you do get to have
units enter ready even though not a lot
of the deck does. is and we are going to
see just a pouty porro go in conquer
forge of the fluffed and that will allow
this porro to then have a Dorne's blade
as a little treat for that conquer of
the forge of the fluff. You know it's
really thematic. The porro is getting in
there. It's getting all kitted up and
now it's forging a Dorne's blade for
itself.
>> Probably porro loves a little treat and
porro should be very good in this match
up right. So of course Victor quite
spellbased lot of removal spells and
that deflect can certainly start to add
up. So Porro's in and now at form might
going back Danax's way
and Victor uh a deck with a lot of big
powerful plays. So these higher room
counts start to get pretty scary. Yeah,
this is where Sinja can actually make a
lot of value. So a single more recruit
being added to the backline here is
going to allow Syninja to enter ready.
Um because you just need to have two or
more other units in your base when you
play him. Then he'll come in ready. And
there's a stupify to add to it. And yes,
you will have to pay the deflect cost.
And as you're saying, Pouty Pora is
still going to be able to gain a little
equity that way. But then Syno can
potentially just get a free trade. And
you still maybe have to play around
things like punch first. That's
something you maybe want to consider in
a spot like this. But if you force your
opponent into a punch first, you're
still kind of creating a better board
state for yourself where they've dramped
so many extra runes that it can start to
be okay. It's your runes is definitely a
lot. So Danx makes that recruit
and I mean feel like making the recruit
is committing to this line first. So but
no going to go uh pop the other recruit
in. Check out the treasure horde again.
We're going to see a hex deck ray.
>> Okay,
>> so there you go. The ray takes down the
recruit. Uh a tough exchange, you know,
being uh down a rune and then using a
card on only a recruit. So maybe not
ideal.
It does however put Danax down to only
one unit. Okay, so instead Danx instead
of going for the Sinja approach is just
going to go for wages plus a stupify
afterwards. Use the initial gold uh to
pay the first deflect cost. Now you're
going to have to pay one for real. Uh
however, still going to be able to
remove the unit and get a new
replacement gold coming through. Not
going to get a score on this turn, but
overall just keeping the board clear,
getting an additional gold. still having
a recruit on the board and uh similar
rune totals, but the hand is uh three of
a kind for Syno and not really a card
that wants to be played next to each
other. It wants to be played in tandem
with a myriad of other units that have
been played to the board.
>> Yeah, and that was painful. Pipor really
uh kind of chomping away at uh at the
runes and the gold there. But we're
going to see uh we we see the combo.
>> The combo is getting assembled.
>> The combo is here. So, game over broken
on it, right? I mean,
>> maybe one way or another,
>> maybe. Yeah.
>> So, all those powerful equipment are in
play, but of course, they are very
lonely. They have no unit to hang out
with.
>> Going back to Danx's way, we're going to
see another recruition.
>> And then popping right in play. Ready?
>> And we have a ready unit ready to go.
Sing gets to come down ready. You get to
go for the double conquer. I mean, it
just goes up to three, but I think
that's still fine. you just start
scoring cuz Victor is a deck that can
still potentially look for an endgame
hold. So you don't have to just play
point tempo with Victor. It's not like
you know Aurelia perma double conqueror
that you're looking for. Even Lucian
really wants to play that point tempo as
best as possible. So you're going to
just see go into three here and no big
reason not to. And the question is is
does Broken Honor have a unit in the
hand? I mean I I think developing the
combo is fine even if there are units in
the hand. You don't necessarily need to
develop one cuz you might just be
putting it in danger of dying to some
back row access. But does he have one?
That's what we all want to know.
>> I want to see confront runner.
>> Yeah. I mean, I'd go crazy.
>> That's what I want to see.
>> I mean, I'd go real crazy.
>> Okay. First mate first feels like that's
the only unit in hand.
>> It says first right on the card.
>> Yeah.
>> First mate comes in first.
>> So now the second mate needs to get
played.
>> Yep.
>> All right. So first mate will pick up
the Trinity Force.
of course get a hold to get the full
value of that one. So just two might at
present.
>> Yeah, we'll see what he can actually get
done. I like you can still equip the
spear, but if there's if it's not going
in, I don't know if I want to equip the
spear yet. I in fact I I don't like uh
jamming all the equipment onto the first
mate if there's not a way to actually
ready it on this turn. You do still need
to play around the the backline removal.
So going up to seven might is a
reasonable idea, but not equipping Oh,
yeah. Yeah, of course. cuz you're going
to equip it via the Relentless Pursuit.
So, going to Relentless Pursuit to pick
up the spear and now start going for
some conquers.
>> All right, it's game time.
>> Here we go.
>> So, the full equipment stack is on the
first mate. Pursuit puts it in. And now
we get to see
>> a hidden blade.
>> Well, that was shortlived.
>> All for not. Uh, so all the equipment
falls helplessly back to the
battlefield. Uh, and uh maybe next turn.
And now we get to ask the age-old
question. Does Broken Honor have a unit?
There is there is the big one that we
have to find. And you know, two more
cards added to the hand from that hidden
blade.
>> Confront.
>> Okay,
>> we get to We go again.
>> Okay.
>> Is it our favorite Porro? It is.
>> Wow.
>> All right.
>> Look at that face.
>> Howdy. Porro is back. And this time he's
got some friends. Uh quite the armory
for this porro.
>> Entering ready, of course. And now we
can see combo again. So, unfortunately,
we can't because it costs one energy and
one power to equip the spear.
>> Ah, yes. One of the few equipments that
has the the energy cost as well.
>> So, instead, you know, you can go to the
forge of the fluff. And once again, the
porro can have a Doran's blade as a
little treat or a spear. Uh, I think the
spear is actually really nice cuz you
get to dodge the energy cost with the
the forge. So, I think that's the most
efficient way to do it.
>> So, now total might in the porro is six.
Is that correct?
>> Uh, yes. two, four, and that is six.
>> Okay,
>> so we got a whole point putting Danx up
to four, broken honor at two. And again,
we're getting to that really high rune
range uh for Victor where a lot of these
really huge spells can come online. Six
isn't that a tough number uh for both
Singularity and Riptide Rex, which both
do exactly six. So, and then it's at the
point now where I think you're almost
happy just firing up Singularity to kill
the one unit, right?
>> Yeah, you would you would do anything
really. It would be fine. Uh, but this
is a very efficient clear to just go for
the watcher. You don't even have to pay
a deflect cost for this. So, you just go
ahead and send this in. Just
>> good oldfashioned combat. So, watcher
comes in and once again, the equipment
falls to the ground. That's point number
five for Natex
and a retreat and a pass.
>> So, I have to ask you an age-old
question.
>> Does broken honor have a unit?
>> We're going to find out. I mean, and
maybe uh the third confront.
>> Yeah, the third confront as well.
>> Yeah,
>> really get things rolling. Maybe the the
the second and third mate can show up
this time.
>> Oh, okay.
>> It's a party. You got to run a ship. You
know, first, second, and third mate.
>> Okay. Okay, that works.
>> Hey.
>> All right, so Kai'Sa look, I could only
assume accelerated. This is going to be
a costly rune turn, though.
>> It sure is.
>> So, we got one rune going down for the
Kai'Sa accelerate. Then of course for
each of the equipss is as needed.
Thousand del's on seven Kaiser starts at
four.
>> You got all the equipments are currently
plus two. So it's two each.
>> Yeah. But an additional one from the
purifier at least offensively. So
>> correct the assault.
>> It's you are far and above any might
that you need to reach for the conquer
on this turn. Mhm. And I really like the
idea of equipping the spear and the
trinity to score to four and then using
the forge to equip the uh the Dorne's
blade uh after the fact in order to just
beef up the might total uh so that
potentially you can hold into any unit
combat. Um we know Danax is drawn into a
drag under so no matter what this is
going to end up getting kind of like
punished on the following turn. Uh, but
I do think Broken Honor is doing kind of
what he can with this deck. This is
really solid. You get to score two
points up to four. You draw a card. You
equip the Doran's Blade for free because
of the the forge of the fluff. I mean,
it's everything you want to be doing
with the deck. Unfortunately, Victor
just has a lot of removal and is being
able to deal with each of these
individual units.
>> Yeah. So far, Broken Honor has asked a
question every turn, and I would say a
pretty big question, too. You know, it's
been a very threatening question, but
Danx has the answer on every street.
starting with that first call of the
week uh which was really a great place
to start. So Kaiser here like you said
we'll draw a card. Okay,
>> Sabo's very I mean that is is really
effective in this spot. Uh you get to
take the drag under. Uh it is your only
option. You get to see that this is
going to be Riptide Rex which means
unfortunately for you there's no way
you're actually holding cuz that damage
will be enough to at least clear away
the Kai'Sa. you know, hey, if I equip
this uh this additional Doran's blade,
that might help me get a better trade.
>> So, blades a free equip. Might as well
fire it on there.
>> Yeah, no reason not to.
>> Yep. So,
still a tough spot. The problem here is
that uh Broken Honor lost a lot of runes
this turn, you know, so that rebuild
phase, you know, able to ask a good
question every turn, but
>> I I I think he must have forgotten about
the forge here because, you know, Lucian
is still untapped. He he's gotten it
every single other turn, right? He's
just absolutely
>> Yeah. Uh
could be a bit of resation kind of
seeing the hand and being like, "Ooh,
okay. This is not going to go well." So
now even further down on runes and
again, you know, like I said in the uh
intro to the match, fatigue is
definitely a factor at this stage in the
tournament,
>> almost test of wills, if you will.
>> So doubling up on the creatures. One is
nice, two is nicer.
>> How about three?
>> Yeah. I mean, it's it's Sin City and
we've got three Syninja on the board
right now. So, I think, you know, it's
it's very fitting for the Las Vegas
tournament that Syninja will make this
appearance and he is going to just send
all three of them in, trade two of them
away to clear away the Kai'Sa.
>> So, do you prefer that to using the
Riptide Rex to deal six and then coming
out with one of them?
>> Uh, no.
>> No, I actually I I do actually kind of
prefer the Riptide Rex play. I think
playing one jouo, play the riptide rex,
trade ones in and uh and then you know
just conquer from there. Uh go to six
and then play for double conquer on the
next turn is my preference in that spot.
Uh but this is going to set up for a
double hold and you're probably just
always winning with the double hold
here. I think it's kind of like uh you
know six of one half dozen of the other
at this point because of this lead
because broken honor is only on four
runes. Uh yeah, I just kind of feel that
uh Danx really cannot lose in that spot.
It's it's both are very strong plays.
both are setting you up for success
afterwards.
>> So really clean game from Danx.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> I'll have the answers on all the right
streets. And honestly, Broken Hunter,
every turn we felt like, oo, are we
falling apart? No. Uh, a big thing comes
in, but Danx has the answer. And, uh,
that's some pretty impressive stuff. So,
Danx up a game here in this final match
here in the last round of regional
qualifier Las Vegas. We got Jim and Cass
in the booth for you. We got Voidgate as
Danx's second battlefield and Obelisk of
Power for Broken Honor. Yeah, I think
Brooke and Honor in in that game as
well. I I'm not really seeing any
problems coming from the gameplay. I
think he's is actually making a lot of
really correct decisions. It's just
coming down to the structure of Lucian
versus Victor. Uh you don't have counter
spells, right? You are you are beholden
to my opponent has a card that says my
unit dies and when they cast it, I say,
"Oh, okay." Like there's nothing I can
do about it, right? So, I think for
Broken Honor, uh, if there's any
sideboard tech, something like
Unyielding, it can help it against some
of these spells, but Victor being in
yellow has a lot of spells that actually
just say, "Okay, your unit dies." And
there's not really counterplay in these
colors to that specific line of attacks.
>> Yeah. And a lot of pressure on sabotage.
There are only three com. And that
really is one of the few ways to you
could say pick apart, but there's just
so many great removal spells. very often
are going to cast it and just see two
rule spells in hand for Danax and get to
go. So pressureures on for Broken Honor.
Great start for Danax. You've got a
recruit and a uh what we got there? Is
that an honest broker? Yeah, honest
broker recruit as the followup to turn
one uh with the starting with obelisk
for the Lucian just having the immediate
Lucian merciless going to go into
obelisk just start trying to score
points and we'll see what the
development in the back is following
this cuz last turn or last game started
in a decent spot for broken honor combo
found pretty much right away relentless
pursuit was there as well right kind of
like everything you would want however
not able to keep a unit around to
actually utilize it
>> so trreny forces the
uh declines to go for the hold. Just
going to back the Lucian out with the
old hit and run going back's way. Six
runes already. The Obelisk of power
games are crazy.
Two units available and open path to
both battlefields. Rober's going to come
in, take that first point on Obelisk of
Power. Recruit comes into void gate,
takes in point number two. So, a two to1
lead for Tanics
and then some big heavy hitters in hand.
Imperial Decree, Singularity.
Singularity kind of be backbreaking
match up.
>> Yeah, it's this weird thing where it's
like you almost want to snap off
singularity and just be like, "Okay, you
can't have your Lucian." Uh, however,
one rune up means unyielding is probably
something you should respect. And also,
there's a good chance it gets better and
you could just develop back row,
especially because I actually feel
pretty decent about developing the
Victor leader here. uh because honest
broker is sitting at obiska power and is
very likely to be something that gets
taken down and you get to get that kind
of free recruit. So instead holding open
a bunch of energy. The only action speed
spell I remember seeing at five energy
was going to be that Imperial decree but
there's a lot more smaller action that
could happen with the wages, the hidden
blade, the face breaker.
>> Yeah, Facebreaker, hidden blade in hand,
wages of pain. So a lot of options.
Definitely a pretty telling turn where
broken honor is going to be like whoa.
Uh, five runes up, huh? Yeah. Well, I
guess I just don't have anything, you
know. Sorry. So, got to go broken honors
way. Broken honors. Have to think about
>> how he wants to navigate through all of
these open runes and these potential
pitfalls of these variety of removal
spells.
>> Interesting idea of maybe trying to
force Broken Honor to just develop
backline because you're holding on to
singularity. Saying like, you don't want
to run into all of these, so you should
play another unit. Like, you you should
play another unit here. Like, another
unit's really good here. Y
>> and then you can set up the singularity.
Now, unfortunately, Runeer cannot be
selected by Singularity. So, that does
not fully work for Danax as Broken Ar
does take the bait and plays another
unit. Uh, it's just not the one that
Danax is hoping to see.
>> Yeah. So, Runner seems great against
most of Danax's deck, but Imperial
Decree in hand is a pretty good answer.
Things lining up well here. This does
seem like a pretty good match up for
Victor going back's way. A double hold
up to four. Four to one in Danax's favor
again. And this is a win and in match
for day two. The player who loses his
match will um be find some fun side
events to play tomorrow. So want to keep
on playing.
>> They qualify for the side events.
>> Yep.
>> So we're going to see immediate Victor
token in the back row.
>> What is the next step here starting
there?
Yeah, I mean you can kind of keep
playing around these spells that you've
got in hand. Uh the Imperial the Curry
is a lot of value. There is even a world
where you let Broken Honor kind of walk
in and you just cast Imperial the Cree
at action speed to try and deal with the
Ruin Runner. I mean there there is a
completely valid play that Danax can
look for. I with the point lead though I
kind of like you know slowing it down
just develop and then just use decree to
win the game at six. Um often you know
people are afraid of casting it too soon
uh because it's not like a win the game
uh button but it feels like a win the
game card, right? Uh this is one of
those games where I actually feel like
being patient with it and using it as a
win the game card is is quite
reasonable. Um and we are going to
instead see you know a hidden I assume
hidden blade cuz hiding face breaker
seems really suspicious into ruin runner
and this is just going to be used to
draw additional cards and have more
options going forward.
>> Yep. So we see the root retreat I assume
is hidden. It's honest broker is like
wait what did you hide here?
>> Yeah excuse me.
>> What what what's the plan? Is it someone
going to tell me about this or uh so
passing back broken honors away and now
a lot of runes you know definitely
getting more set up this game you has
more than one unit in play for the first
time uh in the rune runner and rune
runner is a really good unit to have uh
and then Lucian as well Trinity Force
and then what is uh the next step going
to be
>> well let's see a sabotage that would be
uh
>> great place
>> a really good start
really
>> know what you're walking into
>> yeah really illuminate what's going on
here and uh you
In some cases, you can't play around
stuff, but at least take the best card,
get some information, and figure out
what the best path to proceed here in
this pretty tough matchup.
>> Yeah, I do feel like if you can take
this decree, the game becomes a lot more
winnable.
>> Absolutely. Yeah, the rune runner decree
is the the current ace in the hole
against the rune runner. Otherwise,
without the decree, these targeted
spells can't stop it. And if it can get
big enough, they could just be a house.
>> Cuz right now, the unit combat's still
pretty scary. like admittedly um there
there's still a lot of might that's
going to be available for Danx and you
know we we saw the watcher in the
previous game so that's something you
have to be concerned about always
>> but I do think like with the decree
there it feels like there's almost no
out like there's no win available that
I'm seeing for broken honor and so if a
Sabo is found at least this gives you an
opportunity where hey maybe there is
like a light at the end of the tunnel
and there's a there's a way to actually
navigate this match up actually feels
quite hard for Lucian because of the
fact that there's just not a lot of
great answers to all the different
spells and removal that Annex has. And I
think it often needs to start with a
good sabotage.
>> Yeah. And the variety, too.
>> Correct.
>> So, yeah. But I think here, um, if you
are Broken Honor and you have the read
that was a hidden blade, time to cast
sabotage is now. It's not the start of
the turn. Let the hidden blade go off.
Draw some more cards. Now, I get to look
at the full amount, but we'll see what
Broken Honor has in store for us. It's
going to be a Yona.
>> Yeah, Yona getting set up. Great way to
deal with Victor Leader. uh if you can
end up having any uh unoccupied
battlefields. But what I will say is
siding in Yona against Victor is a
little surprising to me as a whole
because you're not conquering open
battlefields very frequently. Um often
there's a recruit there that you're
killing when you go conquer. So ouch.
Solution goes in, tries to go for hit
and run on void gate and wages of pain.
Pain indeed. Solution is down. The
treasure is in and this poor is looking
mighty nice for Danax to the point where
the decree is almost not necessary.
There's enough stuff in play to kind of
just go activist rune runner but we're
going to see an equip and uh unfortunate
for broken honor here as Imperial decree
is probably going to cause some trouble
this turn I would think.
>> Yeah, I was I was mentioning waiting
until it wins the game. I I do think
that there's a very very good argument
for just killing the rune runner while
it is sitting on this point right now
and
>> right with with Trinity Force on it
also.
>> Yeah. Yeah. and not waiting until the
final turn because what you can do
instead is use that to clear the rune
runner now and then you use the hidden
face breaker to try and look to even
hold on this next turn.
>> Yep. So, here comes a void gate. That's
point number five. Getting point number
six here. Also a uh
>> thing you want to do and there is the
decree. So now whenever a unit deals
damage it will kill whatever it deals
damage to I guess. Sorry the other way.
Whenever a unit takes damage kill it.
Same thing. So recruit comes in and says
hi roomunner. How big are you? Don't
care.
And
>> now this is tough. Either there is, you
know, a hex tech ray or something like
that here. There's a few more recruits
just uh next in line.
>> Oh,
>> so we're going to see. I think this can
go base.
>> See a pursuit. And uh All right, just
back it up.
>> Yeah,
>> I was like I'm pretty sure it says
location, not battlefield. So yeah,
going to go ahead to base.
>> That's pretty good, right? So Nava
decree is gone.
>> Yeah. So now this room runner has a
chance to kind of run away with things.
Uh if we can get it a little bit bigger.
So pursuit
fight orflight impression.
Another recruit for Danex.
And uh still developing pretty good
board here. It's probably a little less
impressive than it looks. They are just
one might recruits, but still plenty of
good spells in hand, but again those
spells might not be able to touch the
root runner. We're going to see a hidden
card at the void gate which is we saw
the face breaker in hand.
>> Yeah, it should still be there with the
ruin at home. I don't think Danx is
going to ever hide this face breaker. Uh
I I believe there was a consult that
passed in hand or it was a hidden blade.
One of the two.
>> Yep. We got another hidden guard too. So
time to play the shell game. Going back
broken honor's way. All right. So I mean
runer hey you know survive a turn kind
of dodge that Imperial decree bullet.
Now we see Singularity in hand. Got
hopes looking on. Hidden blade. Same
thing. But can Ruin Runner make some
noise is the question.
We're in here.
>> All right. Sing me a song.
>> Draw two.
>> So we're going to see a consult in
response to draw two cards
>> and then draw two.
>> I believe other hidden card is another
hidden blade. So recruit is going to
bite it and take two more cards. So
going to concede a point this turn. Uh
that does open up a battlefield for the
so maybe things turn around here a
little bit. And you know I think that if
for broken honor if the majority of
Danax's cards are in hand that's not a
bad place to be. They are often very
expensive. They are very impactful cards
like Singularity, Riptide Rex. But you
can only do one a turn and Broken Honor
is able to kind of get in here and start
making some moves.
>> That's not too shabby. Yeah,
>> we could see a path here. Um,
>> yeah, I was trying to think if there's a
world where actually playing the hidden
blade there and losing your victor is
not the correct line, but also just
drawing a million cards and being ready
to play like another decree on the next
turn feels pretty good. So,
>> sure, finding decree is huge, but I mean
there that's a big question is what's
more important, two cards in hand or
Victor on the back row?
>> Yeah, you know, tough thing to answer.
Danic says I want the cards. So, more
runes coming in now. Broken honor on
these battlefields and on them strongly.
Uh that rune runner is huge
and we see so many cards in hand and
this is a spot where if you're broken on
or you're just like in the mental the
mental uh discussion is no decree. No
decree. No decree. No decree.
>> The singularity got a lot better and I
actually think there's exactly enough
room for singularity call the week and I
think both of those are in hand which
completely wipes the board. I think that
is very likely the line we're going to
end up with with Danax. You know, when
you get to draw your whole deck, uh I
think you often are able to find some of
these really strong spell combinations.
We saw that singularity all game. I'm
pretty sure I saw a call drawn. So,
singularity going to deal six to two
units. Going to kill the Brin here.
Going to kill the Yona. Uh going to
leave you still with three recruits back
where you get to slam the call the week,
get rid of one of your recruits, get rid
of that ruin runner, and then conquer
both sides for the win. The only hope
would have been that with that one rune
there was an unyielding spirit and as
we're seeing him pack up those cards
there is not.
>> Yeah. Runner again against half the
cards in Danny's maybe more more than
half but Call of the week also is a is a
big big one. And there it is. Yep. All
right. So here's Call of the Week Rune
Runner going down. Uh and that is tough.
Broken Honor really had a nice setup
there over the last few turns. Really?
And that's going to do it. So that's the
game. Danx takes it down. Danx 61 and
one on to day two. Our Victor player
going to be playing for possibly a
besta, possibly top eight, possibly a
championship.
>> Yeah, still alive. This could be the
very start of the miracle run for Danx
going into that day two. Has the
potential for top eight. Uh and
unfortunately for Broken Honor, that is
going to be the end of the road for this
tournament. not going to be able to
sneak into that day two, but still a
great run overall. I think going X2 and
one on day one still great feat. 52 in
one is a good record.
>> Yeah, that's not quite good enough to
make day two.
>> Not bad at all. Tough match up there. I
like actually I'm on day two. It's
awesome. Really, really, really good
stuff. So, great to see. And Victor
looked great there, you know.
>> Yeah.
>> So, uh really, really cool stuff. Again,
I think a tough match up for Lucian. You
know, Victor definitely has some
polarizing matchups, right?
>> Yeah. It it feels very difficult. It's
like any deck that just cannot deal with
the the spells is going to have some
trouble. And the only tool that I'm
really looking at in that Lucian deck
would be something like an unyielding
spirit uh in the side or the Ruin Runner
to try and answer it. But, you know,
there's still answers. Decree and call,
as we saw, are both ways that that Ruin
Runner can be stopped by the Victor. And
so all those different tools, all that
extra removal and Victor tends to draw
more cards than Lucian, it just kind of
leads to this recipe where the two decks
don't line up super well for Lucian's
favor. It lines up great for Victor.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's really tough when you
have these interactive elements to kind
of fight back, but you really need to
draw the right half at the right time.
And that adds a adds a whole another
element to, well, I need my deck to
work. I need equipment, I need units,
and I need to have the right interaction
at the right times. And if I'm able to
do it, I mean, valiant fight there in
game two. Really, I thought that um that
Room Runner was going to be able to kind
of take through it, but enough cards
drawn and our V Victor player takes it
down. And let's hear from our newly
minted uh day two player.
>> I'm here with Danx taking the victory on
Victor. You've officially now made day
two. How does it feel?
>> It feels great. Yeah, I was I was a
little worried going in, but you know,
made it through.
>> So, Victor, pretty popular choice
actually for the weekend. How did you
land on this deck?
>> Yeah, uh I've been playing Victor since
set one. Uh, I just really like his play
style and I feel like set two there's
just kind of a lot more um flexibility
in what you can do. It's a tricky deck
to build though because there's like so
many options that seem good. So yeah.
What have your matchups been like? Is it
kind of what you expected metag game
wise or have you hit kind of a lot of
different things on day one?
>> Um I pretty much hit most of the the top
meta I would say. Yeah. Um so nothing
surprising.
>> Of course now you've made day two. You
can continue making that run. do have to
you have to win out quite a lot to kind
of make it far. But how you feel you're
going to do now that you officially made
it to tomorrow?
>> Uh yeah, I think there's definitely some
opportunity. Um I just got to play play
well and you know luck of the draw.
>> It's just that easy. Good luck tomorrow.
>> Yeah, thanks.
>> Love it attitude, you know, just I'm
going to play. I'm going to play
tomorrow and we're going to see what
happens. And uh that's the sort of like
zenness I think you need to go deep in a
tournament. You know, you can't be
living and dying at every match. You
know, oh, I got to win two more. I got
to one more. Uh, you know, so love to
see that.
>> Yeah. I mean, it's it's a classic for
any long Swiss tournament. The mindset
that I've always had, right? 13 rounds
of Swiss. Just keep winning. Just keep
winning. It's fine. Just keep winning.
You don't think about the the future.
You don't think about top eight. You
don't think about like, you know, too
far forward. You just one round at a
time. Oh yeah, just win this one. Okay,
now I'll win this one. Yep.
>> And you just keep going and eventually
either wheels fall off or you win the
event. So there's really only two
options.
>> That's what I I always say. I'm going to
keep playing. The judges tell me to
stop. Yeah. the end I'll have a trophy
or I might have a tournament.
>> Yeah, there you go.
>> Going to play it best I can. So, we got
one more match for you to close out day
one here in Las Vegas and we're going to
go and see
Jojo Kfabe cards. Uh,
>> sponsor.
>> Oh, sure. They got it. So, playing
Ezreal.
>> Yeah, I mean this is a a fairly now
standard Ezreal build of the 3x main
bane. A lot of really juicy one-of- that
are being thrown into this one. We got a
beast below. That's the one that's going
to be able to bounce both sides. Kind of
nice in Ezreal where you can bounce back
the Ezreal Prodigy when you bounce your
opponent's large unit. And then you can
continue your draw engine. Or you get to
bounce yourself a Fizz back and be able
to replay that, which is really nice.
Just the single copy of Ross of the
Sunder. Pretty interesting. Not worrying
too much about stacking an overwhelming
amount of might. You can do that via
student. You don't really need to do it
via Rossa, but it's just like some
additional might you can slam for a late
game hold. Uh you have to find the slot
somewhere. And I think the morbid return
has been a really impressive card that
we saw from the Allen ZQ build uh that a
lot of other players have tried more and
more. Uh this is just two energy. Find
the unit that's most important for the
moment. And that can be the one of
Watcher, that can be the Rosa, that can
be the one of Mindsplitter, the one of
Beast Blow, that can be another Ezreal.
It can be another Fizz. There's so many
different options that you can find. And
it will be against an Aurelia. And
they've even got a Vex in the main
board. So Vex is really catching on. Vex
is the breakout card right from last
weekend. Uh really really cool card and
Aellia here and we see Divine Dance and
all the usual stuff uh counter spells.
How's the match up play out? So you have
Aelia kind of be able to do with those
really big shots uh whereas Ezra's like
more controlling role. What's it look
like? So what I will say is Aurelia for
a long time seemed like the blocker to
Ezreal. Really good match up for her.
She's playing a deflect unit baseline is
the thing she wants to play around.
That's annoying when you are playing as
Ezreal. She's got all these counter
spells for all the things that you're
trying to play. She's going to defy all
your cheap spells. She's going to not so
fast when you try and go for a rebuke or
do any of that.
Then Allan put three vexes in the main
board of the Ezreal deck. And I will say
that uh his teammate who was on Ezreal
nearly quit the deck. Uh so it does get
really difficult when the Vexes start
coming into play entering combat and you
as a like I would like to cast four
spells. Oh, that's going to cost me how
much? Oh, my life savings. Oh, my car.
Oh, my house. Ah, yes. I see you're
taking everything. So, that's kind of
where the issue starts to come up for
the Aurelia is because that Vex attacks
of an additional energy and an
additional power, very notably, uh, that
could cause a lot of issues. And we'll
see if Ezreal can kind of make that
work. uh if if not Aurelia maybe finding
some charms onto Vexes and being able to
kill them off when there's low runes
like the Vex is very integral to this
match up now. All right, so we're coming
in game number two here and we see uh a
Nation coming in with Tonka Temple and
then Jojo is actually Jonathan Job who's
a Magic player who's been playing Magic
for a really long time. So we're going
to come into game two. We're going to
see that Astation is starting up a game
in game number two. So Jojo behind the
eightball got to win two games in a row
here. Purple. These players are also 51
and one. So another pure win in winner
goes on to day two. Loser qualifies for
side events.
Yeah, a bit different from this Ezreal
build actually. Oblisk of power for
being on the play uh to just immediately
be able to cast Ezreal on your first
turn, but Jojo not even going to to go
for that. So just actually skipping the
turn and instead Aurelia is just going
to start the game four runes. And if we
just see something like a Stella, I mean
that's a massive early lead.
>> Yeah. So, the concern here is just not
spending a rune for for Jojo.
>> Yeah, I suppose so. I mean, I would
imagine I haven't seen a lot of oblisk
going first uh Ezreal. It's not been
super popular overall. Um but definitely
this feels like kind of nightmare
scenario, right? You you've played
Obelisk, you've skipped your first turn,
and your opponent has now gotten to
Stella turn one.
>> Yeah. And Stella Corn, of course, a
great draw engine. And if Astonation is
able to defend this with counter spells,
combat tricks, and then that card draw
starts to stack up, it can be a huge
factor. Yeah. So, back Jojo's way. Got
to think through. Of course, Asination
also saw no Ezreal on turn one. So, both
players kind of, you know, say, "Okay,
what's going on here? What are you
thinking about
as like is often in no rush, right?"
>> Yeah. No, I mean, it it really isn't.
You you kind of uh get to refund, you
know, wasting quote unquote wasting
runes uh by playing a lot of things for
free later with your Vex and Ezreal on
board. And you know, we are going to see
this is could be a very good reason to
not play the Ezreal on turn one. You
have the Vex in hand. You want to turn
two Vex. Uh however, you know, that is
still kind of feeling like, oh, skip the
turn and then immediately there's a
Stellicorn. That's still going to be a
bit of a struggle. But, you know, Stella
going in. We're going to see probably
Aseration be able to ready it via the
Blade Dancer and then move it back. Get
two cards drawn on this turn for the
cost of a power. Uh that's going to be a
pretty nice start overall.
um as you're not going to be able to
find an easy combat for the Vex on the
side of Jojo.
>> All right, so you are correct. Stellic
Horn's coming in sunken Temple. Going to
draw a card on the move. Take the first
point of the game. First blood and then
now many options for Masteration up a
game. Got to be feeling pretty good
and definitely need to tread carefully
here. Uh
stock deck good place to start. Look at
the top three.
They put it all together. The right
interaction at the right time. So, as
you've seen with these Aurelia decks,
there's a lot of different moving parts
when it comes to interaction and piecing
together the right ones to have on the
right streets is really, really
important. So, starting that uh that
path right now. I wonder if he's just
looking for shoes. I I feel like shoes
draw a card uh conquer to two.
Really powerful. I mean, you can even
reready the Aurelia Legend and then
still move the the Stella home after
that. There's like enough runes here to
kind of do all of that. Uh, draw three.
I mean, you spend two power. It's it's a
steep cost, but you go to two, you draw
three cards. I mean, you you end up just
really nice position overall. Uh, so I
could see shoes being something that you
really want to find. Other than that,
maybe like sneaky deck handhand, just go
to two and then you you let the deckhand
die and you still kind of ready the
Celicorn with some other spell that you
have in hand. Five runes, there's a lot
to work with here.
>> The rune costs in a match up like this
where things are going to be at a slower
pace aren't as important, right? Cuz
you're going to can build back up. So,
so we're going to see was boots the find
>> going sneaky. So, that's point number
two. So, now deck hand at the obelisk
still at the sunken temple. Both of
these are vulnerable to the Vex. And now
the question is, are we going to see a
back out on the Stellicorn or maybe just
going to try and fight in combat?
Fighting in combat against the Vex is is
quite difficult.
>> Best card would be flash. I think just
flash and you would just cast it now.
>> Um, but okay, just going to be a
guardian angel. No equip and run home.
That again would be very pricey. That
would be too power to actually be able
to move the Stella home. However, this
is just saying that it is fine if you
would like to kill all of my units. I
will develop the Aurelia on the next
turn with the guardian angel and we'll
we'll we'll go from there. Yeah. So,
this is a I mean almost surprising to
see, all right, you can just have my
units. The runes are more important.
This shows to me a player who has a
plan, knows how things are going to play
out, and it's like, okay, I know what I
need to do, and I'm going to play to
that. Stelico and Herder be damned. So,
Herder is going to hang out. Herder is
like, wait, you
>> you could have saved me cards. Yeah, I I
I drew you a card. You know, I'm just uh
hanging out his temple and things are
looking a little vexy. So, back Jojo's
way and Jojo now here's the converse has
to say, "Oh, so you're just giving me
your herder. You know, what are you so
excited about next turn uh that you're
willing to kind of just give me these
cards for free?" And uh both players
have a lot to work through.
>> Yeah. And the answer really is just uh
Aurelia on eight runes. Like I just get
to, you know, you have three runes open
after you play the Aurelia. generally
going to be able to keep her somewhat
safe, especially with the the guardian
angel. Uh, and so now we're finally
going to get to see that Ezreal come
down from the champ zone. Ezreal, Vex,
Exodiac assembled, all of the uh, spells
are now free. I think that's how it
works.
>> Do whatever you want.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. As soon as this
happens and you get a Vex into combat,
you can just kind of dump the whole
hand. Um, but yeah, going to start with
Callot and that is uh, just just free
free.99. So the Azer of course reduces
one power cost and the Vex went in
combat versus the other one. So Vex
really really powerful card kind of
overlooked a little bit and then uh last
weekend had a big breakout and uh does
some quite powerful stuff. Does make you
do things at a certain time. You know
we're in combat must be done during the
combat uh showdown, but you know that's
not too hard to do with these action
speed spells. So call it shot, look at
some cards and kind of get that train
rolling.
>> Yeah, I mean that's just the first of
many. We'll see how this turn ends up
going because the combats are just going
to be one. Everything's going to get
removed probably by the end of it. And
the question is is just what else can
Jojo leverage? And that is going to be
the card draw. That is going to be, you
know, what else can we continue to cast
through.
Usually you want to be able to go for
this when your opponent also has like a
a back row and you're kind of just like
removing all the work they've done,
right? Because you're getting to cast so
many different spells. But, you know,
bells with repeat that is just going to
essentially be for free. It does cost
one energy or one power when you have
both of these online. Um, you get to
decide because you can reduce it all the
way down.
>> So, this this reduces the the cost.
>> Explain the reductions and then uh
>> yeah, let me let me let me talk you
through Bellow's Breath when you've got
uh Vex and Ezreal cuz this is something
that people got to see kind of debuted
in Bolognia.
>> The way it works with Bellow's Breath is
when you pay a repeat cost, it becomes a
total cost of the spell. So this spell
with repeat is two energy and two power.
Then you're allowed to stack reductions
however you would like. So Vex is going
to then reduce it to one energy and one
power. And then because it's a repeat
cost, Ezreal can reduce either the one
energy or the one power. And that's how
you're actually able to cast Bellow's
Breath for zero energy and one power.
Now, in this case, he did cast it for
one energy, but you can cast it for zero
energy, one power. Even though Vex says
reduce by one energy, one power to a
minimum of one.
>> It's because she's not the one reducing
it to the zero. It's the Ezreal that is.
And I know that can be a little
confusing. I hope I've explained in a
way. If you don't get it yet, we'll
continue to see Ezreal all weekend. And
I think by the end of it, you'll fully
understand why these Bellis breaths are
being cast essentially for free.
>> I got it. There we go. We're good. So
Vex is in and uh we see there's a lot of
cards in hand for Jojo here. Um I can't
even count that I looks like nine or 10.
Uh so Ezreal back row now going back
asation waste. Astonation that turn
looked bad but Aston as said I I don't
care that turn's going to happen. You
know for the most part some combination
of things is going to happen. I'm going
to lose my stuff but I don't care cuz I
wanted this turn right here with these
runes. And now I get to see that plan
come to fruition and see what what's
going to happen.
Yeah, I mean it feels like it has to be
the Aelia turn. And we actually have
seen him separate his runes as a five
and a three. So I think I know where
that five is going.
>> I got a good guess, too.
>> Yeah.
>> And I would be wrong. It's a Vex. I'm
also wrong. So the one of Vex going to
have a Vex battle.
>> Yeah.
>> So now if two Vexes are in combat
together, they just they cancel out.
>> Yeah, I guess so.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Spec says, "While I'm in combat,
friendly spells cost one energy, one
power less to a minimum of one energy.
Enemy spells cost one power, one energy
more."
>> And we're going to see already and
equip. All right, so Vex is getting in.
>> This is kind of cool to see.
>> Yeah. And you know, it's it's kind of
funny because
>> originally
rebuke would have been able to be cast
if this was an Aurelia running in, not a
Vex, but because Vex is resetting the
Vex reduction from Jojo by being in a
mirror.
>> Listen, Cass Rebuke has now gone back to
costing two. The only way to beat a bad
guy with a Vex is a good guy with a Vex,
>> I guess. So,
>> Jojo's scratching the head a little bit.
All right. Is this what it feels like?
>> Yeah.
>> Am I the baddie? Is Vex the baddy?
>> So,
>> can I think it through? And uh
>> got to figure out how Jojo wants to
proceed. Now, now Jojo needs to be aware
of it. Uh the clock is at 18 minutes and
of course Ezreal not a very fast deck.
Uh a draw here would be catastrophic for
both players. Oh, it's in both players
out of day two. Uh so
I think this is just stack deck. I mean,
what else are we we what what else is
being paid for with one? I mean, is
Stupify?
>> Stupify would open up a trade.
>> Yeah, that would be good.
>> I guess the backs would just be it would
just be trade for guardian angel, but
>> yeah, that's worthwhile though.
>> Yep. So,
>> or you force a spell out of Nation.
>> Oh, hello.
>> Factory recall and the Defy. Okay. Wow.
So, going for the recall to bounce the
equipment. That's no good. Defy. So,
we're gonna see uh the Vex battle go to
the uh the player with only one Vex in
the deck.
>> And uh it's now two to one. That's a
great spot.
>> Vex is also mighty. A card can be drawn
here as well.
>> Factory Recall. Cool stuff.
>> Yeah, I think Factory Recall very
underrated purple card, very strong in
decks like Ezreal. It's a really good
tech against Urelia because bouncing a
Guardian Angel is effectively killing
Guardian Angel in this matchup often
times. Uh oh,
>> it's charm time. So the charm gets the
Ezreal, too. Astonation says, "I want
all of it. I'm taking all of it." And
now Vex is here by the Guardian Angel.
Joe got a lot of cards in hand, but that
was a great turn. Yeah, it doesn't feel
like the cards in hand are actually
doing much at this point. Uh you often
want you you need to have those units in
play to really make value of this. And
really, the Vex Ezreal combo is what's
going to allow you to play seven of the
10 cards you have in your hand on a
single turn, right? So by not having
that setup anymore, you have to redeploy
what I was expecting to be maybe another
Vex, but it is going to be a Mind
Splitter instead.
Splinter, you see Rebuke, Rebuke,
Discipline. That's uh not a great hand.
>> No, Rebuke is interesting here cuz like
it's it's tempo card and you know the
Ezra deck is not a tempo deck. It is
definitely a control deck. So how do you
feel rebuke is used in a matchup like
this? Uh, rebuke would generally just be
used to send home like
>> I I suppose
>> thousand tailed Watcher,
>> but realistically I feel like I would
side out some amount of rebukes in this
matchup and I'm seeing two right now. I
mean, that has to be for for Watcher. I
there's not a lot of good targets. You
you really can't cast Rebuke into Vex.
Like, let's be real. I mean, that that
is costing three energy, three power.
Uh, so yeah. What else are you sending
home in this Ezreal match up? I mean,
it's really thousand Watcher, but it was
a one-off that we saw. I know Astonation
doesn't exactly know that. Maybe he saw
Watcher in the last game. Maybe it was a
valuable card and decided to keep the uh
Rebes in. It's also possible that
there's just no other cards in the board
that feel better than Rebuke. They're
kind of stranded in the matchup.
>> Yep. That's kind of the the power of
playing a controlling deck like this
where you're kind of just sidesteping a
lot of the interaction in the format.
And uh you know, all of these units have
really good abilities when you play
them. So rebuking them can be painful.
Uh you know if it's a clutch tempo turn
sure bounce that minds spplitter but uh
>> if it's not it's coming back down to get
another card. So
>> so back out and uh we're going to see
mindsplitter. That m look pretty good.
So while the uh the turn went very well
for station on the previous turn. Uh
hands a little weak and now also face
up. So Jojo now stepping my unit in
play. A lot of cards in hand. Try and
start picking things apart.
>> Yeah. I mean, if he's got like another
Vex, that can start to really turn
things on again. Uh, we know it was one
of Ezreal. It was just the Champson one.
So, to get another one, we'd need to see
Morbid Return uh come through for the
side of Jojo, which we know is in the
deck. Uh, just has not been seen yet.
>> You know, when you're putting Morbid
Return to your deck, you got a plan.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> You know what you're doing.
>> You're returning a unit from your trash
unit,
>> right? Right. Yeah, at face value that's
like wait I I took a card out of my J
starter deck day one you know like but
uh when you're looking to use the late
game loops makes a lot of sense but
we're going to see another Vex.
>> So Vex is in
>> and
>> okay
>> yeah this is this is once again the
beginning of a very powerful board. Uh
Vex going to reduce the cost of
everything and going to be able to allow
this Raven Bloom to get fully juiced.
But because there is Vax on the side of
Aster as Nation, it gets to kind of
cancel it out in a lot of these spots.
So, you know, not going to be able to
get the craziest Raven Blooms uh like we
were seeing in Bolognia where it's
getting up to about 12 might and a lot
of uh a lot of the turns that you're
getting from the side of the Ezreal.
>> All right, so good news is that Senate
Temple will provide a card as hand was
not great. It was just to your bues. Uh
now we've got a card drawn for turn and
a card drawn for sunken temple. So, four
cards now.
This card on last turn, too, right? Just
three cards. So, all right, it's charm
time. Another Vex battle. And once
again, Astonation comes out on top of
the Vex battle. Two Vexes down.
>> I don't know that there was a better
card to get a drawn.
>> Yep, that was
>> I think that was quite literally the
best card in Astonation's deck to have
picked up there. Uh because the Vex
coming in, canceling out the effects uh
was immediately going to be quite
strong. I think Jared does have a rebuke
in hand. It feels like a very reasonable
rebuke at this point to try and slow
things down, slow the tempo down. Uh but
I actually think there's a not so fast
that was picked up by Ascernation on one
of these other draws, which is going to
defend against that. The other big
question would just be does Jojo have a
way to actually kind of kill off the Vex
cuz that's the better thing to do than
rebuke if but if there's no answer then
you might have to just go in that
direction cuz you need to cast all the
spells pre-combat. Uh you can't start
the combat with Vex and then cast a
bunch of spells. Everything has to be
played now.
>> You can. That's
>> But uh you know what?
>> You got to empty your piggy banks to
have empty your wallet out. You may not.
>> All right. So rebuke is the start. So
we're going to see Rebuke targeting Vex.
And uh as I was saying earlier, having
the right answers at the right time.
There it is. Not so fast, says
Astronation. I've got day two plans of
my own. So there goes the rebuke. Vex
standing strong.
Now, there's still a ton of cards in
hand for Jojo, but are they the right
cards is the question?
>> Uh, no, they're not. Yeah. Yeah. I It's
a great question that you're asking
here, Jim. But, uh, when I'm looking at
it, I'm seeing like a wage is a pain.
That feels kind of a little a little
goofy. Uh, I mean, I think it it can
work out if there is still something
like a frigid touch. You know, wage is
frigid. You still just kind of deal with
this Vex, get it off the board. Uh, and
when I say off the board, I mean uh off
the battlefield and back to the base
because of this uh
>> this guardian angel. So then you'd need
some kind of backline access to go along
with it. Something like a bellow's
breath uh which is not quite there.
>> Do end up seeing a Fizz potentially to
be deployed here. I I also saw an Arcane
Shift. So Fizz Arcane Shift is a
potential here to try and get through
some of the removal to get some recast
through. Maybe just fizz the uh the
factory recoil. Bounce this to try and
permanently remove the Vex. It's a
decent idea.
>> There you go. All right. So, trying to
solve his Vex problem now. It's been a
problem for a number of turns. Jojo
says, "Get that guardian angel out of
here. Vex is uh all alone in sunken
temple.
>> It looks like asation been that guardian
angel. That should be back in hand.
Factory recall is just a bounce effect.
So, we'll see if they catch that and
he's able to grab it back. If not, that
could be a major loss."
>> Yes.
>> This that or here or here.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
That's what I'm
>> So there's Stupify.
Raven Bloom is doing what Raven Bloom
does and just learning and learning,
getting bigger and bigger
and your stack deck.
A lot of game actions.
All right,
stack deck.
I mean, the big thing is is you just
have to be able to outmite the Vex now
if you're not going to have an actual
removal spell. Raven Blooming at five,
uh, you know, that's even, but you if
you start the combat, then Astonation
now is going to have Vex online. You
know, there's a pair of rebukes, right?
That's going to be able to deal with
some of this. And they get to be cast
for one rune, uh, one energy and one
power.
>> One power rebukes are quite nice.
>> Oh, yeah.
So, student comes in. Student is a five,
right? Oh, but yeah, Max is a four
thanks to Superfly. So, so
>> Oh, I forgot to super. Yeah, you're
right. Absolutely.
>> So, we're going to see the rebuke and
student goes back. Of course,
mindsplitter is still there. Now,
getting your mind splitter splitter
rebuke is not too bad, you know. So,
certainly can it seeds the point for the
turn. Uh, but can come back next turn.
You know, Astonation is at five. We'd be
going to six potentially, but this game
doesn't really feel point racy.
>> No, not really. I think Azer Nation is
going to be really happy just going to
six after this double rebuke. And then I
I I would assume
I mean there's not much development that
can be done cuz right you've spent so
many runes here going down to three
runes. You're going to go up to five.
You could develop technically the
Aurelia Fervent uh to go alongside this
Vex, but then you're opening yourself up
to just being singularity and kind of
losing the game on the spot. So it may
just be Vex goes home and hangs out and
you actually just pass and keep as many
uh runes and cards available to protect.
Vex does go home. And now we're see I
mean this is the uh the area of the game
that Ezra wants to be in. Right. We're
approaching the uh the late game. A
bunch of cards, a bunch of runes, a
bunch of options.
Again though, I'm starting starting to
get player anxiety on that clock. Played
a lot of control decks in my day and uh
the clock has been my mortal enemy many
a time.
>> I mean, we're not playing a game three.
That is that is for sure. If we do get
into that game three, it is going to be
a race to score a few points at the
start to see if someone can win the game
or if we end in a draw. Neither of these
players wants the draw. The draw means
that their run is over. They they need a
win. This is a must-win scenario at five
wins, one loss, one draw. The only way
to advance to a day two is with a win.
>> Yep. Five wins, one loss, and two draws
is exactly one point short. Just it's a
little bit short. You don't want to go
home, come up a little bit short. So,
we're going to see Vex, sorry, Fizz get
into combat over at the Sunken Temple
and go up to two. Raven Bloom go up to
three. Our first big offensive turn from
Jojo.
And guess who's back?
>> Back.
>> Back again.
>> Mindsplitter.
Tell your friend what you got in hand
there. Uh, Astronation.
>> Oh. Oh, I'm sorry. Never mind. You got
to make me look wrong, you know. Come
on. So, we got uh Beast Bellow, right?
>> Beast Below.
>> Beast Below. My My bad. Sorry. Haven't
seen that card very often, you know. So,
got to come in. It bounces uh one of
your own units and an enemy unit. So,
>> you didn't get Ezreal at your pre-ift,
did you?
>> I did not. No.
>> Yeah. Classic Pre-Rift allstar here. The
beast below.
>> Yep. So, that'll send Vex back to hand.
And of course, bouncing Fizz is a little
bit of value. This deck is built on
value.
And now, uh now I think this one through
and see if there's any responses.
>> I mean, if there's not so fast, you can
just stop this.
>> Yes. And it that would also keep the
fizz in play too, right?
>> Yeah, I believe so. It should counter
the bull effects.
>> Yep. So,
>> all right. So, that's no good. And now
we see almost a big tempo swing uh where
Jojo has kind of gone from sitting back,
taking the lumps, uh to now being on
both battlefields, bouncing things, and
getting really well set up.
Back Astronation's way. 6 minutes left.
I'm going to keep looking at it, folks.
I know you are, too.
The important question is, are players
looking at it?
>> Yeah. Now, is it time for Aurelia
instead of Vex? You do actually have to
start beating some larger might numbers
with the Beast Below being on board?
Feels like the answer is yes.
>> That's tough cuz Vex is a slow card to
develop.
>> Yeah.
>> So now if you slip behind a little bit,
when are you even going to get that back
into play? So here's Aurelia. Two runes
left over and just a pass. Wow. So
double hole for Jojo. We are now
five to six, right? Six.
>> Five to six.
>> Okay. Five to six. And uh still the
mindsplitter in hand for Jojo. So, it's
tough to have a setup turn where you
know your opponent's going to mind
splitter you. Uh but that is the world
we are in right now. Jojo in the
driver's seat. Here comes that
mindsplitter. Going to take a look at
the hand. Going to play it over to the
obelisk joining the river balloon
student. And let's see that hand if uh
Yep. Okay. So we got we got
>> wow
>> two of x.
>> That's a horrible hand. That is a snap
pick of a discipline which makes perfect
sense. Great selection by Jojo. Deny the
the card that draws a card.
>> Yep.
>> But also it's the only buff card in the
hand as well. So it's kind of also in
two ways the the best card that
>> Yeah. Only only targeting effect two. So
now the hand of just kind of you the
second Vex the first Vex already in the
spot was a little iffy now that we're in
this stage of the game. The second Vex
is almost blank and for sneaky Doc hands
got no place to sneak to.
>> Not very sneaky.
>> So, a lot of work to do here. Uh, Asian
up on points but not on board. But
Aurelia fervent as always coming in and
right off the top
we're going to see some plus two minus
two.
>> Yep. Divine dance very good. End of the
day, it's a plus three minus two when
it's a really fervent.
>> Rex, we're see Arcane Shift. The shift's
going to come in. Oh boy.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh boy. So, Arcane Shift is going to
banish
>> the beast.
You have to pay the
>> I don't I don't have to pay for the
three damage.
>> Okay. So, right now they're talking
about uh so the arcane shift also has
the three damage effect too. Uh the only
unit that as in play is the Aelia. It
has deflect. So the question is uh does
the deflect cost need to be paid if the
shift to damage isn't relevant? The
answer is yes.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh so
but that is going to bounce uh the
Aurelia which is crippling which is
absolutely backbreaking.
>> Yeah. At this point with Jojo still at
five going to hold the seven.
>> So they're just double checking the
ruling.
>> Yeah. So, what he is doing is
>> he's saying I decline paying for the the
deflect. Uh I just won't deal three
damage.
>> Which which is Yeah, that is luck.
>> Well, that that works for abilities and
not for spells. We had this I put a game
uh yesterday uh with Frank Scar, one of
the Riot developers, and and this
happened and he played it as we we just
said, but apparently he checked the
rules and uh you have to deflect.
>> That's great on spells and abilities.
So, this is this is a good old reflexive
triggers falling star thing that has now
since been changed.
>> It's I don't know exactly.
>> We will we'll go past it. We'll go past
it.
>> Either way, the
>> you learned last night that that did
need to be paid for and this is uh we're
all learning together, right? Um
>> with a million runes in play. Not super
pertinent either way. So, we see hold up
to seven. Jojo says go.
>> 2 minutes and 35 seconds on the clock.
Looking great to take game number two
here. And then game number three. Oh
boy. Game number three. What's going to
happen in game number three? Which which
deck? Which of these decks can score
three or four points very very quickly?
>> Uh Aurelia.
>> Yeah. Well,
>> yeah, there are sneaky deck hands that
we did see, right?
>> That's right. Yeah. So, I think if
you're as you just like getting out of
this game and trying to get into game
three with with a at least a minute or
two to start.
>> Uh yeah, I would I would absolutely I
don't know that you're actually
>> based on what we know of the hand,
right? It's two vexes. Is is a sneaky
like you're you're just not winning,
>> right?
So here's I mean guardian angel so far
not threatening either battlefield uh
when uh Jotto's holding threatening to
hold both at seven now as far as the
extra turns go if we're in time before
we start game three. Do the players
start game three?
>> Uh no. My understanding is no.
>> Okay. So so in that case I mean
>> yeah I guess you just stay in this game
for another minute 30. I mean that
doesn't feel great at
>> No. I'm saying that you you back it up.
shuffle cards fast as possible. Try and
get the game started before that clock
hits zero.
>> Uh to have a chance at maybe scoring a
few fast points. Of course, when you are
in turns, there are three extra turns.
And if a player is winning by two
points, that player wins, otherwise it
is a draw. So, Aurelia is a deck that
can score quickly with sticky deck hands
and stuff. But we're going to see a
combat here. So, we're going to see uh
Guardian Angel is going to
Okay, that's it. All right. So can't
stop both holds. 1 minute and 3 seconds
left. And now the question is game
three. We see Dreaming Tree and Void
Gate as the battlefields. Uh all players
looking a little unhappy here. And are
we going to get to start into a game?
>> All judges over
>> tough spot.
>> Yeah, it sounds like they were talking
about just start it as fast as possible.
See if you can get you know your your
three turns in.
>> Okay. So it sounds like the that they're
able to start the game. Might have been
a little more time in the clock than it
showed. You know, our coverage clock and
the actual table clock might be a little
bit off. So we see
tide turner coming in. And uh that's a
this tie turn is an important job to do.
That's called score two points.
Raven balloon for Jojo. And then as far
as uh our turn counter if we were in
turns or not, I can only assume
>> how nice I have.
>> We're in turns.
>> What? We're just going to both.
>> Okay. Okay, so this game start actually
started in turns.
>> Okay,
>> so turn zero, turn one,
>> right? So we had
>> on turn two.
>> So we're on on turn two with this tide
turner. Um
>> turn two.
>> So the problem is that so if Astronation
can conquer deckand defend win two.
>> Yeah. I mean it would have to be exactly
to fine dance.
>> Yep.
>> So it's deck hand to find dance and then
there's a world
>> maybe a hidden card as well, right? Like
you know add on top of that. And if it's
not that then I mean there is a defined
dance in hand actually notably.
>> Okay so here comes T turner. Point
number one is not that relevant. You
must win by two in extra turns to be
declared the winner otherwise the game
will be a draw.
>> Oh you know what? There was a tide
turner in hand as well. That would also
work. So you tie turner use a ready the
one that you targeted at the dreaming
tree. Run it into void gate. You're
holding both. There's a defian dance in
hand. I mean it's possible.
>> Okay. So, we were saying we wanted to
get this game started for a reason, and
this is definitely the reason. So,
tense moment here. This is our last game
of the day, round number eight, regional
qualifier, Las Vegas. Jim and Cass in
the booth. Thanks for joining us, of
course, as always to try and send
another player into day two for a chance
to take down the whole tournament.
>> Yeah, we get EST card, get some serious
prize money,
>> life on the line
>> and the glory. Glory is pretty cool,
too.
>> All right, so we got a charm uh starting
on charm on Ravencl. So,
this is uh just going to be a straight
trade barring a spell. This is risky.
>> Yeah, but we saw the define dance. So,
you get to dance here,
>> deal with this,
>> and I I believe I saw another tide
turner in hand.
Okay, so Defiant Dance goes off. We got
a plus and a minus. Here's a stif of
five. So, Defiant Dance puts the Tide
Turner to four. The Raven Bloom down to
zero. Then, uh up to one off the off the
spell. There's Tie Turner.
>> Little switch. Little ready coming in.
That's point number two.
>> Now, the question is, Jojo, can you stop
one of these tie turners? You've got one
turn.
>> End score,
>> right? And score. Correct.
And that would just keep it as a draw,
but instead Aston Nation going up 200 on
the points.
>> That might be punching his ticket
towards day two.
>> Wow. Unbelievable. So, starting the game
in turns uh in a spot where I was so
worried that was going to go to a draw.
Of course, both players would be knocked
out with a draw, but instead as Nation
is able to take it down, starting the
game in turns, and it becomes a sub
game. it becomes simply okay this is not
a normal game ribbound this is a game of
can I get to two before turn three end
and wow that is what a way to end the
day uh in extreme fashion yeah I mean
the Aurelia deck is going to be heavily
advantaged when we get to those kind of
uh situations being a sneaky deck hand
deck and it wasn't even the sneaky deck
hand it was actually in fact the tide
turners the two of them being able to
turn the tides of this one and send
Aurelia and Astonation into day two
still with a hope and a gasp towards
that top eight being at X1 and one.
>> Yeah. And that's part of the problem
with the Ezreal deck, of course, is the
deck is extremely powerful, but you do
not have infinite time.
>> You got to play fast,
>> right? You know, there's so many game
actions. You go so deep every game. Your
plan is to see your whole deck and you
know, you're morbiding back and just oh
my god, so much stuff. So, uh that is
part of one of the pitfalls of playing
with deck despite it, you know, of
course, winning last weekend and being
great. Uh but we're going to hop down to
a winners interview with Astronation and
find out if he can even talk after that
game.
Never mind. We got to decline the
interview. And honestly, I don't blame
him. Uh because after that game, I would
probably just go lay down and take a
nap.
>> Yeah. Yep. Time to rest up for day two.
>> Yeah. Uh and yeah, and a nap is very
well needed. Uh a good night's sleep, a
nice good dinner. Very very well-earned
asation. Uh just a a crazy crazy finish.
Really really awesome stuff. And uh
>> I need a nap too watching the game.
Yeah, I mean it gets so crazy, right?
You have so much complexity between the
Aurelia deck and the Ezreal, the Vexes.
We actually see the countervex coming in
from Aster Nation to try and deal with
all of the Vexes that are going to exist
in the Ezra deck. Because as I was
saying at the start, like when the
Ezreal is piloted extremely effectively,
the Vex can basically close out the
entire game against Aelia. It can make
it almost impossible to play the game,
and you can see how suffocating it can
become. But when you cancel it out by
playing around your own Vex instead of
worrying about the deflect from your
Aurelia, don't worry about that. Play
around the Vex your own. Don't allow
Ezreal to just cheat out every spell
from hand. Play seven cards a turn. That
can at least maybe buy you the space.
And we saw it get there for Aston
Nation. I mean, you won game one. We
didn't get to see exactly how that
happened, but I have to assume somewhat
of a similar game plan as we saw in game
two where it was such a close match.
>> Yeah, really cool stuff on Vex. So,
we're going to take a very, very short
break. Get our final standings in order
so we can show you who's the top of the
standings, who to watch tomorrow. So,
don't go nowhere. Come right back.
Hey, hey, hey.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. N.
All right, folks. Welcome back to the
booth here at Regional Qualifier in Las
Vegas. Jim Davis, Castanova. We've had
an incredible day. Uh so many awesome
games, great matches, really, really
cool decks. Uh and the best part is we
have to do it again tomorrow.
>> Oh, hell yeah.
>> Yep. So, we're working on our standings,
trying to get those final standings, get
a few straggler matches, you know, kind
of get them finished up. We got to get
out of here, you know. So, uh we get for
as far as day two goes, we get to look
forward to five rounds of Swiss tomorrow
where our players will be, uh continuing
to battle it out for those coveted top
eight slots as we see here Sunday. Fire
on Swiss Top 8 starting at 11:00 a.m.
Pacific, 2:00 p.m. Eastern. So, make
sure you are tuned in and ready to go
here on Twitch or on YouTube. And uh
nothing like day 2 play. You know,
players who are playing for a variety of
goals. You have players who are of
course playing with topic in the
tournament. Uh even if folks, you know,
slip out, maybe they take that second
loss or a third loss, still possibly
playing for best dubs and other great
prizes, too. And uh it's just great to
see you getting those late rounds of a
Swiss, the winning. It's where the tiers
start coming out, the hugs start coming
out. You know, for some players, you
know, it might be maybe their fifth top
eight or sixth top eight across various
games. And for some players, it's that
first big achievement, that first chance
to kind of be on stage and play for that
trophy. And then they start playing
their hearts out in that top eight
untimed rounds where they are able to
think through all the lines, try and
find the best outs, and you get to see
that high high level of game play not
stopped by needing to be playing around
that clock as well. Yeah. which is
really really cool to see. You know, it
things are always just more intense and
special when so much is on the line, you
know. So, in those top eight matches
where it is untimed, you can you can
feel the pressure, you know, and the
players are, you know, they're playing
against their opponent, they're playing
against, you know, the weight of being
on camera in top eight knowing there's
there's money up top, there's trophy. It
can be life-changing to win a tour for
tournament like this, you know, where
you now you are on that trophy shot,
you're holding the trophy, you know, and
uh they can you can build a brand around
that which really really cool and no one
can take that away from you as it's your
trophy.
>> Take a look at at Shawn Dolly Dewali
winning Houston and from there being
basically able to go full-time Riftbound
just leaning into it. He had played
plenty of other card games before, had
done well in other card games before.
It's not like he was a slouch in some of
these other card games, but Riftbound
kind of gave him that opportunity where
he he took it, ran with it, and he's
been building a community around himself
as well. And he's been having some
really great performances in in
Bolognia, still had a great performance
there. And here, if I'm remembering
correctly, he was X1 going into that
last round. So, he'd already made day
two and is still going to be fighting to
try and, you know, continue that legacy,
make another top eight potentially.
>> Yeah. And that's the really cool part
where making top eight of an event like
this is so difficult. is such a huge
accomplishment, you know, and but when
you get to go home with the trophy, it's
very tangible. You know, you get to show
maybe friends and loved ones who, you
know, know you're playing playing a
competitive card game cool, but don't
really understand. Well, you say, "Oh, I
I came in fourth place and won a best
of," they go, "Okay, that that's cool.
Sure." You say, "I won the whole darn
thing." You show up a trophy. And
grandma goes,
>> "That's pretty cool.
>> That's not too shabby, right?" So,
something really, really cool and very,
very exciting. Love seeing players
getting in and playing for that. So,
while we get those standings ready for
you, I want to remind you your journey
starts at Nexus Nights at your local
game store. These are happening all over
the country and all over the world. And
there's so much fun to play kind of a
casual light environment uh where the
focus is around, you know, kind of just
learning and kind of getting into
competitive play, which is so cool. Love
my Nexus Knights. And you were saying
you love yours also. Oh, hell yeah.
>> And uh any store you want to shout out
your own personal home store?
>> Yeah, I go I usually play at Riftgate.
Riftgate Games. Cool.
>> Salt Lake City.
>> Very very good store. Absolutely love
Were they called Riftgate before
Riftbound or is that absolutely
coincidence? Cool. That's a that's some
good branding there, right? Little
future proofing. And of course,
>> then it's time to take the next step
from your Nex Knight to your summoner
skirmish, which is kind of the bridge
between your Nex Knight, which is a
little more casual, and of course the
regional qualifier here in Las Vegas and
many other spots as well. Skirmishes
give you a chance to win that coveted
first round buy. So, you can take round
one off uh and have the comfort of
knowing, all right, round one's good.
Kind of get the jitters out. And that's
great. High competition, lots of fun as
well. And all the info for these are on
uvsgames.com/rofbound-organize-play,
you can find local stores in your area.
If you can use the eventfinder to find
when the events are happening and get
involved in your community. Great stuff.
And we got a road map here. So, what
events are coming up? Well, I mean,
these are the ones that we just had.
We're in Las Vegas right now and we're
going up to Lil next in April. Well, you
know, the month March, we're skipping a
lot of it, but going to Lil then Atlanta
to close out Spirit Forged before
Unleashed hits the shelves on May 8th.
Unleash. Yeah, new sets are always super
exciting. You know, as we've seen, Spear
Forge changed the metagame so much. So
many new things happening. Really,
really cool. Uh, now we're going to pop
over all the way down to Sydney, uh,
which is very, very exciting. Up to
Vancouver in Canada in May. We got Urk
in June and then Hartford right near me.
Of course, I'm from New York, so that's
a little bit of a cross in the Long
Island Sound for me over to Hartford.
And then the release of Vendetta.
>> Yep. And Vendetta is going to bring us
in line with the Chinese release. So,
that's going to be the first time that
we get that global release going for
Vendetta. And also, we heard about those
uh competitive uh competitive uh colors
coming against each other, right? The
red and green uh going to be in the same
decks. You're going to have purple and
yellow and orange and blue for the first
time ever in Vendetta, which is very
exciting. And the vendetta ones are
going to be in Barcelona and Singapore
that we're going to get to go to for
that. Barcelona is a nice spot. I've
played many big card tournaments there.
It's a great city. Really, really cool.
Then we got the release of Radiance in
October. And then Los Angeles, kind of a
the hometown Riot event uh to end out
the year. Uh that's going to be a really
really fun one. I'm would not be
surprised if Riot pulls out all the
stops for that one.
>> Oh, absolutely. I I'm very very excited
to to head back to LA. I want to go to
all the stops. I want to make it to
every single one. you know, either play,
commentate, everything. It is so much
fun going to these events for fountain.
I've been having a blast. You know, even
being in Bolognia last week and getting
to play it was is an absolute ball.
Yeah, just being involved is is so cool
in whatever way. And that's kind of the
cool part about these events is that you
can come and you can buy some cool stuff
with the merch place. You can play some
side events, you can play some sealed,
play some team with your friends, or of
course compete in the main event and try
and do your thing. So, I think we're all
set here uh with our with our final
standings. Let's take a little look and
see what we got. So, we have six
undefeated players. Wow, that's weird.
Allen's undefeated again.
>> Yeah, very interesting. Prismaticism,
Allen's EQ. Uh 8 and0. I've seen this
one before uh a couple of different
times. Uh even on Thursday, there was a
2K at an LGS local here to Las Vegas and
Allen and Pris showed up and made it to
the finals and split. Uh yes. Uh so they
they have just been winning non-stop. Uh
in Bolognia, no different than here in
Vegas. Allen and Pris making themselves
main stays in the early stages of
Riftbound. Yeah. Um just so cool to see
that the the skill ceiling in this game
is so high and it it's rewarded so much,
you know. So uh really really cool
awesome awesome magic player. But you
have eight undefeated players and uh
really awesome stuff. And tomorrow we're
going to see uh we got six undefeated
players. What about down to to three
perhaps and uh on from there to King of
the Hill and we can see who's going to
take down the trophy, take down the
championship and of course best of cards
too. Lot of a lot of fun things to look
forward to. So I think that's going to
do us here do it do it for us here in
Vegas. Jim Kasanova of course the team
we'll see you tomorrow for some day
action. Let's crown a champion here in
Las Vegas.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.